Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wir machen Podcast. Also Salon heute. Heute ist Salon.
Heute ist Salon. Wir sprechen über das Buch Angststillstand, warum die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet von Richard David Precht. Das ist ja ein Thema, das uns jetzt schon seit Monaten verfolgt in diesem Podcast.
Wie findest du das Tier da vorne drauf?
Ja, was ist das für ein Tier? Das ist ein Axolotl und das hat selbstverständlich was mit dem Buch zu tun.
Das ist aber noch keine Larve. Es gibt ja verschiedene Tierstadien, die uns gleich vorgestellt werden. Ein bisschen mehr als eine Larve.
Ja, genau. Aber wir sind so eine Axolotl-Gesellschaft offenbar. Wir schauen uns an, was das bedeuten kann.
Also ich bin kein Axolotl, Richard. Okay, warte.
Aber du bist ja nicht unzufrieden mit dem Buch an sich, oder?
Also, das Buch kommt sehr nah ran an die Sachen, die mich interessieren.
Ja.
Hegemon. Wer ist Herr Hegemon? Wer bestimmt hier, wer sich für was, wo rechtfertigen muss und so weiter. Und ich möchte es ihm nicht verübeln, dass er natürlich über die Stränge schlägt. Wir sind weder eine Generation noch ein Milieu ökonomischer Natur. Und deswegen sieht er naturgemäß Sachen anders. Aber noch eine Unterscheidung. Ich bin Ossi, er ist Wessi. Der Ausspruch, uns fragt ja keiner, den kenne ich von vor 20 Jahren aus dem Osten. Ja, ich habe vor einer Weile einigen Jahren überlegt, ob ich vielleicht der Alten Republik ein ostdeutsches Kapitel gebe mit dem Hinweis. Schaut euch an, da seid ihr in zehn Jahren. Hier sind wir.
Ja, ganz interessant.
Also so ein paar Sachen begegnen mir wieder, wo ich mir denke, ah ja, ist das jetzt eine westdeutsche Haltung? Okay.
Ja, da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Was mich vor allem interessiert, ist, dass er sich zum einen mit rechtlichen Fragen auseinandersetzt, dass er sagt, da hat sich gar nicht so viel verändert, dass er sich aber mit der subjektiven Meinungsfreiheit befasst. Er stellt sich ja die Frage, wie kann es sein, dass so viele Menschen inzwischen sagen, dass sie sich nicht mehr frei fühlen, ihre Meinung zu äußern? Woher kommt das? Denn das ist ja erstmal was, was dann Umfragen hergeben. Und man muss sich fragen, wer ist dafür verantwortlich? Kann man überhaupt einzelne Akteure dafür verantwortlich machen? Was ist das für ein gesellschaftliches Klima, in dem man eigentlich sagen muss, rechtlich hat sich nicht viel verändert, bis auf so ein paar Dinge bezüglich Politikerbeleidigungen und so etwas. Das schauen wir uns dann auch genauer an. Aber dass man trotzdem sagt, hier hat sich radikal etwas verändert, nämlich dass die Meinungsfreiheit ganz stark abgenommen hat, wird subjektiv empfunden, dass da Zahlen genannt werden, die wirklich erschütternd sind. Und danach zu gehen, finde ich hochinteressant. Und es ist, glaube ich, eine sehr gute Debattengrundlage, denn das Buch ja übertreibt mitunter, aber es ist nicht eine Polemik. Es ist nicht eines dieser Bücher, jetzt wird aber hier mal aufgeräumt und sonst was, sondern es ist tatsächlich eine sehr klar argumentierte Hinführung.
Aber wir können ja schon mal eine Frage voran stellen, für alle die, also das Buch hat ja noch keiner gelesen, es kommt ja heute erst raus. Und man kann sich ja die Frage stellen, was ist eigentlich das treibende Problem gerade? Und welches greift Richard David Precht auf? Entweder dem Titel nach Angststillstand, also Leute zucken zurück, halten sich die Hand vor den Mund und sagen, denken, das darf ich hier nicht sagen. Oder aber alle, ohne weiter drüber nachzudenken, hauen nur noch ihr Zeug ins Internet raus, wie kleine Kinder plappern sie drauf los. Und erstaunlicherweise steht in diesem Buch beides als Problem drin.
Ja, das ist es.
Und das wollen wir gleich mal auflösen. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Das ist nämlich sehr streitbar.
Ja.
Diese Frage, die ich jetzt gerade, diese Unterscheidung aufzulösen, die ich...
Ich kriege es auch noch nicht ganz zusammen. Denn es gibt beide Phänomene und das ist wirklich bemerkenswert. Aber bevor wir dazu kommen, ist es ja so, dass zu Meinungsfreiheit auch gehört, dass man sich kritisch äußert über kulturelle Erzeugnisse. Hin und wieder tun wir das ja hier im Salon besonders. Jetzt muss ich dich selbstredend fragen, wie gefällt dir das neue Album von Taylor Swift?
Ich habe das Cover gesehen, wo sie in der Badewanne liegt.
Oh Gott, was kommt jetzt für eine Antwort, Stefan?
Und dachte mir, super Fotoidee.
Ja.
Im Sinne von oben unten, sichtbar, unsichtbar, aber es ist ja Wasser, aber man sieht so eine Wasserkante. Also es war irgendwie ein interessantes Foto. Olli, unser Fotograf hier in Frankfurt, hat mir gestern ein Bild von Heidi Klum in Strumpfhose am Hauptbahnhof gezeigt. Und ich möchte hier eine Petition starten. Wenn schon Fotos dort, dann lieber so wie Taylor Swift. Ja. Und nicht wie Heidi Klum. Also es gibt ästhetische Unterschiede, möchte ich sagen. Ansonsten, ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe gesehen, dass du hast Clips dazu mitgebracht. Ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt. Ich habe noch nicht reingehört.
Ach so. Gut. Mir geht es jetzt gar nicht darum, die Musik.
Hast du schon reingehört?
Ich habe mal reingehört, ja. Denn es gab den Streit darüber, ob diese Songs anderen berühmten oder nicht so berühmten Songs gleichen, ob sie etwas kopiert hat. Ich kann das nicht beurteilen. Ich habe jetzt nicht so tief reingehört und kann das auch nicht in der Weise miteinander vergleichen, dass ich sage, ja, genau hier kann man es exakt sehen. Es gibt Ähnlichkeiten, die sind mir so beim Hören, bei Spiegel Online wurden ja verschiedene Lieder so gegenübergestellt, dann für allen einem Ähnlichkeiten auf.
Spiegel Online hat eine Liedervergleichsanalyse gemacht, sehr gut.
Allerdings ist es ja so, dass diese, man verzeihe mir diese Formulierung, sehr generisch produzierte Popmusik durchaus sich immer mehr angleicht.
Generisch produziert ist noch besser als generiert.
Wodurch solche Ähnlichkeiten sich viel stärker ergeben. Das ist, glaube ich, schon ein generelles Problem. Ich glaube, es ist falsch jetzt so zu tun, als sei Taylor Swift diejenige, die die anderen Leute beraubt, um sich das anzueignen, um Hits daraus zu machen. Sondern ich glaube, dass wir eine große Angleichung in der Popmusik erleben. Was man auch daran sieht, dass man oft die Lieder, wenn man nicht großer Fan ist und das alles 100 Mal durchgehört hat, dass man sie kaum noch voneinander unterscheiden kann, von welchen Künstlern sind sie gerade. Und da ist meine bescheidene Popmusikerfahrung oder mein Wissen über die Popmusik, zum Beispiel auch der 80er oder der 70er Jahre andere. Da weiß man sehr genau, dass hier jetzt gerade dieses Lied von Tina Turner ist und das ist das Lied von Cher und das würde man nicht mal zufällig vertauschen. Ich will das nur sagen, dass sich hier eine große Angleichung ergeben hat. Und woher die kommt, wissen wir ja, denn wir haben ja dieses wunderbare Buch von Liz Pelly besprochen über Spotify. Und das ist ein wichtiger Grund für diese Angleichung, die stattfindet. Womit ich jetzt nicht sagen will, Taylor Swift ist einfach nur der Spotify-Algorithmus. Sie hat sicherlich Talent und all das. Das ist ohnehin nicht meine Musik. Deswegen will ich mich da gar nicht tiefer mit beschäftigen. Ich glaube nur, diese Debatten, die es da jetzt gerade gibt, müssten viel grundsätzlicher geführt werden. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass wohl einige Taylor Swift-Fans wiederum enttäuscht sind von diesem neuen Album. Jedenfalls jubeln sie es nicht so in den Himmel, wie sie das mit vorherigen Alben getan haben. Was jetzt mir aufgefallen ist in den sozialen Medien, ist, dass andere Influencer, Creator sich dazu äußern, dass es Kritik an dem Album gibt. Und mitunter ist es ja notwendig, auch die Kritik zu kritisieren. Aber ich glaube, man muss es ein bisschen intelligenter machen, als zum Beispiel hier diese Variante Rafi redet.
Also dieses neue Taylor Swift-Album, ich finde es gar nicht mal so gut. Ich finde es sehr gewöhnlich, super langweilig. Und die Lieder sind uns auch nicht wirklich mal so gut. Sag mal, geht es noch? Das ist eines der coolsten Alben, die sie je rausgebracht hat. Schreib du erst mal während der Welttournee, die zwei Jahre lang geht, wo du, keine Ahnung, 150 Auftritte hast, zu je dreieinhalb Stunden Livegesang, Performance und Tanz. Schreib da mal ein Album. Aber nee, nee, nee, ohne Songwriter. Das macht sie nämlich alles selber. Sie schreibt die Texte selber, sie komponiert selber, sie macht alles selber. Die Ideen fürs Musikvideo kommt alles von ihr. Also mach du, kleiner Pimmel, ihr das erst mal nach und sei damit mal halb so erfolgreich. Dann können wir noch mal reden, okay?
Ja, das ist natürlich Unsinn. Wir kennen das immer.
Kann man sich zu solchen Videos nicht mehr äußern.
Bei den Filmkritikern wird dann auch immer gesagt, ja, dreh du erst mal einen Film. Ich sage, ich habe noch nie eine Kamera in der Hand gehabt, weiß ich nicht, wie das geht. Ich weiß aber, wie ein guter Film aussieht.
Ich will uns zurückschwenken auf eine Argumentation, die ich jetzt vorschlage. Ich war die vergangene Woche in Dissabon und habe dort meine Kirchen-Rondtour gemacht. Wahnsinnig tolle Bauwerke, 15. Jahrhundert. Man ist ganz plötzlich Seefahrernation geworden, superreich. Und dann, drei Generationen später, war schon wieder alles vorbei. Und diese Zeit wurde ausführlich genutzt. Es gibt dort ein sehr großes Kloster, Santa Vincenzo Pipapo di Faro oder so. Da hängen die Patriarchen in der Galerie. Also da kann man sich typischerweise so wie im Kaisersaal hier nochmal die großen Köpfe der Stadt anschauen, die natürlich alle auf Anfrage und mit Gnade des Papstes und so weiter, die Geschäfte führten. Das heißt, für die hat man Gebäude gebaut, von denen wir ja schon gelernt haben. Die sind eigentlich für den Klang hergestellt worden. Also große Kirchen vor allem. In diesem Kloster gibt es also eine sehr große Kirche. Ich war zweimal da und beim zweiten Mal wurde durch Zufall Orgel gespielt. Ich habe also diese Kirche so wahrgenommen, wie sie eigentlich gedacht war. Sie sieht doch schön aus und so, aber sie klingt vor allem wahnsinnig toll. In dem Moment habe ich so gedacht, du bist am Rande Europas. Im Grunde gibt es diese Kirchen, die kleinen Kirchen, hauptsächlich, weil die Leute einfach, wir fahren morgen auf See, auf See sind wir in Gottes Hand. Vielleicht kommen wir zurück, vielleicht nicht. Wir gehen vorher nochmal beten oder so. Also man ist, trotz super Reichtum, ist die Bevölkerung, ist jeder einfach komplett im Schicksal. Man weiß einfach gar nicht, wie geht es hier weiter. So und dann gibt es für die wenigen, die so ein paar kleine Generationen oder sonstiges haben, die Möglichkeit, in so einer Kirche Orgelmusik zu hören. Und der Unterschied vom 15. Jahrhundert zu heute ist, die AirPods Pro 3 von Apple stellen ja den Ton im Grunde so da, wie das wirklich in der Kirche klingt. Das heißt, wir haben eine extreme Entgrenzung. Jeder darf diese Musik, die ihm gefällt, überall hören. Und ich finde, jede auch nur Anflüge von Argumentationen zu ach, hör doch das nicht oder was auch immer so, finde ich falsch. Und von daher, sie hat ein neues Album gemacht. Ich blicke da auch nicht mehr durch. Anscheinend kommt es jeden Tag irgendwie so ein Album oder so. Es soll einfach jeder überall hören, egal wie er mag, dass irgendwelche Leute da Meinung darüber haben, dass das irgendwie klingt wie, ach, das ist doch ganz schön redundant und so. Ich meine, die Leute lesen G-Jack, finden sich klug und stellen gar nicht fest, dass der G-Jack 2025 klingt wie der G-Jack 2005 und selber schon Flaggjatzvorwürfe gegen sich selber erhebt.
Was er sagt, was er sagt.
Das gilt in der Musik halt auch. Man darf das trotzdem toll finden.
Also er kritisiert aber doch jetzt hier, dass Leute die Musik kritisieren. Und zu einem öffentlichen Diskurs gehört doch eine Debatte über Kunst. Und bedeutet auch, dass man eine kritische Debatte über Kunst führt, weil sonst können wir das Reden aufhören und dann jeder darf hier hören, was er will. Also ich kann mir auch den ganzen Tag Heino anhören. Das wird mir ja niemand verbieten.
Das ist aber ein sehr wichtiger Punkt. Jeder darf hören, was er will.
Ja, aber das muss man ja nicht nochmal eigens betonen. Also ich habe jetzt auch... Also ich bin ja... Also er parodiert das ja am Anfang. Er parodiert ja am Anfang, dass Leute behaupten, so gut sei das Album nicht. Und es ist doch gut möglich, dass dies nicht ihr bestes Album ist und dass diese Taylor Swift Fans und auch einige Musikkritiker sehr wohl Recht haben, wenn sie sagen, das sind nicht besonders originale Lyrics und das ist auch nicht sehr gut produziert oder was auch immer.
Ich stelle die Frage, wer will das wem sagen und warum?
Ja, das ist einfach der, der die Debatte über die Kunst, die geführt wird über Literatur und sonst was. Das machen wir ja im Salon auch. Weil dann kann man auch sagen, jeder nimmt das Buch von Richard David Precht, liest es für sich und dann schweigen wir alle dazu. Es muss doch zu einer Gesellschaft gehören, dass man sich darüber austauscht. Das heißt ja nicht, dass ich jemanden dadurch verbiete, irgendetwas zu hören, sondern bedeutet ja einfach, dass ich doch in einer Auseinandersetzung kann. Und da, wo die Kunst des Unterscheidens beginnt, beginnt in meinen Augen auch erst der richtige Kunstgenuss. Nämlich dann weiß man auch plötzlich, warum man vielleicht etwas sehr gut findet oder anderes nicht so gut. Oder für welche Zwecke, welche Musik geeignet ist. Es wäre ja auch jetzt fahrlässig zu sagen, ich stelle heute einen Komponisten vor, Telemann ist sein Name. Dass ich sage, das ist aber nicht geeignet, um in Mallorca Party zu machen. Das wäre ja eine völlig falsche Kategorie, die ich da anlege. Das heißt, ich kann nicht falsche, sondern ich muss richtige Kategorien anlegen, um Dinge zu bewerten, um damit in der Differenzierung Klarheit zu verschaffen über mich selbst, über mein Hörverhalten, über aber auch die Kunstproduktion. Und deshalb, glaube ich, ist es wichtig, dass man sich nicht dieser Kritik so verschließt. Und was ich jetzt gerade feststelle in den sozialen Medien, ist, dass gerade sehr reichweitenstarke Leute sich der Kritik verschließen und sich über jede kritische Äußerung jetzt so lustig machen. Oder wir hören uns das mal an, was Rizzo...
Aber lass mich noch auffechern kurz.
Ja.
Das Urteil über Musik ist naturgemäß ein anderes als über ein vor allem ausgeflackt politisches Sachbuch. Dazwischen wäre irgendwo Literatur, darunter wäre Shizheq Originalphilosophie, vielleicht sogar Muttersprache. Das heißt, wenn man sich einer Kritik verschließt in Sachen Musik, geht relativ wenig kaputt. Ich finde, sehr viel driftiger wäre das zum Beispiel beim Film, weil es beim Film sehr viel einfacher ist, in diese Ästhetik etwas unter zu jubeln. Weshalb du ja Filmkritiken machst mit dem Hinweis auf, achte mal auf die latenten Sinnstrukturen in diesem Film. Schau nicht nur darauf, wie dir die Faustkämpfe gefallen.
Genau.
Und das droht aber bei Musik. Also ich finde auch, Musik ist so eine Art...
Gerade bei Musik jetzt wieder. Denn wir haben ja bei Spotify gesehen, wie also ein Algorithmus dafür sorgt, dass plötzlich die Komposition dem angepasst wird. Dass sofort so eine Hookline da sein muss, dass am besten das Lied schon mit dem Refrain beginnt, dass es in zehn Sekunden erschlossen wird, damit es nicht weiter geskippt wird. Das verändert ja die Produktionsbedingungen. Ich sage hier ganz deutlich, es gab immer Außeneinwirkungen auf Musik. Wenn man eine Oper in Paris im 19. Jahrhundert veröffentlichen wollte, dort zur Uraufführung bringen wollte, musste man Ballett komponieren in die Oper hinein. Ob das passte oder nicht, es gehörte dazu. Das heißt, solche Produktionsbedingungen gibt es immer. Aber jetzt, in einer Weise wie das bei Spotify monopolartig ausgeführt wird, unterstützt dann noch von den Algorithmen der Reels bei Instagram, der TikToks und all dem, können wir sagen, dass das ein großes Problem ist für die Musiker, weil sie immer mehr sich dem angleichen, womit die Kreativität eigentlich geschmälert wird. Und wir bekommen übrigens von unserem Freund, den du eben schon genannt hast, Oli, die bekomme ich fast täglich jetzt irgendwas per Instagram geschickt, von Musikern, die mit Bands auftreten, die sich unglaublich darüber aufregen, wie wenig sie über Spotify verdienen, wie sehr sie nicht mehr dem Algorithmus entsprechen und deshalb aussortiert werden und, und, und. Ja, und wie prekär auch die Lage der meisten Künstler ist, die Musik machen. Und deswegen finde ich es auch richtig, gerade den Mainstream zu kritisieren, dass man auch wieder deutlich macht, es kann auch noch andere Musik geben, womit man ja nicht den Leuten abspricht, dass sie nicht Taylor Swift hören können, aber man kann Unterschiedsschiede machen.
Ja, also da muss man aber schon drauf achten, dass das eben nicht dazu führt.
Naja, also ich glaube, man muss jetzt die erfolgreichste Sängerin aller Zeiten.
Nee, darum geht's ja nicht.
Nicht so ganz groß davor beschützen, dass sie jetzt bald nicht mehr gehört wird.
Es geht mir nicht um die Erfolg, es geht mir nicht um Taylor Swift, es geht mir um die, die Taylor Swift hören. Die hören Taylor Swift, weil sie ihnen gefällt. Und zwar, und das ist halt so diese Art von Kunst, die ich ja gerade aufgefächert als ein bisschen special, weil man da einfach auf Play klickt und nicht weiter drüber nachdenkt, weil man nicht in einem Klassenraum ist, weil man gerade nicht in einem Seminar ist, sondern weil man gerade aus der Schule kommt und sich nachmittags entspannt.
Hat absolut seine Berechtigung. Das Problem ist ja nur, dass wir einen sehr starken Diskurs über Taylor Swift in den Föjetons haben, in entsprechenden Podcasts, in denen uns Taylor Swift als die große Künstlerin verkauft wird. Was du jetzt gerade schilderst, das ist Gebrauchsmusik. Dann sind wir ja in einer ganz anderen Sphäre plötzlich unterwegs. Nur wenn jemand vor mir sitzt und sagt, es gibt zwei große Sänger, der eine ist Fritz Wunderlich und der andere heißt Heino, dann würde ich Widerspruch anmelden und sagen, also Heino hat auch sein Talent für das, was er da macht im Bierzelt, aber das ist nun jetzt nicht Fritz Wunderlich.
Ich ermundere also hier alle Schüler, die nachmittags aus der Schule kommen und sich entspannt zu Hause einfach Taylor Swift anhören. Sagt einfach nie, das ist Kunst, das ist eure Gebrauchsmusik, sie gefällt euch, das ist das Einzige, was zählt. Haut rein.
Wir hören jetzt einen Reel von Rezo, Rezo zu Taylor Swift. Nein, der sich jetzt äußert, denn auch Nina Truba hat ein neues Album veröffentlicht. Und es gibt eine Kritik in der Zeit an diesem neuen Album von Nina Truba. Und diese Kritik nimmt sich jetzt Rezo in einem Reel vor. Das neue Album von Nina Truba ist gräßlich.
Nina Truba hat ihr neues Album veröffentlicht.
Hallo, hallo.
Das hier ist eine Rezension.
Die Frau heißt Juliane, die das geschrieben hat.
Ich lese jetzt einfach vor, warte. Truba-Songs über Dosis und Unsicher sind kaum zu er tragen.
Diese junge Musik. Gräßlich unhörbar. So furchteinflößend grausig, dass man einen baldigen Hörsturz erfleht. Das ist keine aus stilistischen Gründen gewählte Hyperbole, sondern im Wortsinn gemeint.
Okay, nein.
Warte, wie drücke ich das aus?
Ich meine das nicht als hyperbole, was als nächstes kommt.
Wie Kunst wirkt auf Leute, ist halt extrem subjektiv.
Ich weiß, das ist crazy, ne?
Deswegen ist es so wertlos, was du tust, Julian, in deinem Leben.
Und das ist nicht als hyperbole gemeint.
Zu sagen, dass man etwas gräßlich und scheiße und unhörbar findet, das kann man machen.
Aber wenn man dafür mehr als fünf Minuten investiert, das Leuten klar zu machen, dann ist man ein Opfer. So, das ist die Art der Auseinandersetzung jetzt. Ich habe dann dagegen einen Kommentar bei Instagram geschrieben. Und du weißt, was passiert, wenn man resokortisiert, dann ist er sofort in deinen DMs und erzählt dann Nein, es gibt ja noch einen Stream, in dem ich das viel differenzierter gesagt habe und mehr gesagt habe. Und denke ich, ja, schreibe ich ihm mehr, aber das interessiert mich ja nicht. Du hast das ja als einzelnes Real so veröffentlicht, wie es da ist. Und ich finde das im höchsten Maße fahrlässig, was hier passiert. Man kann immer darüber diskutieren, ob eine Kritik treffend ist oder nicht. Und man kann darüber diskutieren, ob das jetzt die beste Kritik der Welt ist, die hier in der Zeit von Juliane Liebert verfasst wurde. Aber hier werden Sachen verdreht. Sie beschreibt erst mal das Phänomen. Nina Tschuba sagt, was sie schon gemacht hat in ihrer Karriere, bezieht sich dann darauf, dass sie nicht ihrem eigenen Stil weiter gefolgt ist. Sie sagt, es ist irrsinnig schade, dass Nina Tschuba nicht, etwa von Wildberry Lillard ausgehend, ihren eigenen Stil, ihren eigenen Sound weiterverfolgt. Stattdessen klingt sie inzwischen wie alle anderen. So, das ist ja erst mal nicht eine Generalabrechnung. Juliane Liebert hat auch nichts gegen junge Musik. Sie ist, ich habe mir das dann angesehen, ich kannte sie nicht, sie ziehe...
Bei dem Satz von Rezo gerade, man wünscht sich ein Ohrsturz herbei. Man sieht, steht das da drin?
Ich komme jetzt dazu. Sie beschäftigt sich ja in der Zeit hauptsächlich mit Popmusik und lobt auch moderne Popmusik von Rihanna Taylor Swift und was weiß ich. Es ist nicht grundsätzlich so, dass sie junge Musik ablehnt. Und sie schreibt dann allgemein, nicht über Nina Schuber direkt in einem Absatz, leider ist ein Großteil der marktgängigen Popmusik heute präzedenzlos, schrottig und überflüssig. Das ist keine aus stilistischen Gründen gewählte Hyperbel, sondern im Wortsinn gemeint krässlich unhörbar, so furchteinflößend grausig, so abgefucht, packt und austauschbar herzlos und geistlos, dass man einen baldigen Hörsturz fleht, sich aus dem Taxi werfen will oder den Supermarkt niederbrennen möchte, indem man den ganzen unerträglichen Mist zwangs hören muss. Dies ist eine Polemik gegen eine bestimmte Art der Popmusik, die ich in gewisser Weise teilen kann. Mich beschäftigt Popmusik nicht so sehr, weil ich sie einfach kaum höre. Aber das ist etwas, was wir feststellen können und was simuliert. Jetzt kann man sagen, das kann man anders ausdrücken, warum sich Rizzo daran stört, dass sie hyperbel sagt. Nun, die Autorin ist auch noch Lyrikerin. Ihr wird dieser Begriff sehr leicht über die Lippen gehen. Und sie findet es nun, dass es kein gutes Album ist. Dass sie das hätte anders begründen können noch, tiefer begründen können, alles geschenkt. Also Kritik an der Kritik kann man üben. Nur was hier passiert, was Rizzo hier tut, ist zu sagen, wenn du dich länger als fünf Minuten mit sowas auseinandersetzt, dann bist du ein Opfer. Bedeutet also, die tiefer gehende Auseinandersetzung mit Kunst ist überhaupt gar nicht gewünscht. Fühlt es toll oder lasst es. Aber denkt nicht länger drüber nach. Schreibt auf keinen Fall einen Verriss oder so etwas. Und das ist wirklich eine ganz merkwürdige Unkultur, die wir jetzt in den sozialen Medien erleben. Eben ja auch den Clip, den ich da schon abgespielt habe. Dann wird gesagt, ja Taylor Swift hat eine Welttournee gemacht, schreib du da mal nebenher ein Album. Da muss ich denken, ja, Francis Ford Coppola hat 20 Jahre an seinem Film, der kürzlich erschienen ist, gearbeitet. Er ist trotzdem scheiße geworden.
Also, was soll ich sagen? Rizzo hat offenbar an einem Tag, in den letzten Tagen, gehörte er offenbar zu den 700 Millionen Leuten, die auf Instagram ein Video veröffentlicht haben. Mit dem wir uns jetzt hier im Podcast befassen. Aus Gründen, dich, also ich verstehe das, was du sagst, ich kann es trotzdem.
Nein, was ich erlebe in den sozialen Medien ist jetzt immer mehr, dass man gerade die erfolgreichsten vor jeder Kritik nochmal besonders beschützen will. Und das ist eine eigenartige Sache, die jetzt da stattfindet. Ich bin sehr dafür, dass zur Meinungsfreiheit auch die Kritik der Kritik gehört. Nur, was hier stattfindet, dass man jetzt Leute als Opfer tituliert, die sich die Mühe machen, einen Verriss zu schreiben. Und denen vorwerfen, dass man das dann doch gleich lassen kann, ist doch keine Herangehensweise. Also das ist doch ein völlig irrsinniger Diskurs. Ich bringe dir noch ein drittes Beispiel jetzt. Ein drittes Beispiel, du hast mitbekommen, Caroline Wahl hat einen Roman veröffentlicht.
Hat sie ihren Preis jetzt bekommen?
Sie hat den Preis nicht bekommen. Den Preis hat übrigens Dorothee Elmiger bekommen. Deren Roman habe ich ja hier vor zwei Monaten im Salon empfohlen.
Und alle, die ihn gelesen haben, fanden ihn toll. Elena hatte noch mal einen Textauszug in der Insta-Story. Ich habe den kurz gelesen. Ich hatte mich ja auch gewundert, wie viel das ja fast Inception-artig, konjunktiv, Kaskaden kann man bauen. Ich muss sagen, ich habe es nicht so richtig genossen, diesen Textauszug zu lesen, aber wahrscheinlich steckt da da irgendwie was drin.
Wir kommen jetzt aber zu Caroline Wall. Die hat jetzt diesen deutschen Buchpreis nicht bekommen, ist auch nicht dafür nominiert gewesen. Sie hat ihren dritten Roman veröffentlicht, Die Assistentin. Dieser Roman kam zum Teil überhaupt nicht gut an. In der Literaturkritik hat man sich sehr zurückgehalten. In der Literaturkritik generell in Deutschland wird ja vor allem jetzt portraitiert. Besucht man Autoren zu Hause oder auf Spielplätzen oder sonst wo oder beschreibt so andere gemeinen Phänomene. Aber die Kritik ist ein bisschen in den Verruf geraten, vor allem der Faris. Und übrigens auch Juliane Liebert schreibt ja zum Thema Musikkritik. Trotzdem sind die Rezensionen zu aktuellen Popstars meist wohlwollend. Oder sie vermeiden es weitgehend, über eine Inhaltsangabe und ein paar Phrasen hinaus etwas zu Musik zu sagen. Also das ist etwas, was wir glaube ich bei der Literatur auch immer mehr erleben. Wir erleben das auch in dem Sinne, dass dann so kurze Hypes entstehen. Also ich hatte eigentlich vor, im Salon zum Beispiel den Roman Lazare mitzubringen von Elio Biedermann. Ich habe hundert Seiten gelesen. Es ist nicht zum aushalten. Ich halte das wirklich, auch wenn es so überall gelobt wird, für kitsch, für parfümierte Literatur. Und wer der Leopard gelesen hat, braucht Lazare nicht mehr zu lesen. So deswegen habe ich mich dagegen entschieden. Ich bin auch dafür klare Urteile. Aber was wir jetzt bei Caroline Wahl erlebt haben, ist, dass also sehr viele aus ihrer Leser-Community, die den Roman nicht toll fanden und sich auch daran gestört haben, wie sie das Hörbuch einließt, dass das nicht gut klingt, dass sie nicht sehr gut ihren Text lesen kann.
Da habe ich Ausschnitte gehört.
Und du hast Ausschnitte davon gehört und wirst das bestätigen können. Daraufhin auch gleich so Verteidigungswellen. Ja, das sind Idiolekte und manche Autoren lesen, aber sie können nicht so wie ein Tagesschau-Sprecher sprechen. Dann wurden Leute wie Heinz Strunk, Benjamin von Stuckrad-Barre oder Martin Walser genannt. Stimmt alles. Die könnten alle nicht in der Tagesschau sein, weil sie sowieso nicht, weil er nicht mehr lebt. Aber ich würde sagen, bei allen drei kann man sagen, wenn sie ihre Texte lesen, dann gewinnen die Texte dabei. Bei Caroline Wahl, finde ich, ist das nicht der Fall. Das ist ein Urteil, das man treffen kann. Möglicherweise sehen das andere anders. Was aber dann so gekommen ist, ist, dass natürlich viel Hass auch ausgeschüttet wird und sich irgendwelche Leute eschaufieren darüber, warum Caroline Wahl in 22 Bahnen über eine prekäre Familie schreibt, wo sie doch selbst nicht aus einer prekären Familie kommt. Das ist dieses identitätspolitische Gedöns. Damit müssen wir uns jetzt nicht beschäftigen. Das ist ja eine irrsinnige Argumentation. Jedenfalls gibt es Kritik, positives, negatives. Es ist jedenfalls so, dass dieser Roman jetzt der dritte, nicht so erfolgreich zu sein scheint, wie die vorangegangenen beiden. Jedenfalls ist sie ja eine Autorin, die gerade so zu den erfolgreichsten in Deutschland zählt. Alles gut, aber man wundert sich dann, mit welchen Pappkameraden da gearbeitet wird. Caroline Wahl war im Podcast von Jagoda Marinic zu Gast, Freiheit Deluxe. Und wir hören jetzt mal Jagoda Marinic, wie erst sie, zu diesem Streit, um den Roman und um Caroline Wahl zu sagen hat.
Folgen gerne nutzen, um die auch zu spiegeln und es vielleicht noch mal hier auch vorzusetzen, dass du endlich so einen Literaturbetrieb, ich habe vorhin Frauen skeptisch, aber Frauen ängstlich, sie fürchten Frauen, völlig herausforderst, weil du einen Millionen Erfolg hast, den man einem Daniel Kehnmann vielleicht gönnt, mit seinem Duktus und mit seinem Habitus, aber eben nicht an der Carowal. Und ich finde es geil, dass du es machst. Und ich will es auch als Frau umgekehrt sagen, ich bin auch in diesem Literaturbetrieb gesessen. Und wenn du jetzt sagst, es provoziert manche, dass du viel willst, dann frage ich mich so, alter, die Frau formuliert, was sie will, wo sie hin will, was sie sich für sich wünscht. Welche Ziele sie, Entschuldigung, Caro, welche Ziele du dir für dich setzt, warum provoziert das andere?
Hat der deutsche Literaturbetrieb ein Problem mit erfolgreichen Autorinnen? Ich habe nicht den Eindruck.
Ich auch nicht. Ich habe gestern gesehen, dass der Preis von einer Frau an eine Frau übergeben wurde und sehr viele Frauen sich darüber gefreut haben und so weiter und so fort.
Der deutsche Buchpreis ging häufiger an Frauen als an Männer. Wenn man sich mal durch die Bestsellerlisten, Taschenbuch, Belletristik, Bundesbuch, Belletristik pro Chur, Belletristik klickt, dann wird man feststellen, dass zu 50 Prozent Frauen, zu 50 Prozent Männer dort sind. Manchmal ist es sogar so, dass mehr Frauen als Männer da sind. Wir erleben, dass die großen Literatursendungen, sowohl das Literarische Quartett, wie der Schweizer Literaturklub von Frauen geleitet wird. Wir können wirklich nicht behaupten, dass der Literaturbetrieb ein Problem ist für erfolgreiche Frauen. Das ist einfach Quatsch. Nur wird hier immer diese identitätspolitische Karte jetzt gespielt, wenn man Kritik äußert, beziehungsweise mitunter ist diese Kritik auch mit Helme voll. Also ich finde, das muss man auch nicht machen. Ich finde, das hilft auch der Kritik nicht weiter. Ich habe ja mit Ole sehr ausführlich über 22 Bahnen gesprochen. Und das haben wir glaube ich sehr analytisch getan und sogar ohne Polemik, obwohl ich doch ein Freund von Polemik bin. Aber ich will zum Beispiel einmal erinnern, dass es den Schriftsteller Takis Bürger gibt, dessen Debütroman unglaublich gefeiert wurde. Dann hat er irgendwann einen Roman veröffentlicht, in dem es um den Holocaust ging. Dieser Roman wurde verissen noch und nöcher. Man hat ihn dann auch so dargestellt, das ist dieser Everybody's Darling, der sich an jede Buchhändlerin zum Selfie anschmiegt und und und. Also man hat genau so, wie man über Caroline Weil jetzt herfällt, hat man das auch mit Takis Bürger gemacht. Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich das gut finde. Ich will nur sagen, dass das stattfindet. Wir haben heute ja einen Autor mit Richard David Precht, in dem, wenn es einen Artikel überhaupt noch mal in der Zeitung über ihn gibt, immer erwähnt wird, diese schönen Haare und wie er da wieder eitel sitzt und all das. Also es ist nicht so, als würden die mit Kritik geschont werden. Und um einfach noch mal das ein bisschen zu verstehen, was hier passiert, wir konzentrieren uns die ganze Zeit auf diese Super-Super-Superstars, die natürlich auch wichtig sind für Verlage, weil sie die Verlage oft mit Querfinanzierung funktionieren. Immer weniger funktioniert das aber für die Verlage, weil diese Erfolgsautoren enorme Vorschüsse bekommen. Es ist ein Wettstreit, wer bekommt den höchsten Vorschuss, und sie können den gar nicht mehr einspielen. Das hat sich ja jetzt in der Vergangenheit bei mehreren großen Autoren gezeigt, dass sie Rekordvorschüsse bekommen haben, und da konnten sie jetzt nicht einspielen, die Verlage werden immer nervöser. Am Ende wird der Druck nach unten abgegeben. Der Roman von Dorothee Elmiger, ich wage mich so weit vor zu sagen, ohne den Buchpreis, ohne diese Nominierung all das, hätte der sich vielleicht, wenn es gut kommt, 10.000, 12.000 Mal verkauft. Ein sensationeller Roman. Wir können davon ausgehen, dass in dieser Saison viele sensationelle Romane weit unter 10.000 verkäuft liegen werden. Das ist die Situation gerade am Buchmarkt. Und die Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie funktioniert so, dass wir uns jetzt nur auf die Stars ausrichten und dann die ganze Zeit darüber reden, wie wurden sie irgendwo behandelt und hat der Literaturbetrieb da ein Problem mit einer Bestsellerautorin. Ich will mal in Erinnerung rufen, wie mit Autoren in der Vergangenheit mit Männlichen umgegangen wurde.
Ich sehe, es kommt jetzt Marcel Reichranditzki, was ich natürlich sehr gut finde. Ich möchte nicht in ihn hinein quatschen mit Argumenten, die ich eigentlich jetzt loswerden möchte. Also jemand macht ein großes Album und groß im Sinne von ist schon erfolgreich, ziemlich sicher von allen Beteiligten wird ein nächster Bestseller und so. Das sind ja die super, super, super Stars, die du gerade meintest. Dann verhalten sich Leute dazu. Ich möchte jetzt gerne einfach alle Grenzen verwischen. Wenn Taylor Swift ein Album macht, kann man das anhören und sich zu dieser Musik verhalten. Aber wir wissen alle, heute geht es ja nicht nur um die Musik, die man für sich alleine hört, denn man hat ja Internets und First, Second, Third Screens und kann überall seine Meinung bekunden. Also gehört zum Phänomen dieser Album Veröffentlichung, dass sich Leute dazu verhalten und man möchte gerne diesem Diskurs mit sein. Also jemand macht eine Musik und du forderst, diese Musik darf, muss kritisiert werden. Wir brauchen diesen kritischen Diskurs über, warum ein Album veröffentlicht. Ich sage jetzt, jemand macht ein Album, ja Kritik daran muss möglich sein. Wenn diese Kritik daran kommt, gilt für den, der diese Kritik kritisiert, genau dasselbe.
Genau.
Jeder, Rezo der Typ, jeder darf irgendwelche Kritiken sich rausnehmen. Ich finde ja auch, Rezo hat einen inhaltlichen Fehler gemacht. Ich brauche keine Aufklärung, Rezo, schreibt mir keine DM. Wenn in diesem Text eine allgemeine Aussage gemacht wird über die Popmusik und dann schaltet man ja lieber die Ohren ab, dann sagt das ja gar nichts über das Nina Tjuba Album aus, denn das ist ja nur Anlass für diesen Text. Wenn man also mit dieser Kritik gar nicht umgehen kann, weil man nicht in der Lage ist, einen Text richtig zu lesen, weil man nicht versteht, dass Absatz 3 vielleicht einen Brückenschlag, Absatz 2 drin hat und gar nichts mehr so viel mit Absatz 1 zu tun hat, ist das durchaus ein Problem. Das kann man auch kritisieren. Nur auch diese Kritik ist dann wieder genauso berechtigt, wie jeder andere Kritik auch. Also von daher, wenn jemand ein neues Album macht, einen neuen Film, wie auch immer, Feuer frei macht, Reaction Videos zu Reaction Videos von Reaction Videos, jeder darf alles machen.
Das hat sich ja ganz verändert. Wir sind nicht mehr in der Gatekeeper-Struktur. Die Literaturkritik oder auch die Musikkritik ist schwächer denn je, weil plötzlich die Leute, die zum Beispiel Musik produzieren, sich zu Wort melden können. Sie können sagen, nein, nein, das ist aber so und so gemeint, oder hier trotzdem kauft mein Album, was auch immer. Diese Möglichkeit bestand früher in dieser Weise nicht. Zudem gibt es Communities, Leserschaften, die sich äußern können. Nur, das war ja dann auch im Fall von Caroline, war es so, dass da sehr viele aus ihrem Publikum gesagt haben, aber den Dritten finde ich nicht so gut, was man ja auch akzeptieren kann. Ich finde auch manche Regisseure toll und dann enttäuschen sie mich zwei, drei Mal nach Gang. Das ist so. Das kann so sein. Das mag auch daran liegen, dass man nicht immer auf einer Höhe abliefern kann, was auch immer daran liegt. Nur muss man das mal akzeptieren und dass dann hier so gesagt wird, ja mit Daniel K ist das anders.
Ja, also ich will da auch noch mal. Sie sind hier überall so kleine Unschärfen drin. Die Karolin Emke hat gerade, also klar, die hat die Genderkarte gezogen, aber ja in Bezug auf und also nicht, dass es Frauen da gibt in dem Betrieb, sondern dass sie sagt, das ist die Jagoda Marinic. Oder Jagoda Marinic, sorry, nicht diese Unschärfe eingebracht, aber für mich ist das alles, also die Jagoda Marinic hat gerade gesagt, du hast dich als Frau hingestellt und eine Forderung gestellt, nämlich einen Preis zu bekommen. Und da würde ich sagen, zeigt mir den Mann, insbesondere Daniel Kehlmann, der das jemals gemacht hat. Daniel Kehlmann hat dieses Land verlassen, Europa verlassen, der lebt irgendwo in New York, weil er einfach seine Ruhe haben will und sagt, ihr ist mein neues Buch, macht daraus, was ihr wollt. Dass dann alle ein Theaterstück daraus machen und wie auch immer. Damit hat Daniel Kehlmann relativ wenig zu tun. Ich habe jedenfalls keine Titelthesentemperamente vor Augen, in denen er den großen, ich bin ja gerade im Interview, also ich nutze die Gelegenheit und fordere einen Preis. Genau das gibt es nicht. Und das hat aber Caroline Weill gemacht. Und es ist natürlich total erwähnenswert, weil es auch total funny ist, dass jemand so einen Preis für sich einfordert. Und da Instagram-Stories dazu macht. Und das muss man natürlich mit Absicht nicht kritisieren dürfen, sondern darüber muss man sich lustig machen dürfen, weil es einfach super funny ist.
Ja, also wenn ich jetzt sage, gib mir die Sendung von Karen Mioska, dann muss ich damit rechnen, dass Leute sich darüber lustig machen. Das ist einfach so. Und bei Daniel K. Mann ist es ja auch so, dass zum Beispiel sein Roman F so leidlich gut bei der Kritik kam. Ich erinnere mich, wie da Elke Heidenreich sich unglaublich darüber aufgeregt hat. Ich erinnere mich, dass er das Drehbuch geschrieben hat zu Felix Krull, zu der neuen Felix Krull-Verfilmung. Und ich erinnere mich dann an einen Kritiker, der wirklich getobt hat, wie grauenhaft dieser Film ist. Und dieser Kritiker, weißt du wer das war? Das war ich. Also es ist nicht so, als würde man mir Kritik sparen.
Ein Punkt, den muss ich jetzt unbedingt noch machen, bevor wir malstreichen. Ich finde, um es jetzt ganz auf die Spitze zu treiben. Ja, ich habe gerade Carolin Wall kritisiert dafür, dass sie einen Buchpreis für sich fordert, was ja im Subtext bedeutet, ich finde mein Buch selber so gut, bitte gib mir einen Preis. Ich finde, nachdem ich jetzt auch große, große Kunstmuseen in Lissabon gesehen habe, und die ja sind natürlich voll stolz auf ihren Surrealismus und so weiter, den sie da zeigen können, und haben dann gleich gezeigt, okay, nicht nur wir auf der iberischen Halbinsel, sondern es gibt das auch in der Schweiz und Ding, da haben sie sogar einen Transatlantic Drift, da haben sie drin, um dann noch mal Jackson Pollock, der auch mal so ein paar figurative Sachen, aber halt total kubistisch und so. Ich finde, wenn man in diese Museen geht, heute, ich mache einfach ein Foto von diesem riesen Text an der Wand und lasse mir den dann vorlesen, so, ne? Ich finde, diese Bilder hängen zu sehr für sich alleine. Mich nervt das total, dass ich an ein Bild herantrete und da steht einfach untitelt. Zum Sinne von, der Künstler sagt, das sollst du selbst entdecken, ich gebe dir gar keinen Beipackzettel, ja? Ich finde, Beipackzettel sind jetzt ein Qualitätsmerkmal. Also, ich finde nicht, jemand sollte für sich einen Preis fordern.
Da kannst du ja wieder auf die Dokumenta gehen, da bekommst du ja wieder alles erklärt.
Dokumenta ist, hier klären wir jetzt mal aus. Ich finde, wenn jemand Kunst macht, Musik macht, ich habe das sehr genossen, auf diese Art fair zu sein, hier in Frankfurt, also einfach in der hinterletzten Messerhalle, ist halt so eine Ecke. Jeder Künstler mietet sich für 3000 Euro am Wochenende so einen Stand und bringt ein oder zwei Kunstwerke mit, ist selber vor Ort und erklärt, worum es hier geht. Man kann Rückfragen stellen und so weiter und so fort. Und das finde ich zum Beispiel, das kann man jetzt auch mal nicht nur Kritiker, auch die Künstler selbst können jetzt mal ein bisschen Show-Atelier machen.
Ja, können sie machen, aber ich bin generell nicht so für diese Beipackzette-Kunst.
Ich bin für lebendige Kunst. Bei uns im Vöter gab es immer die Literatur und das literarische Leben. Und wir haben einen Reader-Scan gemacht und weißt du, was die Leute lesen? Das literarische Leben.
Ja, und da bin ich nicht so dafür. Ich mag auch nicht so gerne Portraits lesen, sondern ich lese lieber Kritiken oder Debatten. Wir erinnern uns jetzt an das literarische Quartett. Wir sind in den 90er Jahren. Günter Gras hat seinen großen Wende-Roman veröffentlicht, Ein Weites Feld. Man hat Marcel Reich-Ranitzki dann schon, bevor die Sendung aufgezeichnet wurde, auf dem Spiegelcover gesehen, wie er den Roman von Gras nicht nur im Text verreißt, sondern zerreißt. Jetzt hören wir noch einmal Marcel Reich-Ranitzki dazu, um mal zu sagen, das ist jetzt nicht so ein Angriff gegen erfolgreiche Autorinnen, nur das mit drastischen Worten um sich geworfen wird.
Gib zu, du spielst das auch aus Unterhaltungszwecken.
Ganz richtig. Und ich sage auch hier gleich dazu, dass wenn ich mir heute alte Folgen ansehe, mich das zwar immer noch unterhält, dass ich aber, was das literarische Urteil anbelangt, viel häufiger bei Sigrid Loeffler bin als bei Reich-Ranitzki. Ja, niedriger.
Das ist ja schon, wir sagen, es ist wertlos. Warum sagen wir sonst niedriger hängen?
Nein, wenn Sie das Buch vom Jahrhundertereignis etwas niedriger hängen...
Dann bleibt es ein genauso schlechtes Buch wie jetzt.
Wenn dieses Buch von Siegfried Lenz geschrieben werde oder von Stefan Haidt...
Dann hätten wir es nicht behandelt hier.
Dann würden Sie es dulden. Und dann würden Sie es leben lassen.
Dulden, dulden, ich lasse es nicht. Dann würden Sie es leben lassen. Nein, ich kann etwas, was tot ist, nicht leben lassen. Ich kann etwas, was tot ist, nicht leben lassen.
Sie haben es ja tot geredet.
Nein, passen Sie mal auf. Es gibt Autoren, die mit einem ersten Buch fabelhaft angefangen haben, weil Thomas Mann hat im Leben einen Romantik-Budden-Proben nicht geschrieben.
Es gibt nicht viele Autoren, die ihr ganzes Leben hindurch eine gewisse Qualität halten.
Niemand verlangt von ihm, dass er immer dieselbe Ebene hält. Aber das ist ein Buch, das total wertlos und langtäglich ist. Von der ersten bis zur letzten Zeit.
Ja, und so weiter und so fort. Wir hören noch als zweites Beispiel eine Auseinandersetzung. Ganz kurz, Norbert Hitzke da zu einem Roman von Martin Walzer mit dem Titel Ein springender Brunnen.
Geht's mir nicht. Es geht mir eine andere Sache in diesem ganzen Roman. Ich bin überzeugt und ich bitte mich hier nicht, hier nicht zu brüllen, gleich vor lauter Empörung. Er kann viel dieser Martin Walzer erzählen kann er uns verrecken nicht. Er weiß überhaupt nicht, was erzählen ist.
Also das über einen Roman Schriftsteller zu sagen, ist so mit das härteste Urteil, was es überhaupt gibt. Ich bin da gar kein Fan davon, das in solcher Drastik laufend vorzuführen. Und ich finde auch, dass er gerade im Punkt Martin Walzer Unrecht hat. Bei Ein Weites Feld kann ich ihm da durchaus beipflichten. Jedenfalls geht es einfach mir darum, noch mal abzubilden. Es ist nicht alles nur gestern erst passiert, sondern wir haben eine sehr lange Geschichte der Literaturkritik. Und die bedeutet auch, die Überspitzung bedeutet diese Polemik, bedeutet auch, dass sich Autoren wiederum da ärgern. Zum Beispiel ja Martin Walzer, der dann Tod eines Kritikers schreibt, um sich an Marcel Reichranicki zu rächen. Auch das gab es damals schon. Aber dass man heute gerade in den sozialen Medien, die Kritik so abqualifiziert und Leute dann sogar als Opfer hinstellt, die sich die Mühe machen, einen Verriss zu schreiben, das finde ich falsch. Die Kritik an der Kritik finde ich wiederum sehr wichtig. Und eigentlich wäre das ja wunderbar, wenn das jetzt alles die Debatte beleben würde und wir versuchen würden, wieder über Kunst und Kunstkritik zu sprechen, versuchen zu differenzieren. Was aber stattfindet ist, dass man jetzt so tut, als sei da jemand ein Opfer, als müsse man jetzt so eine Lagerbildung betreiben, statt über die Literatur zu reden. Das ist nämlich auch interessant in diesem eben gehörten Ausschnitt aus dem Podcast da, mit Jagoda Marinic und Karoline Wahl. Sie sprechen nämlich gar nicht über die Literatur. Sie reden 90 Minuten, aber wie eigentlich diese Literatur verfasst ist, wo die literarischen Vorbilder sind. Sie sind zum Teil nämlich auch bei Irmgard Coyne und anderen zu finden. Darüber wird nicht gesprochen. Und so gibt es nur noch diese Metaebene, auf der irgendwas diskutiert wird. Das halte ich für falsch und es dient auch überhaupt nicht der Literatur, die sowieso einen immer prekären Status hat.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wie Herbert Grönemeyer mal bei Markus Kafka in der Sendung war. Und er so eine Frage zu der Instrumentalisierung eines Grönemeyer-Liedes hatte. Und Grönemeyer sagte, das erste Mal, dass ich da gefragt werde. Sonst immer nur so diese einzelnen Sätze, die dann irgendwie so totgequatscht werden.
Achtet mal darauf, Albumvorstellungen, irgendwelche Musikvorstellungen, wenn das bei Aspekte ist, Kulturzeit, da sind die Künstler im Interview, die sagen irgendetwas, aber die werden meistens nicht zur Musik direkt befragt. Da hört man nie irgendwas über ein Gitarrensolo oder so.
So, damit kommen wir zu aktuellen Sachen. Zum einen Aufklärung. Wir hatten über die Anti-Baby-Pille geredet, weil wir über Migration dazu kamen. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr so genau.
Es ging um den Club of Rome.
Dass der Club of Rome von der Überbevölkerung ausging.
Und ich sagte dann, naja, es hat ja schon die Anti-Baby-Pille gegeben. Insofern hätte das der Club of Rome ja rezipieren können. Und dann meintest du, die Anti-Baby-Pille kam später. Und jetzt ist es so, die Anti-Baby-Pille kam tatsächlich schon 61. Also der Club of Rome war darüber dann schon zehn Jahre fast unterrichtet, dass es sie gibt. Aber du hast jetzt noch mal genauer nachgelesen, wie die Auswirkung dieser Pille war.
Also wir lesen gleich nochmal, wir lassen uns vorlesen von Frederik, was in der WGP dazu steht. Das ist nämlich wirklich eigentlich auch interessant. Die Anti-Baby-Pille ist mir zuletzt in der Diskussion begegnet, als ich bei Land saß und neben mir Rainer Hank plötzlich meinte, ja, da gab es ja die Anti-Baby-Pille und dann Pillenknick und so. Und der Pillenknick spielte bei mir weder in der Kinderwüste, noch in der Alten Republik, noch irgendwie eine Rolle. Und ich will es kurz erklären, in den 70ern. Also was bei mir immer eine Rolle spielt, ist ja, heute werden Menschen alt, denen die Gesellschaft kein Angebot macht, während die Gesellschaft diesen alten Menschen damals, als sie jung waren, ein Angebot gemacht hat, das so lautete, ach so, du möchtest etwas lernen, ja dann bauen wir dir das größte Gebäude der Welt und zwar genau dahin, wo du es haben willst. Uni Bochum, Uni Bielefeld, Uni was auch immer. Das sind die von dem umbauten Volumen wirklich größten Gebäude der Welt. Also auch ein amerikanisches Hochhaus hält da einfach nicht mit. Wenn man sich die Uni Bielefeld anschaut, das ist für 20.000 Leute ausgelegt. Da ging der Generalschlüssel verloren, in den Besetzungszeiten als Studiengebühren eingeführt wurden und so. Und dann hieß es, ja, da müssen wir jetzt 10.000 Schlöße austauschen. So ja, also das sind die Gebäude, von denen wir da reden. So, wir hatten gleichzeitig zu dieser Explosion von Universitäten Containerschifffahrt 68 ist das erste Containerschifffahrt, Containerschiff gefahren. Das heißt eine Explosion an Möglichkeiten, Globalisierung, Biografiegestaltung im Grunde. Das man dann auch noch verhütet hat, schön und gut, aber der Schalter wurde eigentlich im Kopf umgelegt, nicht in der Medizin. Man hat einfach gesagt, Kinder? Nö, ich mach doch jetzt Karriere und so. Ja, also das war dieser Knickpunkt. Und es spiegelt sich ganz wunderbar in dieser Anti-Baby-Pillen-Geschichtsschreibung in der Wikipedia wieder. Wir hören hier mal drei Absätze.
Anti-Baby-Pille war nach ihrer Markteinführung derart revolutionär und wurde gesellschaftlich und politisch so wenig akzeptiert, dass sie bis Ende der 1960er Jahre in Westdeutschland nur von sehr wenigen Ärzten und auch von diesen nur mit großer Zurückhaltung und ausschließlich als Mittel zur Behebung von Menstruationsstörungen und zudem nur an verheiratete Frauen verschrieben wurde, die schon drei oder vier Kinder hatten und über 30 Jahre alt waren. So lag der Anteil der hormonell verhütenden Frauen Ende 1964 noch unter 0,3 Prozent und 1965 bis 1966 bei 1 bis 2 Prozent. Zudem erschütterte der Contagán-Skandal, über den mit Beginn des Contagán-Prozesses im Mai 1968 intensiv in den Medien berichtet wurde, sowie Berichte über krebsauslösende Wirkungen bestimmter Wirkstoffkombinationen der Antibabypille im Tierversuch 1969, das Vertrauen der Öffentlichkeit in die Arzneimittelsicherheit und die Zuverlässigkeit der Risikostudien und führten zur Zurückziehung einer Reihe von hormonellen Verhütungspräparaten und einem zeitweiligen Rückgang des Interesses an der hormonellen Schwangerschaftsverhütung. Erst Ende 1970 lockerte die Ärzteschaft nach Entwarnung durch neue positive Studienergebnisse, BCGL, Krebs- und Thrombose-Risiken und der darauf erfolgenden Veröffentlichung der Lautze, Leitsätze zur Verordnung oraler Ovulationshämmer und breit angelegte Schulungsangebote für die Ärzteschaft durch die Ärztekammer Sigmund. Ihre restriktive Haltung gegenüber der Pille. Danach begann der Absatz hormoneller Verhütungsmittel rasant zu steigen, auf 25,6 Prozent Ende 1971 und erreichte im Jahr 1976 in Westdeutschland mit einem Anteil von 32,8 Prozent Frauen, die mit der Pille verhüteten, den damaligen Höchstwert.
Da kommen ja auch noch zwei weitere Punkte hinzu. Also erstmal der Punkt, der zu nennen ist, in den 60er Jahren gibt es die Pillen-Enzyklika des Papstes, der sich dagegen ausspricht, gegen die Pille. Und nochmal zu den Zahlen jetzt, dass dann plötzlich so viele Frauen die Pille nehmen. Das hängt natürlich auch mit zwei Dingen zusammen. Einmal gibt es eine sexuelle Liberalisierung, die stattfindet. Und zugleich gibt es aber noch eine patriarchale Struktur, die auch dafür sorgt, dass Männer sagen, ja um die Verhütung kümmere ich mich nicht, mach du das, wenn du willst. So und das ist, glaube ich, was da zusammenkommt in den 70ern, auch nochmal interessant. Aber es ist erstaunlich, war mir auch nicht klar, wie lange sich diese Pille nicht durchgesetzt hat, beziehungsweise nur in verschwindend kleineren Prozent.
Genau, also wenn man immer Pillenknick hört oder andere historische Phänomene, bei denen man rückblickend so, ja klar, voll das revolutionäre Produkt hat natürlich die Gesellschaft umgekrempelt. Nee, so einfach ist es dann immer nicht. Und so auch ein kleiner Kommentar von mir. Wenn ich jetzt Kolumne-Schreiber wäre, würde ich eine Kolumne schreiben. Donald Trump wird gerade von allen der Nobelpreis verliehen, des Herzens, weil er hat die Geisel in den Haaren geholt. Das hat ja nicht mal Netanyahu geschafft, oder was auch immer jetzt so kommentiert wird. Zwei Jahre lang haben uns die deutschen Journalisten erklärt, Netanyahu braucht freie Hand. Wir haben eine deutsche Verantwortung. Egal, was da stattfindet, können wir jetzt später darüber reden, welche Begriffe wir wählen. Es muss geschehen. Wir müssen Waffen liefern. Es darf gar nichts und so weiter. Kritik ziehmt sich nicht, gerade für Deutschland. Netanyahu muss machen dürfen, was er will. Und außerdem hat er ja diese rechtsradikale Regierung, und da kann er ja gar nicht anders. Dann, von heute auf morgen, wie so ein Corona-Pivot in China, wird uns erklärt, also wie der Donald Trump den Netanyahu gezügelt hat, habt ihr alle dieses Foto gesehen, wie ihr ihm das Telefon gereicht habt und gesagt habt, du rufst jetzt bei Peter an und entschuldigst dich dafür, dass du ihm heute das Eis weggegessen hast. Also manchmal denke ich mir so, ich sehe diesen Journalismus und komme aus dem Staunen nicht raus, ehrlich gesagt.
Und damit sind wir doch schon bei unserem Thema des Angststillstands, denn nur aus so einer Angst, was darf ich denn jetzt gerade sagen? Ach so, jetzt ist Trump okay, jetzt ist es mit Netanyahu, darf man ihn einhegen, muss man ihn einhegen, Trump hat es auch gesagt. Alle Journalisten sagen es, Döpfner ist auch zufrieden mit Trump. Okay, dann Feuer frei.
Aber da ist noch mehr das Cursor-Bild.
Das ist Cursor-Bild, wir kommen ja auch noch mal darauf zu sprechen, er erwähnt das noch mal, der Cursor-Journalismus, den können wir da wirklich in Reinform sehen. Ich war auch erstaunt, du hast es so schön jetzt gerade noch mal beschrieben. Wir sprechen also jetzt über Angststillstand, warum die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet von Richard David Precht. Darüber werden wir diskutieren ausführlich. Außerdem haben wir auch wieder Empfehlungen, denn es gibt ja auch noch andere Literatur, zum Beispiel Das gute Übel, ein Band mit Erzählungen der argentinischen Schriftstellerin Samanta Schweblin. Wir hatten schon mal ein Buch von ihr, also ich hatte schon mal eins vorgestellt und jetzt hier ein weiteres mit wirklich ganz beeindruckenden Erzählungen.
Ja, da du den Buch mal kennst, auf der Shortlist stand ja wohl auch ein Buch, habe ich nur ganz kurz gehört, bei Andruck oder so, von einem damaligen Fünftklässler, als Robert Steinhäuser in Erfurt 20 Lehrer erschossen hat.
Ja, Caleb Erdmann habe ich noch nicht gelesen, bin aber sehr gespannt darauf.
Das würde mich mal interessieren, weil da ist ja dann wirklich wichtig, wer schreibt, so?
Ja, vor allem, weil er auch mit dem Autofiktionalen wohl zu spielen scheint. Ich bin auch sehr gespannt auf diesen Roman. Ich bin noch nicht dazu gekommen. Vielleicht ist das was für den nächsten Salon. Dann wissen wir, der Goldpreis steigt immer weiter. Wir lesen mal in der Diplomatik nach, was dann passiert, wenn der steigt. Nämlich dann boomt der illegale Bergbau in Ghana. Das ist so verheerend, unglaublich, das zu lesen. Außerdem geht es um die Neue Friedensnobelpreisträgerin, ein Autor in der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Äußert Kritik, sehr gute Kritik, wie ich finde. Wir sprechen ja hier nicht nur mit Precht über Meinungsfreiheit, sondern auch sonst, wie gehen wir um mit TikTok, soziale Medien, verbieten für Kinder, Jugendliche, was auch immer.
Sofort verbieten.
Ist aufgefallen, dass ich schon jetzt in mehreren Runden saß, in denen dann immer wieder darauf verwiesen wurde, dass die Leopoldina doch so ein Diskussionspapier dazu rausgegeben hat. Und ich dachte, Leopoldina, habe ich zuletzt gehört, wir müssen nochmal eine Schule schließen, Corona und so weiter. Soll ich das überhaupt lesen? Ich habe es dann gelesen. Wir gehen mal auf die Punkte ein. Es ist also gar nicht so schlimm. Und glaube ich, wir könnten vielleicht einen Kompromiss finden, wir zwei, während wir darüber sprechen.
Ich bin immer sehr gespannt, wenn ich schon wieder Leopoldina höre.
Ja, aber die sind eher näher an dir als an mir, sage ich dir lieber.
Also wir werden im Oktober noch drauf zurückkommen. Ich hatte mich ja sehr vehement und habe dir das auch sehr wuchtig dargelegt. Ich will nicht hören, was irgendwelche Politiker dazu sagen. Ich warte nicht auf Gesetze. Es hat ein paar Leute irritiert und ich verstehe auch warum. Ich will jetzt schon mal ankündigen, wir reden Ende des Monats über dieses Mieterbegehren in Berlin, in dem ein konkreter Gesetzestext geschrieben wird. Also keine Aufforderung an den Senat oder überhaupt, sondern 80 Prozent der Leute in Berlin wohnen zur Miete. Und die machen eine Mehrheitsentscheidung, hoffentlich, mal sehen, wo einfach im Gesetz steht, mehr als 3000 Wohnungen darfst du nicht haben, wird verstaatlicht, enteignet, vergesellschaftet, wie auch immer. So, es gibt offenbar selbst in noch ziemlich, sagen wir mal, internationalen Vergleich, gefestigten Demokratien wie in Deutschland Umwege, um einfach zu sagen, der parlamentarische Politikbetrieb hat vollständig versagt. Wir ignorieren ihn ab jetzt.
Ah, interessant.
Und das finde ich sehr gut. Dieses Berliner Beispiel, finde ich, ist einfach nur Schiffre, Miete. Aber wir haben da, und es ist auch nicht einfach Volksentscheid oder irgendwas, sondern da sitzen Leute da, die sich ernsthafte Gedanken über den konkreten Gesetzestext machen und machen ihn kollektiv bindend, weil die Bevölkerung das will unabhängig des parlamentarischen Betriebs. Und das finde ich ein sehr interessantes Phänomen. Und ich hoffe natürlich, dass man daraus eine Entwicklung machen kann. Um zum Beispiel auch englische, amerikanische, deutsche Politiker wollen irgendwie ausbeuten, dass ja hier Kritik, Eltern wollen ihre Kinder schützen. Und deswegen machen wir jetzt Überwachungstechnologie. Du hast es ja bei Ben auch wunderbar sofort auf den Punkt gebracht. Eine Waffenverbotszone ist keine Waffenverbotszone. Sie ist eine, die Polizei darf dich hier durchsuchen Zone. Und nur weil das Gesetz anders heißt, das muss dann einfach umgangen werden. So was. Und auf dieses Phänomen, auf das ich sehr viel setze, kommen wir noch zurück. Und deswegen Leopoldina, okay.
Ich bin weniger skeptisch jetzt, als ich es dann gelesen habe. Habe ich mich dann eines besseren belehren lassen. Aber es gibt auch da Punkte, die ich wiederum heikel finde. Da müssen wir dann nochmal drüber reden. Und es gibt auch Musik von Georg Philipp Telemann, die ich empfehle.
Sehr gut. Wir lesen heute meinerseits, ich trage die Zahlen vor. Warum sind die Liberalen so glücklich, also unglücklich, warum sind die Konservativen so glücklich? Wir haben ja über die Zahlen des Einkommens schon gesprochen. Es ist egal, welche Metrik man nimmt, es ist erschütternd. Und danach, nachdem du dann Texte vorgestellt hast, komme ich auf dieses Thema zurück aus der anderen Richtung. In der FAZ wurde darüber geschrieben, warum immer mehr Frauen Single sein wollen und bleiben wollen. Also sagen, ich verlasse nicht nur den Mann, ich verlasse die ganze Idee. So, da kann man sich also über dieses Unglück dann noch mal spezifisch Gedanken machen. Dann ein Text aus The New Atlantis, eine Publikation, die ich erst kürzlich entdeckt habe, die mir aber sehr gut gefällt. Da wird einfach monatlich oder so Texte publiziert. Über das erste Forschungs- und Marktgebiet, bei dem China die Schlüsseltechnologie, die dann auch Markt und so weiter relevant ist, vor Amerika vorstellt. Und das ist KI in Verbindung mit Genetik. Also da wird es gruselig. Ja. Und als wir darüber sprachen, dass Mangold uns den Christen, Antichristen, Katechern und so weiter vorstellte und dann darauf hinwies, das ist auch ganz interessant mit Blick auf Amerika und wir das im Salon gesprochen, hat Peter Thiel vier Vorlesungen gehalten in San Francisco. Zu diesem Thema. Ich habe das dann meinem German-Eigegeber gesagt, guck mal hier, ist das noch aufgetaucht? Also wow, es ist ja krass und so. Also wir gehen diese vier Vorlesungen durch, die gibt es aber noch nicht im Original. Der Guardian hat sich darum gekümmert, sie relativ detailliert vorzustellen und Adrian Daub hat sie auch noch kommentiert. Man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht heraus. Also es ist wirklich unglaublich. Ich will nicht sagen, es ist unglaublich gruselig, sondern ich möchte es gerne auf die, es ist unglaublich albern. Man kann es sich nicht vorstellen, was in diesen Köpfen der amerikanischen Milliardäre davor geht.
Das alles gibt es im Salon, den Salon kann man abonnieren. Darf ich noch kurz auf einen Termin hinweisen? Bitte.
Ich habe einen Termin in Jena angenommen, der ist aber schon am Dienstag, am 21. Also nächste Woche. Ja. 21. Oktober bin ich in Jena. Infos dazu auf meiner Webseite, dass der Termin verlinkt.
Prima. Ich bin am 27. in Berlin und dann noch im November in Essen, in Prag. Wir sind in Düsseldorf. Auch das kann man dann beiziehen. Wir reden in Düsseldorf im Filmmuseum, glaube ich, wird das stattfinden.
Wow, steht da auch ein Alien hier in Frankfurt.
Wir werden nachschauen. Werden wir über KI reden? Also auch da gibt es das, wenn gleich wir dieses Gespräch auch aufzeichnen werden und dann für die Salon-Abonnenten auch noch im Nachtrag veröffentlichen können.
Sehr gut.
Das ist also Ende November. Ich glaube, auf meiner Homepage ist schon der Termin oder wird dann da bald folgen. Jetzt noch ein Punkt. Genau. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Salon unterstützt. Wenn ihr also in den Salon kommt. Dort sprechen wir ausführlich über die jetzt genannten Titel. Vor allem werden wir diskutieren, so etwa zwei Stunden über Angststillstand von Richard David Precht. Was können wir mit diesen Thesen machen? Und man hat natürlich dann auch Zugang zu allen alten Folgen, auch zu den Live-Salons, die es ja fünfmal im Jahr inzwischen gibt.
Außerdem gibt es auf der Webseite verlinkt das Salon Archiv. Es sind jetzt alle Salons aufgeführt mit allen Kapitelmarken. Und oben gibt es ein Suchfeld. Da könnt ihr also nach Tuus suchen. Steht da. Zwölf Erwähnungen. Und dann sind genau die, wo Tuus auch vorkommt, unten aufgelistet. Also da kann man sich jetzt endlich Übersicht verschaffen. Das wird es natürlich für den allgemeinen Podcast auch noch geben. Aber da will ich natürlich gleich eine KI-Suche. Deswegen muss ich da noch ein bisschen Vibe coden. Ich rufe da auch nochmal nach Hilfe auf, spezifischer Hilfe. Denn es ist gar nicht so einfach, die großen Kapitel, die großen Podcast-Transkripte in diese kleinen Chunks einzuteilen, sodass man überhaupt da drauf zugreifen kann. Weil keine KI kann 50 5-stündige Transkripte durchsuchen. Also da stoßen alle an ihre Grenzen. Aber zumindest die Salonsuche gibt es schon mal. Also für alle, die schon Salonmitglieder sind, die können einfach sich die Sachen raussuchen. Die Texte sind ja verlinkt. Also man kann direkt den Text anklicken, den wir gelesen haben, und kommt dann unten auf die Steady-Seite, in der man unsere Besprechung findet.
Wunderbar. Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie viel Angst hast du?
Ich habe nicht so viel Angst, weil ich gar nicht so leicht sanktioniert werden kann.
Okay, es sind keine Sanktionsmöglichkeiten. Das ist ja schon mal hochinteressant.
Ja, darum geht es ja bei dieser Angst, die Richard David Precht beschreibt. Also was damit gemeint ist, ist, wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise bei einem Fernsehsender wäre oder bei einer Produktionsgesellschaft, dann könnte es ja passieren, dass man sagt, also hör mal, diese Aussage da, die du da in deinem Podcast getroffen hast, mach das nicht nochmal. Sonst wissen wir nicht, wir wollten dir eigentlich eine neue Sendung geben, aber sieht schwierig aus. Da ich aber ja bei mir selbst quasi angestellt bin, kann mir das ja nicht passieren. Insofern kann man in Shitstorms geraten oder bekommt Kritik, aber es ist nicht diese Art der Sanktionierung möglich, wie das vielleicht bei anderen der Fall ist. Und deswegen kann ich ein bisschen freier von Angst mich da bewegen, wenngleich eine völlige Angstfreiheit natürlich nie existieren kann.
Typischerweise fangen wir mit den archimetischen Punkten von diesen Büchern an, um sie zu besprechen. Jetzt sind wir direkt bei der Achilles Ferse. Denn Richard David Precht ist genau diese Unterscheidung wahnsinnig wichtig. Es geht darum, Sanktionsmöglichkeiten aufzuzeigen, wie zum Beispiel, wir entziehen dir Budget, wir entziehen dir Leute, wir entziehen dir deine Sendellizenz, was auch immer wir jetzt so gesehen haben. Offenbar strecken Funktionäre davor zurück.
Ja.
So, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Dieses Buch beginnt aber ganz woanders. Nämlich seit über 70 Jahren stellt das Institut für Demoskopie Allensbach den Menschen in Deutschland jedes Jahr die Frage, kann man heute in Deutschland noch frei seine Meinung äußern oder sollte man besser vorsichtig sein? Und dieses Ergebnis ist über Jahrzehnte relativ konstant, hat Höhenwerte bis 83 Prozent. Dann allerdings beginnt eine Talfahrt in den 2000ern. Es kommt zur Corona-Pandemie und so weiter und so fort und zack 45 Prozent. 2023 gerade einmal 40 Prozent sagen, sie glauben, sie können hier ihre Meinung frei äußern und müssten nicht vorsichtig sein. Hier redet man also über eine gesamte Bevölkerung, die genau diese Funktionärs-Sanktionsmöglichkeiten eigentlich gar nicht, denen das gar nicht droht. Weil denen wird weder eine Sendelizenz weggenommen, noch wird ein Budget entzogen.
Die gehen morgen in den Handwerksbetrieb und alles ist wie immer.
Und diesen Zwiespalt löst dieses Buch nicht auf, finde ich. Also man kann es ja auch mal jetzt, wo wir schon so angefangen haben, dramatisch beginnen und sagen, das Buch weist auf ein paar interessante Phänomene und Probleme hin, aber es macht auch ganz schön große auf, über die ich bisher noch nicht nachdachte, und die aber hier auch nicht aufgelöst werden.
Ich finde schon, dass es aufgelöst wird. Nämlich, es wäre erstmal leicht zu sagen, das ist ein Buch, in dem sich Richard David Precht mit seiner Rolle als öffentlicher, intellektueller Auseinandersetz, der dann möglicherweise sanktioniert wird, nicht mehr im Föjeton besprochen wird oder sonst etwas. Und ja, das trifft natürlich da alles zu, aber dann würde ich sagen, das ist das Problem von einem Prozent der Menschen, nämlich die, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, irgendetwas sagen oder so. Wenn aber jetzt Menschen befragt werden, habt ihr den Eindruck, dass die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet und sie antworten in so großer Zahl mit Ja. Dann bedeutet das tatsächlich, glaube ich nicht, dass sie das insofern antworten, als sie Angst haben, morgen etwas ihrem Nachbarn zu erzählen, morgen bei der Familienfeier schweigen zu müssen oder im Betrieb die ganze Zeit den Mund halten zu müssen. Sowieso muss man ja auch hier nochmal fragen, was meinen wir hier mit Meinung? Das wird ja nicht aufgeschlüsselt, denn man kann ja generell sagen, wo die Werkstore durchschritten werden, hört die Meinungsfreiheit sowieso auf. Man kann durchaus sich politisch äußern in der Mittagspause zu Kollegen oder vielleicht auch während der Arbeit, aber es gibt eben ganz viele Dinge, die wird man während der Arbeitszeit nicht sagen können, zum Beispiel über die Gedanken, die man so hat über den Vorgesetzten, welche Kritik man eigentlich äußern würde und sie nicht äußern kann. Deswegen haben wir Betriebsräte, Obleute, dafür gibt es Gewerkschaften, wir sehen also, da gibt es ja ein Generalismusmachtverhältnis, mit dem sich Richard David Precht gar nicht auseinandersetzt. Das wäre auch mal zu fragen, wie ist es denn eigentlich mit der Meinungsfreiheit? Ich hatte mal hier im Salon dieses Interview gebracht von Katharina Pistor, die in den USA ja lehrt und gefragt wurde, wie kann das denn sein, fragte das Handelsband, dass die Leute jetzt nicht rebellieren gegen Trump und seine Einschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit an Universitäten. Und sie sagte ja da, die meisten Leute leben ja acht Stunden am Tag in Diktaturen, wo sie ihre Meinungen nicht frei äußern können, nämlich in Unternehmen. Und jetzt ist für die es eher so, dass sie sagen, das geschieht den Professoren mal ganz recht, dass die jetzt auch mal erleben, wie es ist. Ja, das fand ich eine sehr, sehr interessante Überlegung von Katharina Pistor. Wird das aber jetzt aufgelöst, weil man jetzt sagen kann, dann sind es ja zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe. Zunächst mal, dass man sagt, da sind Leute in der Öffentlichkeit, die werden sanktioniert, aber die normalen Leute können ja einfach so weiter reden. Ich glaube, es löst sich in der Weise auf, dass die Leute also diese Frage beantworten mit Ja, die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet, indem sie an die denken, die öffentlich sanktioniert werden. Sie wissen, dass sie nicht dazugehören. Sie sind nicht der Comedian, nicht der Rockstar oder sonst wer, der nicht mehr dann stattfindet. Aber sie identifizieren sich in gewisser Weise schon mit ihnen. Sie sehen eine Art Stellvertreter darin. Und hinzukommt, dass es ja darum geht, welche vorherrschende Moral oder welche vorherrschende Meinung, welche Hegämonie erleben wir, wenn wir zum Beispiel Nachrichten schauen. Und wenn wir dort fortwährend hören, dass eigentlich alle Waffenlieferung wollen, jeder Journalist, ob von Taz bis Welt, alle sagen im Prinzip Ähnliches, dann stellt sich also schon bei den Rezipienten, die das anders sehen, wo immer 40 Prozent sagten, naja, bitte nicht Waffen liefern, nicht so viele zumindest und all das, stellt sich also die Frage, was stimmt hier nicht? Darf man das offenbar nicht mehr sagen? Das heißt, sie dürfen das ihren Nachbarn sagen, sie können das auch abends in der Kneipe sagen, ich finde verrückt, wie da aufgerüstet wird, aber sie wissen, also im allgemein anerkannten Diskurs ist das nicht mehr das, was gesagt werden darf. Und diese Sache ist natürlich nicht ganz deckungsgleich, aber ich finde, dass sich das dadurch etwas auflöst, dieser Widerspruch, der von dir beschrieben wurde.
Ja, bis zu deinem Satz eben, das ist nicht ganz deckungsgleich, fand ich das sehr plausibel, was du gesagt hast, und ich will es auch noch mal reformulieren, in einer Demoskopie, die wir kennen, und da überprüfen wir mal, ob das nicht einfach gar nicht deckungsgleich ist, denn diese Alensbach-Umfrage wird ja auch zum Thema, wie geht es Deutschland wirtschaftlich und wie ist deine eigene Lage wirtschaftlich gemacht. Die Leute sagen, Deutschland geht es ganz schlecht. Ich bin ganz pessimistisch, was die Zukunftsaussicht unserer Schicksalsgemeinschaft angeht. Auf die Frage hin, wie geht es dir persönlich? Super. Also wirklich 80-20. Bei der Frage, kann man heute in Deutschland noch frei seine Meinung äußern? Ich würde sagen, wir haben mittlerweile das Phänomen, dass Leute sagen, klar, ich habe noch nie bei einer Insta-Story darüber nachgedacht, was ich da sage, aber dass der Jimmy Kimmel in Amerika gecancelt wird. Halt dich für ein ernsthaftes Problem. Also ja, man kann seine Meinung nicht mehr frei äußern. Also wir müssen bei dieser Fragestellung, die steht auf ganz schwammigen Grund, wenn sie einfach lautet, kann man heute in Deutschland noch frei seine Meinung äußern? Und dann schlägt das Buch aber um und er hat ja den Richard Thunmüller als ganz großen Anwalt seiner Sache, der eben dieses Bild der subjektiven Meinungsfreiheit formuliert. Also, subjektiv nimmt ja schon mal den objektiven Charakter aus. Das handelt er auch schnell ab. Laut Grundgesetz findet keine Zensur statt, aber die subjektive Meinungsfreiheit ist trotzdem, diese Zahlen sind ja erschreckend, 58 Prozent oder was auch immer sagen, nein, darf man nicht. In Deutschland gibt es keine Meinungsfreiheit mehr. Und auf diesen doppelschwammigen Grund, also der Undifferenziertheit, ob man sich selber meint oder Phänomene beobachtet, die einen Sorge bringen zur Meinungsfreiheit, aus denen leitet er dann eine persönliche Angst als maßgeblich für das Problem, das er im Folge dessen dann aufschlüsseln möchte. Leitet er eine persönliche Angst ab, die Leute haben Angst. Und das kriege ich nicht ganz zusammen. Also diese Angst sehe ich nicht, deswegen auch meine Eingangs-Joke-Frage an dich. Handelt dieses Buch davon, dass alle Angst haben oder dass alle infantil einfach nur noch ins Internet, ohne nachzudenken, was sie eigentlich sagen, voll Müll.
Und er beschreibt ja beide Phänomene. Das ist ja das Interessante. Also er beschreibt ja genau die Leute, die zu allem eine Meinung haben und loslegen und alles ins Internet schreiben, was ihnen so gerade durch den Kopf rauscht.
Also haben sie jetzt Angst oder eben gerade nicht?
Und das ist interessant, dass wir glaube ich hier diese Idee der Identifikation haben. Das arbeitet er nicht so heraus, das müsste man aber eigentlich tun, dass man zwar für sich sagen kann, ich kann ja alles machen, ich schreibe hier nochmal was rein, was nicht opportun ist. Und damit will ich sagen, nicht opportun, das kann im positiven Sinne nicht opportun sein oder im von mir bewerteten negativen Sinne nicht opportun sein. Aber die Leute, die in irgendeiner Position sind, wo es auf was ankommt, zum Beispiel Journalisten oder Talkshow-Moderatoren oder so, da ist das schon wieder anders. Die müssen sich in einer anderen Weise rechtfertigen. Also identifiziere ich mich mit denen, wie geht es denen gerade? Nun, dass wir uns so mit diesen Figuren, die wir irgendwo sehen, identifizieren, das ist ja ganz logisch, dass das passiert. Die Frage ist, wie überträgt man es auf sich selbst? Ich glaube auch, dass solche Umfragen in gewisser Weise sich selbst bestätigen, irgendwann Leute hören. Die meisten Leute sagen, man kann ja nicht mehr frei seine Meinung äußern. Wenn sie das nächste Mal gefragt werden, darf man auch frei seine Meinung äußern? Sagen sie, nee, ich habe ja auch schon mal gehört, das darf man nicht mal. Also nein, man darf nicht mehr frei seine Meinung äußern. Das ist sicherlich als so ein Gefühl und sich selbst verstärkendes Element zu nennen. Was ich aber glaube, was wichtig ist und was Richard David Precht auch tut, ist zu zeigen, dass es diese subjektive Meinungsfreiheit gibt. Er sagt, Freiheitsentzug droht nur bei schweren Beleidigungen, der klaren Verletzung von Persönlichkeitsrechten, öffentlichen Aufrufen zu Gewalt oder der öffentlichen Deugnung der deutschen Verbrechen bei der Shoah. Das ist so und da hat sich wenig dran.
Bis er das am Ende selber aufbricht und sagt, wenn Nancy Feser so ein Gesetz macht oder man wegen Schwachkopfschuhe in der Hochschule... Das ist ja auch nicht nur eine subjektive, sondern eine sehr objektive.
Da geht es dann... Er beschreibt dann neue Phänomene der letzten Jahre, nicht nur Phänomene, sondern Versuche der Gesetzesänderung oder tatsächliche Gesetzesänderung. Auf die kommen wir dann gleich noch. Aber bei Richard Traunmüller bezieht er sich auf die subjektive Meinungsfreiheit und da heißt es, die Kosten der freien Meinungsäußerung. Und das ist wichtig. Beginne nicht erst dort, wo eine verlautbarte Meinung justiziabel ist. Man muss auch fragen, wann ist es günstig, sich zu äußern. Das ist dann der Fall, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Äußerungen sanktioniert werden, gering ist und die Sanktionen selbst geringe Kosten mit sich bringen. Bedeutet also, je geringer die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, für seine Meinung in irgendeiner Form sanktioniert zu werden, umso größer ist die Meinungsfreiheit. Jetzt sagt er in einem Klima, aber der Angst, was immer das dann genau meinen mag, müssen wir mal gucken, sind also Leute nicht mehr bereit, ihre Meinung zu sagen, weil sie sagen, sonst drohen mir Sanktionen. Bedeutet also nicht, dass man sagt, da hat es aber ordentlich gekracht in einer Talkshow, da waren verschiedene, unterschiedliche Positionen, sondern wir sehen dann entsprechend bei Twitterreaktionen, geht gar nicht, den dürft ihr nie wieder einladen, solche Leute sind abschauen, was auch immer. Jetzt kann man immer sagen, da sind wir in dem Bereich der Talkshow, des Medienzirkus, aber das überträgt sich ja immer auch auf die Normalbevölkerung, dass sie also oft nur eine eingebildete Angst hat, weil sie in der Regel sich auch gar nicht ständig im Supermarkt oder sonst wo politisch äußert, wo man dann gemassregelt werden könnte. Aber es ist nun so, dass der Zuschauer, der Publikum ist, sich zugleich aber auch identifiziert mit denen, die dort in den Talkshows sitzen, mit den Protagonisten. Und ich glaube, dass damit schon sehr viel gesagt werden kann. Und damit ist auch beschrieben, warum dann so eine sehr konforme Meinung zu vielen wichtigen Themen entsteht. Also dass beispielsweise aus meinem Umfeld mir Leute sagen, die angewiesen sind auf irgendwelche Fördergelder oder die in größeren Strukturen sind, ich kann mich nicht zum Thema Nahost äußern. Ich kann mich nicht zum Thema Wehrpflicht äußern. Das bedeutet also, diese Angst ist da. Und wenn dann jetzt wieder Leute sagen werden, wie damals schon bei dem Buch mit Harald Wälzer, ja, aber Precht, wovon redet er denn? Der ist doch erfolgreich. Ja, der muss keine Angst haben, denn der kann nicht mehr sanktioniert werden. Also man kann dem jetzt die ZDF Sendung wegnehmen. Meine Güte, er wird genug Geld verdient haben und sagt das ja auch so in Interviews. Wir müssen uns keine Sorgen um ihn machen.
Genau. Also diese Umstände usw. alle eingepreist. Das ist sehr wichtig. Precht hat das bei Jung und Naiv auch nochmal betont gestern. Auf die Frage hin, die saloppe Frage von Thilo. Willst du nicht zu Gaza was sagen oder so? Sagt dann Precht einfach nein, mir wurde schon mal das Antisemitismus Label angehangen. Das war nicht schön. Das will ich nie wieder erleben. Zu diesem Thema sage ich eher weniger. Also ganz explizit Umgang mit einer Angst, wie er sie ja hier im Buch verorten möchte. Ich will trotzdem nochmal sagen, dass diese Angst hier auf sehr schwammigem Grund steht und zwar unnötigerweise. Ich bin selber ein großer Fan des Alarmismus. Ich bin in die Frank-Schönmacher-Schule gegangen. Ein Thema aufzugreifen, bei dem die Welt nicht untergeht, lohnt fast nicht. Deswegen Demografie, Familie und so weiter. Nun haben wir es hier, finde ich, trotzdem mit einem überspitzen Alarmismus zu tun. Denn diese Angst, von der er ausdrücklich sagt, diese Angst ist nicht präzise real messbar, sondern eben nur gefühlt, bindet er zurück an die Meinungsfreiheit, von der ich schon sage, es ist jetzt so ein bisschen, ich will schon mal die Aufklärung, geht es jemanden um die eigene persönliche gefühlte Meinungsfreiheit oder das Gefühl, wie es in der Gesellschaft um die Meinungsfreiheit bestellt ist oder um konkrete andere, die gerade gekanzelt werden, denen man Solidarität ausspricht. So und für ihn ist aber, wenn ich sage, von der Angst zur Meinungsfreiheit ist der Brückenschlag schon ein bisschen wackelig. Macht er einen Brückenschlag von der Meinungsfreiheit zur Demokratie, den wir alle sympathisch finden, aber der auch sehr wackelig ist, denn bei ihm ist ja Demokratie ist gleich Meinungsfreiheit. Sagt er ja ausdrücklich. Also wirklich mit dem Ist, mit dem Gleichheitszeichen so ein Satz.
Würdest du widersprechen?
Ja, ich will da nicht widersprechen. Ich kann da voll mit sympathisieren und sage, ja klar, ohne Meinungsfreiheit, wohin führt uns denn die Demokratie, wenn wir das Vorfeld einer politischen Wahl nicht ordentlich spielen können. Ja, also wenn da keine Freiheit herrscht. Nur ich würde sehr gerne über diese Angst, über den Hegemon, über den Cursor des gefühlten Anstands und so weiter ganz viel reden, habe ich auch schon. Ich habe den Herrn Hegemon, wer ist das eigentlich? Wer verpflichtet hier wen zu welcher Rechtfertigung und so weiter, damit es im Diskurs weitergeht. Ich möchte damit gerne, also ich möchte gerne über diese Themen reden, ohne dass die vorher zubetoniert werden, mit so einer Tragfähigkeit oder so, wo ich denke, nee, da muss jetzt gar kein Atombonker drum gebaut werden mit Demokratie ist Meinungsfreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit in Gefahr durch Angst. Also jedes Mal, wenn wir jetzt über Angst und Rechtfertigungspflichten stehen, ist immer gleich die Demokratie in Gefahr. Ich finde, die Demokratie ist wegen sehr vielen in Gefahr, vor allem auch wegen Meinungsfreiheit und wie man mit ihr umgeht. Wir haben ja die Fälle in Amerika, also die Universitäten werden weggekanzelt, beim Fernsehen wird krass eingegriffen. Das läuft alles über diese Geoökonomie eigentlich, dass man nämlich da sagt, ja die Eigentumsrechte sind halt jetzt so und so und wir haben die FTC und wer auch immer oder die FCC, dass man da einfach Zugriff hat. Nur, ich würde gerne über dieses Hegemann und Körzer Phänomen reden, ohne dass gleich der Antichrist mit im Raum steht.
Bin ich sehr dafür und das ist wirklich ein...
Weil manchmal sind es wirklich einfach nur Gefühlslagen so, ja?
Ich möchte fast sagen, es ist eine Krankheit der heutigen Sachbücher, dass egal worum es geht, ob um die Macht von Netflix, ob Instagram, ob es um Meinungsfreiheit geht oder irgendeine kleine Sache und wir sehen das auch in so einem gewissen Instagram-Aktivismus, der endet meistens so, dass es ein Statement gibt zu irgendeinem Thema und der letzte Satz lautet wie und das schadet am Ende auch der Demokratie. So werden diese Videos in der Regel abgeschlossen und ich würde es auch aushalten, wenn man sagt, ja zur Demokratie gehört die Meinungsfreiheit, aber wir müssen jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit über Demokratie in so einem unglaublich emphatischen Sinne sprechen, denn diese Art der Demokratie, die immer hier auch heraufbeschwommen wird, die erlebe ich nicht und die war auch nicht früher in der Bundesrepublik da. Früher in der Bundesrepublik haben über ein Drittel auch nicht gewählt, haben sich gar nicht dafür interessiert, haben eine Zeit lang nur gewählt, weil der Pfarrer sagte, welch mal die CDU morgen. Haben sich nur mal die Tagesschau vielleicht angesehen, wenn es hochkam und sagten, der Helmut Kohl ist aber dick geworden. Das heißt also diese emphatische Auseinandersetzung, dass wir hier uns als demokratische Gesellschaft wahrnehmen, bla bla bla. Das ist eh eine große Illusion. Deswegen muss das nicht immer so groß heraufbeschworen werden.
Ich finde es trotzdem witzig, wenn man jetzt Precht explizit mal diesen Vorwurf macht, weil er wehr immer und so weiter, wenn man sagt, und jetzt literarisch ein gespielter Dialog, jemand sagt, also dass der Thilo Mischke jetzt die AHD-Sendung da moderiert, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die heißt, ich habe die auch noch nie gesehen. Und dann kommt als Antwort darauf, ach, bist du jetzt auch gegen Demokratie? Das darf nicht sein. Also wir möchten uns gerne gegen Thilo Mischke äußern oder solche Dinge und sei es nur jetzt in der Metaebene, weil das in einem Sachbuchthema ist, diskutieren, ohne dass man sich immer gleich einen Rechtfertigungsdruck aussetzt. Ach, jetzt bist du auch für Diktatur, ja.
Wir kommen auf Thilo Mischke, ja gleich nochmal zu sprechen. Der bekommt ja fast ein ganzes Kapitelgewicht mit als ein Fallbeispiel. Vielleicht sagen wir aber erst einmal, dass er sagt, es gibt tatsächlich eine Repression in Staaten, Victor Orban ist zu nennen, aber er beschreibt einen Freiheitsverlust, der in seiner Struktur, wie er meint, historisch einmalig ist. Deutschland hat eine geringe Meinungstoleranz bei gleichzeitiger rechtlicher Rahmung, die sehr viel mehr möglich macht. Auch wenn sich da man sich jetzt verändert hat, mag in den letzten Jahren, sind das keine gravierenden Eingriffe. Die Frage ist also, wo kommen die Normen her und wer setzt sie? Selbstverständlich darf man in Deutschland heute alles sagen, aber es war noch nie so leicht, mit seiner Meinung anzuecken und dafür angeprangert zu werden, heißt es. Wir müssen lernen, was viele bislang nicht gern lernen wollen. Das wichtige, fortschrittliche und emanzipatorische Entwicklungen, die sehr zu begrüßen sind, Schatten werfen, über die wir bislang viel zu wenig nachgedacht haben. Was er dann macht, ist ja eine große Auseinandersetzung nochmal mit 68, mit der Liberalität, die dann kommt, mit auch einer Meinungspluralität und dann auch mit einer gewissen Art des Sprechens, die sich mehr und mehr durchsetzt, wodurch ein anderes Sprechen dann vielleicht weniger möglich ist. Die Frage ist natürlich, also wir sind im Reich der Gefühle und du hast recht, das ist auf so einem schwammigen Boden.
Ich habe jetzt die ganze Zeit, Aber nicht weil es Gefühle sind, sondern die Brückenschläge aus dem Gefühlsthema raus.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit überlegt, ob es überhaupt einen anderen Weg gibt, also stochern wir nicht immer ein bisschen da im Nebel, wenn wir über diese Themen sprechen, bei denen wir einfach nicht eine faktische Grundlage legen können. Also wenn wir über Gesetze reden, wenn wir da gleich über Majestät beleidigung oder sowas sprechen, ja, da wissen wir genau, da wird eine Einschränkung vorgenommen oder so. Oder das FASER-Gesetz, das sieht aus wie eine Einschränkung, ist auch eine. Aber wenn wir in diesen anderen Bereichen sind, dann wird das sehr, sehr schwierig. Ich glaube, was hier ein bisschen zu kurz kommt, ist, dass wir schon wiederum eine Industrie jetzt haben, die sich gebildet hat, darum zu sagen, das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen, und jetzt sind die Linken wieder, die uns was verbieten. Also das heißt, dass man danach sucht, dass man sich empören kann über irgendeine winzige Repression oder eine winzige Maßregelung. Hat ja auch schon wieder eine Industrie von Büchern und allem produziert oder diese ganzen YouTube-Formate, Streaming-Formate, die es dazu gibt. Bedeutet also, wir haben hier so ein Perpetuum-Mol-Bilet, eigentlich geschaffen, in dem wir über Meinungsweite und deren Verlust reden. Und ich glaube, das ist noch mal so eine Struktur, die hätte man auch aufzeigen können.
Aber das macht er, finde ich, sehr gut mit dem Seerosenbild. Umso mehr sich der eine äußert, die Freiheit und die Freiheit des Andersdenkenden in einem, und das wird bei Nachtweihe und Almen, ne, nicht Almendinger, sondern wie heißt seine Frau da, mit der jetzt die? Ammlinger, die Zerstörungslust. Da geht es ja auch ganz konkret, aber eben materiell um dieses Nullsummenspiel.
Ja.
Wir sehen Rezo und unten steht Views 11.000. Und dann denken wir, wow, das ist viel, zu viel hatte ich nicht. Und was ich finde, ist, dass im Buch zu kurz kommt, dieses unabhängig des Inhalts mal über diese Marshall McLuhan-artige, wie sehen die Messages heute aus? Und wo ist eigentlich die Information? Die Information ist nicht, Rezo hat ein Video gemacht und äußert sich zu irgendwas, sondern Rezo hat so und so viel Reichweite damit. Und damit nimmt er anderen Reichweite weg, weil für uns alle ist der Tag nur 24 Stunden und es ist ein Nullsummspiel und so weiter und so fort. Und da, finde ich, geht das Buch so ein bisschen kurz.
Was ich eben auch sagte, über alle reden über Caroline Wahl, aber die wirklich 100 interessanten anderen Autoren kommen nicht mehr vor.
Genau, die wird dann einfach die Luft genommen. Und dieser ostdeutsche Spruch, uns fragt ja keiner, der ist ja ein bisschen anders gelagert als ich darf ja nichts mehr sagen. Sondern wenn du da auf die Straße gehst und fragst, wie steht es um die Meinungsfreiheit, dann sagen die, also dass man Ausländer hier nicht haben will, darf man ja heute gar nicht mehr sagen. Aber die haben es ja gerade gesagt. Die wollen hier Ausländer nicht haben. So, denen wird also nichts zugehören. Das ist deren Problem. Niemand kommt und holt deren Meinung ab. Nicht mal bei einer Wahl. Man soll sie einfach in Kreuz machen. Und dieses uns fragt ja keiner, finde ich. Und das ist jetzt meine, vielleicht das erste Mal, dass ich so eine kleine ostdeutsche Erfahrung jetzt hier reinbringe, von der ich sage, die ist vielleicht ein blinder Fleck in einem Buch. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Die Leute haben nicht den Eindruck, sie dürften nicht mehr überall alle ihre Sachen sagen. Es ist ja auch, finde ich, absurd, jetzt mit den 50ern und 60ern zu vergleichen. Wir haben heute dieselben Möglichkeiten, wie in den 60ern unsere Meinung zu äußern. Wenn wir uns die Möglichkeiten der 60er anschauen, ist das, ich trete an den Gartenzaun und rufe Uwe rüber. Ausländer sind alle scheiße. Das kann heute auch immer noch jeder. Hinzugekommen sind aber Möglichkeiten, und das ist jetzt was Paradox, die uns vorgaukeln, dass das gar nicht hinzugekommen ist, sondern dass uns was weggenommen wurde. Das ist doch ein interessantes Phänomen.
Ja, es gibt mehr Äußerungsmöglichkeiten denn je.
Genau, und dadurch wächst diese Enttäuschung. Da macht das einen Ansätzen, aber er geht, finde ich, nicht so richtig in dieses Jägemondeskurs ein.
Versuchen wir mal, also er schildert, finde ich, sehr treffend, wie er an einer ORF-Talkshow sitzt, die heißt Im Zentrum, und dort geht es um das Thema Meinungsfreiheit, und er ist dort mit einer Grünen aus Österreich, und die widerspricht und sagt, nein, das ist ganz klar, es gibt eine Einteilung. Die eine Gruppe der Leute will Menschenwürde und die anderen nicht, und die, die das nicht wollen, gegen die muss man kämpfen. Da ist das prokursive Lager, da sind die Reaktionären. Und die anderen, die die Menschenwürde nicht wollen, die seien eben denkfoul. Jetzt sagt Richard David Precht, ihm kommt das ein bisschen denkfoul vor, und er sagt, bei den Diskussionen um Nahost, um Corona und Ukraine, ging es da um die Frage, wer es jetzt für Menschen würde, wer ist dagegen? Nee, das war da nicht die Frage. Das ist nicht das. Er sagt, ja, es geht darum, dass wir Affektmodulation lernen, wie er das nennt. Wir lernen schon als Kind, wie man sich bei Tisch benimmt. Und wir wissen auch, dass wir gewisse Konventionen aufrechterhalten müssen, wenn wir irgendwo hineintreten. Es sei denn, wir sind Klaus Kinski, dann brüllen wir einfach alles raus, wie es uns durch den Kopf rauscht. Und deswegen gucken wir uns diese Videos auch an, weil wir nicht fassen können, dass das wirklich jemand macht. Das ist ähnlich, wie man sich Borat diesen Film ansieht oder diese Sendung, die es da früher gab von Sacha Baron Cohen, dass man nicht glauben konnte, dass jemand sowas macht, dass jemand gegenüber sitzt und sich so äußert, weil wir eigentlich Affektmodulation betreiben. Das sei gar nicht das Problem. Aber wenn man von diesen zwei entgegengesetzten Lagern immer spricht, dann sagt er, dass die ja nicht der Realität entsprechen. Und er bezieht sich auf ein Buch, das wir hier ausführlich besprochen haben, nämlich Triggerpunkte von Steffen M und anderen. Precht sagt dann, es liegt auch sehr stark daran, dass es immer noch dieses ergraute Rechts-Links-Schema gibt.
Ich bin ja, dass er sehr bedient.
Ich bin, dass er sehr bedient und ich bin auch durchaus ein Verfechter dieses Schemas. Nicht im Sinne von, dass ich sage, ich finde das überall wieder, sondern würde mir eigentlich mehr wünschen, das habe ich ja auch bei Ben zum Ausdruck gebracht, dass man sagt, Linke kümmern sich darum, dass wirklich Wohlstand für alle ist, dass die Ökonomie umgekrempelt wird und, und, und. Und da, und da im Prinzip der Gleichheit, auch der ökonomischen Gleichheit folgt, das wäre für mich links. Deswegen bin ich für dieses Schema. Würde es aber auch nicht anlegen können, und da hat er recht, auf zum Beispiel Nahost, Corona, Ukraine. Da wird es sehr schwer, mit dem Rechts-Zinks Schema zu argumentieren, weil wir für alle Positionen, die dort vertreten werden, sowohl Akteure aus der Rechten, wie aus der Linken finden. Ja, wir kennen bei, bei Nahost, wer steht dann jetzt nun an, an welcher Seite? Ja, da wird, wird das alles ganz kompliziert. Er sagte also jetzt diese Arenen, die Mauer aufmacht mit seinen Kollegen oben, unten, wir, sie, innen, außen, heute Morgen richtig. Aber er sagte auch, ja, wie ist denn das mit Israel, Corona? Das ist ja dann nicht einzuordnen. Und dann kommt seine fünfte Arena. Und das darf ich noch gerade zitieren. Welche Positionen werden medial umfangreicher und positiver abgebildet und welche vernachlässigt und wenn überhaupt thematisiert, negativ bewertet? Dass es sich dabei um eine gesellschaftliche Arena handelt, lässt sich leicht einsehen. Denn wie in allen anderen geht es hier um Lebenschancen und um Anerkennung. Wem steht mit einem Wort wie viel Bedeutung und Aufmerksamkeit zu und wer soll oder muss, aus welchen Gründen gering geachtet oder gar ausgeschlossen werden. Diese Arena nennt Richard David Precht drinnen draußen Arena. Und das halte ich für absolut wichtig, das so zu machen.
Und das dachte ich mir. Und ich erinnere mich daran, als wir Triggerpunkte lasen, haben wir auch gesagt, ja, die machen kurz diesen Hinweis, Twitter ist nicht diskursrelevant und so weiter. Aber ansonsten spielt das mediale eigentlich keine Rolle, sondern die schauen dann, haben ja Fokusgruppen gehabt, also konkrete Gesprächsteilnehmer vor sich, die Arenen verwechseln. Also der eine will eigentlich einen ökonomischen Diskurs, oder Migrationsreihen gedrängt, heute Morgen. Also der eine will das Klima retten, der andere sagt, aber es geht doch um das Jetzt und so, ja. Also solche Sachen. Ich finde, es fünfte Arena zu nennen, ist falsch, es Meta-Arena zu nennen, ist genau richtig. Ja. Denn im Grunde müsste man jede der einzelnen vier Arenen, die nämlich inhaltliche Arenen sind, auf dieses Methoden-Level, wie spielt es sich denn massenmedial nieder? Also nicht, wenn man am Gartenzaun redet oder im Ortsverband, im Verein, in der Familie, unter Freunden, auf einer Party, in der WhatsApp-Gruppe. massenmedial. So und das ist aber immer eine eigene Kategorie. Ja. Also man gründet nicht einen Europaausschuss im Bundestag, sondern jeder Ausschuss ist ein Europaausschuss, weil jede Themen inhaltlich europäisch, methodisch bearbeitet werden müssen. Bevor er auf diese Arenen zu sprechen kommt, habe ich mir hier schon drangeschrieben, als Notiz, ja ja, Ungleichheitsdiskurse sind ganz wichtig. Denn bei diesem drinnen draußen stellt sich ja schon vor, man überhaupt auf Steffen Maurer zu sprechen kommt, die Frage. Wenn jemand jemanden diskutieren sieht oder so eine Pranksendung, jemand schrottet einfach sieben Autos, weil das für drei Minuten tolles Infomaterial bei RTL ist oder so. Wir hatten ja auch in Deutschland die Christian Ulmen und so weiter, die über die Stränge schlagen. Also Leute, die sozusagen mit Absicht ausbrechen. Dann kann man ja vom Fernseher sitzen und sagen, ich bin hier ein junger Mann, ich bin im Let's Play Modus. Ich will das gar nicht selber machen. Es reicht mir völlig Zuschauer zu sein. Soll doch jemand anders für mich den Kontrolle halten und das Spiel durchspielen. Ich möchte nur in dieser Welt mal so zuschauen, in der das stattfindet. Oder man ist dessen Opa, der sagt, wieso darf der sich das trauen und ich nicht? Man macht fast eine Neiddebatte daraus. Warum darf der so über die Stränge schlagen? Ich habe mich 40 Jahre lang an alle Regeln gehalten. Wo ist mein Respekt, Herr Kanzler? Der kommt da nicht. Dann sieht man sowas im Fernsehen und sagt, wieso dürfen manche das und ich nicht? Das halte ich für eine sehr wichtige Gefühlslage. Deswegen würde ich sagen, Gefühle sind bei diesem Thema, wie schon bei Eva Iluz, auf der ihr auch sehr positiv zu sprechen kommt, ganz ernst zu nehmen und ganz wichtig. Und nicht mit, ja, das ist so schwammig, deswegen nehme ich mal lieber eine Demoskopie Zahl und binde die so dran, damit es so halb objektiv aussieht, sondern nein, wir können diese Gefühle als Gefühle mal selbst ganz ernst nehmen und dann aber auch richtig ausdifferenzieren. Wie schaut ein 25-jähriger eine Christian-Ulmen-Sendung und wie ein 65-jähriger? Und diese Differenzen sich mal wirklich genau vornehmen. Und dann kann man nämlich, Stefan Maus, Arenen des politischen Diskurses nehmen und sich ganz konkret fragen, jetzt gehen wir mal in den Metadiskurs, der Meta-Arena, wie wird das denn medial dargestellt? Ja. Und dann wäre es glaube ich super, also dann ist es einfach super hilfreich und ich finde auch, wir haben ja auch kritisiert, dass es da einen echten blinden Fleck bei Dricker-Punkten gibt, dass man das dann, diese mediale Realität, die Realität der Massenmedien mal richtig anerkennen. Und jetzt ist halt super, also ich verstehe, dass man das nicht einfach nachvollziehen kann, aber zu sagen, okay, es geht mir wirklich ums Gefühl. Was fühlt jemand? Und auf der anderen Seite, es geht mir auch darum, ganz ernst zu nehmen, was im Fernsehen stattfindet.
Ja, so.
Und das sind eigentlich beide sehr ganz, ach, wenn der Ernst des Lebens kommt, schalten wir den Fernseher aus und die Gefühle typischerweise. Nur wir leben ganz selten in einem wirklich heikelen Ernstes Leben, wo die Demokratie auf dem Spiel steht, sondern Alltag ist einfach Gefühle und das, was auf Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Und das müsste man noch ganz, ganz, ganz viel ernster nehmen. Und ich finde aber, Precht wagt sich hier schon ganz schön weit.
Ich finde auch, dass er da auch sehr klar schreibt.
Er sagt, ein Desiderat bleibt.
Stets waren es Eliten, die die gesellschaftlichen Normen verfügten. Mit einem Wort, die vorherrschenden Klassen verfügten über die vorherrschenden Meinungen. Dass sich daran in der zweiten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts manches geändert hat, ist sicher richtig, aber eben nicht alles. Gerade das macht die drinnen brausen Arena heute so bedeutsam. Geändert hat sich nämlich der Anspruch der Bevölkerung. Sie möchte gemäß dem demokratischen Prinzip möglichst gleichberechtigt über die Normbildung entscheiden. Zwar kann heute jeder seine Meinung in den sozialen Medien äußern, politisch normbildend dagegen, wird noch immer weitgehend das, was in den Leitmedien geschieht. Sonst wären wir in geopolitischen Fragen zum Beispiel sowohl im Bezug auf Nahost, also ökonomische Fragen und und und. Ja, wir wissen das. Wir kennen alle diese Umfragen zum Thema Vermögensteuer. Wollt ihr die? Ja, die meisten wollen eine. Die schmerzende Kluft zwischen Sagen können und auch gehört werden auf der einen und Relativa Ohnmacht auf der anderen Seite sorgt inzwischen 100.000-fach für Empörung und befeuert radikale Skepsis im Hinblick auf die demokratische Kultur im Land. Denn möchte wirklich jemand bezweifeln, dass bestimmte gesellschaftliche Gruppen in Berlin-Mitte stärker Normen bilden für die Gesellschaft sind als alle gesellschaftlichen Gruppen in Sachsen-Anhalt zusammen? Ja, das kann man nicht bezweifeln. Und diese Idee, also welche Möglichkeit hat man überhaupt, um zu Wort zu kommen, wer setzt da einen moralischen Standard und wenn ja, warum, wie wird also so eine Mehrheitsmeinung nominiert? Das ist etwas, was wir jetzt zum Beispiel in dieser Sendung gesehen haben, die die 100, also oder wir hatten das ja hier auch mit dieser Kindersendung, dass sobald man dann nämlich die Bevölkerung anders sprechen lässt, als sie das sonst darf in der kurzen Straßenumfrage, sondern die sollen dann Argument machen, dann geht das sofort los und dann wird man eingenordet, erst vom Moderator, dann vom öffentlichen Diskurs. Was hat er sich da nur gewagt zu sagen, Politiker in Amt und Würden ziehen dann über 18-Jährige her, die sagen, ich will lieber besetzt sein, als jetzt gegen Russland zu kämpfen und so etwas. Man kann diese Sachen, die da gesagt werden, selbstredend kritisieren. Nur was hier so getan wird, ist, dass man also eine Moral hat, gegen die verstoßen wurde. Und damit bekommt man also zweierlei heute durch soziale Medien und alles. Eine Inflation der Meinungsäußerungen, sagt Precht, aber auch eine Inflation der Meinungsabwertung. Und das bedeutet, dass also laufend Leute glauben, dass die Meinungsfreiheit in Gefahr ist. Und in gewisser Weise haben sie recht damit, weil diese extreme Meinungsabwertung sie so vorher nicht erlebt haben, wie sie sie jetzt erleben, wenn der Screenshot vom Tweet gemacht wird und es rund geht und so weiter.
So und dann beginnt im Buch ein Abschnitt, bei dem ich wirklich hoch interessiert war, wie du ihn findest, denn die Zielsetzung, bei der ist völlig klar, die teilst du mit Richard David Precht. Also alle Aussagen zum Thema Kunst und Kulturbetrieb, alle Aussagen zum Thema Was macht Nancy Faeser für Demokratiefördergesetze? Alle Aussagen zum Thema Welche Gesetze schützen eigentlich Robert Habeck und wie wendet er sie an und so weiter und so fort. So und dann geht es aber hier um soziale Kontrolle.
Also wir reden jetzt über das Kapitel anders sein als die anderen.
Ja, das weiß ich gar nicht. Das dritte. Ja, ganz genau, das dritte. Anders sein als die anderen, wo ich mir so dachte, jetzt kommt Peter Thiel, der Contrarian, der von sich erklärt und so. Also dieses Kapitel beginnt mit, dass junge Menschen heute mit einem Wehr- und Zivildienst konfrontiert sind, bei dem sie mal sich mit der Idee eines höheren als sich selbst auseinandersetzen müssen, nämlich dem Vaterland.
Ja.
So, jetzt haben wir natürlich einen Wehrdienstdiskurs, der genau nicht in diese Richtung geht, denn wir sagen ja ausdrücklich, nein, lieber Campino, ein 19-Jähriger, ein 17-, 18-Jähriger, der bei der Bundeswehr einen Befehl bekommt, bekommt dann nicht zum allerersten Mal in seinem Leben einen Befehl, sondern der ist ja jeden Tag in die Schule gegangen und dann hieß es, morgen ist die Mathearbeit und davon hängt dein Schicksal ab und so weiter und so fort.
Und der lernt auch nicht zum ersten Mal die Gesellschaft kennen.
Genau, so. Und jetzt liest sich das aber bei Precht mehr so Campino-artig.
Ja, der ist ja auch für eine Dienstpflicht und zwar für ältere und jüngere.
Denn wir sind ja aus einer Bedarfs-Weckungs-Gesellschaft in einer Bedarfs-Weckungs-Gesellschaft, die so fast jedes Vorzeichen umdrehte zur Frage, was darf ich hier eigentlich, was wollen Leute von mir, nämlich, dass ich eine Meinung habe, dass ich mein Geld ausgebe, dass ich hier in verschiedene...
Ich kann dir genau zeigen, was ich hier an den Rand geschrieben habe, beziehungsweise in meinen Notizen. Da habe ich zu diesem, dass wir nicht mehr in einer Bedarfs-Deckungs-Gesellschaft, sondern in einer Bedarfs-Weckungs-Gesellschaft leben und das diagnostiziert Precht für die 70er Jahre, drangeschrieben, hier Verweis auf Balsak, Das Paradies der Damen, also ein Roman aus dem 19. Jahrhundert. Auf den trifft das nämlich ganz genauso zu. Da kommen die Kaufhäuser und da werden dann diese Paradies der Damen beschrieben. Das heißt, der Kapitalismus an sich funktioniert ja nicht mit Bedarfs-Deckung, sondern natürlich mit Bedarfs-Weckung. Sonst kann es nicht funktionieren. Das ist das Erste. Das Zweite ist, dass das die Kritik ist, die ich schon ganz früher bei Precht hatte, als alle ihn auch gut fanden, sage ich mal. Und die ich auch an Harald Wälzer gleichermaßen habe. Das ist die Perspektive von Leuten, die sehr viel Wohlstand haben, bis hin zu Reichtum und tatsächlich sich alles fragen können, soll ich mir das kaufen? Brauche ich das noch für meine Identität oder meine Identitätserweiterung? Für die meisten Menschen trifft diese Konsumkritik nicht zu. Sie gehen zwar jeden Samstag durch die Einkaufsstraße auf der Zeil, sie haben aber nur 20 Euro in Portemonnaie. Und vielleicht kaufen sie sich dann bei H&M einen Oberteil, damit sie was gekauft haben und vielleicht brauchen sie das nicht wirklich, okay. Aber das ist nicht die Normalbevölkerung. Die Normalbevölkerung muss nämlich den Bedarf erst mal decken. Bedeutet, die müssen sehen, dass sie irgendwie über die Runden kommen. Und ich rede jetzt hier nicht nur von Bürgergelterempfängern, sondern die Miete muss reichen.
Alle mit mehr als zwei Kindern.
Das Kind braucht noch irgendwas für die Schule, noch einen neuen Ranzen. Und dann ist aus. Dann ist der Bedarf nicht nur, ist dann gerade gedeckt. Und da kann nichts mehr groß geweckt werden. Und wenn es mal gut läuft, dann hat man vielleicht mal noch die Gelegenheit, mal essen zu gehen, mal ins Kino zu gehen. Und ja, man wünscht sich auch, dass man sich das neue iPhone vielleicht im nächsten Jahr, wenn es etwas reduziert ist, kaufen kann irgendwann. Aber die meisten haben auch dann vom Durchschnitt kein iPhone, sondern ein günstigeres Modell. Das heißt, dieser ganze Diskurs, den wir hier wieder einmal erleben, und das ist ja bei Welser so, da ganz häufig auch bei Maya Göpel wird das so genannt. Wir kennen die Professional Managerial Class, also diese oberen Einkommen, zehn Prozent Leute. Ich rede jetzt hier nicht von den Superrechten. Bei denen stellen sich diese Fragen, was soll ich mir kaufen? Ich wollte mal Geld ausgeben, ich bin einfach mal in die Stadt und habe dann gesehen, da gibt es jetzt das und das und habe das gekauft. Diese Leute gibt es ohne Zweifel, aber das ist überhaupt nicht die Mehrheit der Gesellschaft. Das heißt, was hier argumentativ versucht wird, kann einfach nicht funktionieren, weil es auf keiner ökonomischen Grundlage steht.
Und das heißt noch lange nicht, dass wir deswegen das jetzt überspringen, sondern wir werden jetzt recht mal im Grunde Boden argumentieren. Also das, was du jetzt gesagt hast, gilt für 1850, 1950, 2050. Das ist die Voraussage, die wir machen können. 2050 kostet das iPhone genau so, dass nur 30 Prozent der Bevölkerung überhaupt in den Gedanken kommen, ich könnte, wenn ich jetzt spare, mit diesen drei Monaten kaufen. Davon machen das dann zehn Prozent und der Rest sickert halt so durch.
Und da gibt es ein paar Leute, die können sich auch zehn kaufen. Genau.
Und er schreibt jetzt, was um 1800 zum ersten Mal von den Romantikern in Jena vorausgedacht und von Sören Kierkegaard in Existenzphilosophie verwandelt worden war, ist heute keine Sache von exzentrischen Dichtern und Philosophen mehr, sondern selbstverständlich gelebte Wirklichkeit. Also ich kann heute Netflix anmachen. Ich empfehle das sehr. Die Serie über die Guinness-Familie spielt so 1800 bis 1850. Wie man Amerika entdeckte und so. Geile Kostümshow, abgefilmt. Also sie sieht wirklich spektakulär aus. Und da kann man genau dieses exzentrische sehen. Da sitzen einfach zwei Brüder zusammen, die zahlen immer so 5.000 Dollar. Da wird immer so eingeblendet in heutiger Rechnung 150 Millionen oder so.
Sehr gut.
Und die hauen es aber echt links so raus. Und dann werden einfach Frauen bezahlt und hier und da. Und dann muss man jetzt so eine Ehe arrangieren. Kannst du denen schon mal nach Amerika schicken? Da gibt es auch so ein paar. Den können wir doch schon mal hier. Es sind auch ganz viele Iren, die wissen doch, was unser Bier ist. Also die sind voll in diesem, die aristokratische Frau, die hat sich schon immer ausgelegt. Also die musste nicht auf die Pille warten, um dann irgendwann zu sagen, ich habe Sex mit wem ich will. So und es ist immer dieselbe Falle, in die getappt wird, dass nämlich uns heute Leute erzählen, die Nachwachsengeneration, die ist ja ganz anders drauf, so wie das schon so gerade erst gemacht hat. Also man kommt gar nicht aus diesem.
Das ist so auch so ein typischer Diskurs, aus dem wir so einen Marzehilcher Podcast erleben. Da sitzen dann Leute, die alle weit über eine Million machen im Jahr und sagen dann ja, die Leute sind nur noch dem Konsum hinterher. Und dann denkt man ja, genau eure Gruppe. Aber das war schon immer so. Man kann sagen, sie ist vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen größer geworden und das hat sich verbreitert. Es gibt früher nur die Hollywoodstars. Heute sind dann noch 100 Influencer oder 500 Influencer zugekommen. Aber ich hatte jetzt noch gelesen, die Schauspielerin Gloria Swanson war ein Stummfilmstar der 20er Jahre. Und sie hat im Jahr eine Million Dollar verdient. Das Durchschnittseinkommen eines US-Amerikaners lag bei 3.300 Dollar. Die hat also eine Million verdient und hat 600.000 Dollar im Jahr für Schmuck, Kleidung und Parfum ausgegeben. Das heißt, wenn ich natürlich mir diese Punkte ansehe oder wenn ich nur in den oberen 5% mich bewege, dann kann ich so nicht eine Gesellschaft zeichnen.
Das ist erstaunlich, wie ich habe es schon öfter gesagt, die Größe Deutschlands wird immer unterschätzt.
Ich habe es ja auch nochmal, wir hatten schon häufig über Meinungsfreiheit geredet, ich habe dann gesagt, warum sind die Leute so wahnsinnig aggressiv, wenn es Regelungen gibt, zum Beispiel bei der Sprache oder so. Sie haben relativ wenig an ökonomischen Mitteln, mit denen sie sich ausleben können, die meisten Leute. Und jetzt sagen sie, ich wähle lieber eine Partei, die gibt mir zwar kein einziges ökonomisches Mittel mehr, aber wenigstens kann ich dann nochmal bei Facebook abends wütend was schreiben. Und das ist auch eine Form von ökonomischer Ohnmacht, die stattfindet. Ich will das nicht damit rechtfertigen, ich will nur sagen, auch das ist ein Phänomen.
Ja, also ich möchte die Kritik, die wir jetzt kurz hier machen an diesen Textstücken auch, wirklich aufs Maximale. Richard David Precht lässt sich einladen für Abendveranstaltungen. Da ist er auf der Bühne, da wird moderiert, da sitzen 100, 200, 300, 800 Leute vielleicht. So, das kann jeden Abend stattfinden in Deutschland. An 365 Tagen, man verlässt danach diese Location, man geht in ein Restaurant, man ist wieder unter 50, 60, 70 Leuten und so. Und das jeden Abend rund um die Uhr. Und man kann in diesem Lebensszenario die ganze Zeit unter Millionären sein und darf trotzdem nicht ausblenden, dass 99 Prozent der Leute keine Millionäre sind. Ja. Die sind auch bei diesen Abendveranstaltungen nicht, die sitzen nicht am Nachbartisch im Restaurant, denen begegnet man zu gewissen Tageszeiten auf der Straße nicht, wir sind alle auch bei der Arbeit, da müsste man dann schon 6 Uhr am Nahverkehr teilnehmen, damit man da mal einen Blick hat und so weiter und so weiter. Und dass das immer wieder ausgeblendet wird, selbst von den klügsten Leuten. Es wundert mich mittlerweile nicht mehr, dass wir die ökonomische Diskussion einfach nicht auf den Boden kriegen. Deshalb ich nochmal umso mehr dafür werbe, wenn ihr irgendeine Frage habt, einfach GPT schnell klären, ihr kriegt eine Aufklärung darüber, wie die Durchschnittseinkommen sind, wie viel Leute, wie viel Urlaube gemacht werden, wie viel Urlaubstag überhaupt nur zur Verfügung stehen und so weiter und so fort. Man kann einfach GPT jetzt fragen und man kriegt diese Antwort. Und wenn man so ein Buch schreibt, muss man das einfach machen.
Ja, die Prospekte, die in diesen ganzen komischen Zeitungen beiliegen, vom Supermarkt einfach mal durchgehen, welche Preise sind dort, womit wird gelockt. Wen kann es also locken, dass man da 20 Cent weniger zahlen muss für gemischtes Hack? Bedeutet das also, die Leute sind einfach nur geizig? Nee, die haben einfach wenig Geld und sagen, toll, 20 Cent billiger, 100 Gramm. Ich kaufe das und dann schreibt eine Schülerin ihm in sein Poesiealbum, das er offenbar noch besitzt, schreibt rein, sei wie das Pfeilchen im Mose, sitzsam, bescheiden und rein und nicht wie die stolze Rose, die immer bewundert wird sein. Und da sagt er, das war noch die alte Zeit, in der man sagte, bescheide dich, denk nicht so groß.
Jetzt ist die Zeit der Rosen.
Und das ist nicht wahr. Die meisten Leute wollen vielleicht heute mehr denn jene Rosen sein, weil sie so viel in Social Media von den Rosen sehen. Aber die meisten Leute müssen das Pfeilchen im Mose bleiben, ob sie das anders formulieren bei Instagram oder sonst wie, weil die ökonomischen Verhältnisse so sind, wie sie sind. Und das hat mich auch so geärgert bei diesem Podcast da mit Karoline Wahl, wenn ich das gerade noch sagen darf, dass die ganze Zeit dann, ja, Gorda Marinić, du sagst, ja, und du nimmst dir den Erfolg und du machst es jetzt und so. Du alle müssen sich den Erfolg nehmen. Dann denke ich mir, ja, es ist ja toll, wenn jemand tatsächlich mit Bücherschreiben noch zu Millionärin werden kann.
Ich würde mir auch gerne den Erfolg nehmen.
Aber ich kann nicht jetzt den Leuten zurufen, die Frauen müssen sich nur den Erfolg nehmen. Die meisten Frauen müssen sehen, dass sie gleich ihr Kind wohin bringen und dann müssen sie zur Arbeit. Und nachher ist noch dies und das.
Scott Galloway weist auch immer wieder darauf hin, wenn ihr in eurem Leben eine Leidenschaft habt, bitte versteht, das ist euer Hobby. Ihr könnt daraus keinen Beruf machen und ihr werdet erst recht nicht Millionäre. Nur weil euch Millionäre von ihren Leidenschaften erzählen. Es sind Hobbys. Geh arbeiten, seid zufrieden mit den 3000 Euro. Mehr wird es wahrscheinlich nicht werden. Es sind Hobbys.
Da war ja Ben auch ganz verplüfft, als ich dann sagte, ja, die meisten werden nicht reich werden, die hier zuhören. Auch wenn hier immer Millionäre sitzen, die sagen, ihr braucht nur in ein Krypto investieren.
Genau, das ist alles so ganz virtuell. Also auf den Straßen begegnet man auf einmal Menschen, die ganz sich selbst zu sein trachten. Blablabla führt dann seitenweise zu setzen wie das Herz und das Schicksal hängen dauerhaft an niemandem, denn nicht ich muss mich der Welt anpassen, sondern die Welt sich an mich. Ich habe nun zwei Bücher darüber geschrieben, dass es keine Jugendkultur mehr gibt. Warum nicht? Weil 28-Jährige irgendwann einsehen, dass sie die Mietbürgschaft ihrer Eltern brauchen. Dass es keinen Sinn macht, sich mit denen zu überwerfen, den irgendwelchen Föllefanz, ich gehe jetzt nach Stuttgart und mache da was auch immer, sondern machen konkreten, jeder muss im Grunde Businesspläne schreiben, den zuerst die Eltern unterschreiben, dann der Vermieter, dann der Arbeitgeber. Und am Ende darf man selber noch mal, puh, ein Glück. Ich habe jetzt 17 Versionen hingelegt, zum Glück ist jetzt mal eine durchgekommen.
Aber du darfst dich piercen lassen, ohne dass die Eltern was dagegen haben. Das ist diese Minimalfreiheit, die noch gegeben wird.
Genau, und dann begegnen wir natürlich Leute, die, wow, die trägt ihre Hose aber frech. Aber das ist nicht die Realität. Also es ist einfach ganz falsch, wie das hier angelegt ist. Und ich finde, da steckt dann eben auch ein ganz anderes Duckmäuser- und Angstphänomen drin, auf das er dann da nicht zu sprechen kommt. Sondern er bleibt ja immer auf dieser…
Mich wundert auch, also dieser Angststillstand, da wird immer von sozialer Normierung oder sozialer Sanktionierung gesprochen. Es ist ja häufig eine ökonomische Sanktionierung im Sinne von, nicht nur bei der Meinung, sondern bei dem, was du angesprochen hast. Ich muss sehen, dass ich everybody starting down dort bleibe, damit ich weiter einen Job bekomme, damit ich Netzwerken, also Netzwerken funktioniert ja nicht so, dass man dorthin geht und mal mit überspitzten Meinungen irgendwo auftaucht, dass man kritiklaut werden ist, sondern Netzwerken funktioniert so, dass man versucht, sich gut zu verkaufen, sich anzupassen an die Norm. Man checkt so ein bisschen, wie wird hier geredet und dann versucht man sich anzupassen, um auch an wichtige Telefonnummern zu kommen oder LinkedIn-Profile. Das heißt also, wir haben da gerade nicht die Rose, die da unterwegs ist, sondern das Pfeilchen im Mose.
Ganz genau, ganz genau. Und dann schlägt er um auf Authentizität als Problem. Da finde ich es dann auch schon wieder ein bisschen besser, denn wir haben es hier mit einem, wie er schreibt, unselbstverständlichen Anspruch zu tun, nämlich, dass man sich authentisch ausleben kann. Jetzt mal klar, wir klammern das immer ein, dieses Netzwerken. Da würde ich jetzt sagen, die Leute haben nicht unbedingt Angst, bevor sie auf so Netzwerken gehen, aber sie merken danach, voll erschöpft. Also Theater spielen ist anstrengend. Man kommt dann nach Hause und denkt sich so, jetzt erstmal wieder zu mir selber kommen. Aber niemand geht über Netzwerke treffen und ist total bei sich selber und alle sagen, da ist schon wieder so ein junger Typ ganz bei sich selbst. Das ist genau umgedreht eigentlich, das Phänomen. Aber gut, diese Authentizität.
Die Konformität, wo sie überall eingefordert wird von einem. Das ist ja auch interessant, wir haben ja auch Leute, die zum Beispiel bei der Bundeswehr sind und was die auch dann erzählen von der Konformität, die das abverlangt. Ich habe ja mit einem gesprochen bei einem Live-Senat. Das war ganz interessant, weil der da auch aussteigen will und wie schwierig das ist. Oder ich hatte bei einem Vortrag in Köln vor einer Weile in Gespräch mit jemandem, der im Handwerk ist. Und da auch sagte, wie schwierig das ist, sich in einer Art gewerkschaftlich zu organisieren. Und dass sie dann eine Lösung gefunden haben. Ich könnte mir noch mal schreiben, wie das so genau jetzt ist, wie sie das jetzt organisieren. Ich fand das eigentlich ein ganz gutes Konzept. Jedenfalls, wir sehen eigentlich, dass Leute, die normal ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen, ständig in einer Konformität ausgesetzt sind. Das hat aber nichts mit Meinung oder so zu tun, sondern das ist erst mal das Ökonomische. Und das fällt hier so ganz raus. Und ich wundere mich darüber so, dass man das nicht zusammendenkt, wo man ja schon, wenn man über Meinungsfreiheit redet und dass Karrieren zerstört werden aufgrund von gewissen Dogmen, die plötzlich vorherrschen. Dann ist man doch eigentlich bei der ökonomischen Frage schon so schnell. Müsste doch dann über die anderen Dinge auch reden. Müsste auch sich die Frage stellen, ob vielleicht dieser unglaubliche Druck, der da in den sozialen Medien entsteht, jetzt muss ich aber hier mal was raushauen, vielleicht auch damit zu erklären ist, dass da was kompensiert wird, weil man es woanders so wenig machen kann, weil man zum Beispiel so sehr in dieser Wirtschaftswelt mit sich vereinzelt ist, weil man gar nicht mehr in dem Tarifvertrag drin ist, der der Kollege neben einem hat.
Genau. Und jetzt baut er daraus dieses Argument. Also aus seiner Sicht, die wir eben hier schon kritisiert haben, dass ja Rousseau damals anfing zu sagen, es ist nicht mehr die einheitliche Vernunft, die wir an der Beobachtung von Mitmenschen orientieren und dann inhalieren, sondern nein, wir horchen einfach in uns hinein. Wir schauen nicht mehr in den Himmel hinaus, sondern wir schauen in uns hinein. Und dann ein Bogenschlag, also aus diesem Startpunkt der Gefühlsmoralsfindung, die man in sich selbst begründet, in dem man immer wieder zurückkoppelt, was fühle ich eigentlich, kommt er auf die Misere zu sprechen, die ja Eva Illouz formuliert hat, was ich auch sehr gut fand, und zu sagen, die spätmoderne ist explosiv. Ich würde sagen, sie ist aus vielen Gründen explosiv und es hat auch sehr viel mit Gefühlslagen zu tun. Die Gefühlslagen hängen vielleicht viel mit vermiedener Aufklärung hinsichtlich ökonomischer Zusammenhänge zu tun, über die man jetzt denken könnte, wie man will. Und je nachdem, was an Kulturproduktionen rechts und links geboten wird. Aber wenn ich am 21. eines Monats Sorge habe um meinen Kühlschrank, weil er nicht voll genug ist, dann gilt halt einfach das marxistische Design und das Bewusstsein und nicht umgedreht.
Da geht es auch nicht ums Authentische. Ich glaube, er ist da stark, wo er diese Öffentlichkeit beschreibt, wie sie mit dem Authentischen umgeht. Wenn er sagt, mochte sich die Parole, die Klotüren auszuhängen, um mehr Offenheit und Intimität zu wagen, im Privaten nicht durchgesetzt haben. Im öffentlichen Raum hat sie es. Wer seine echte oder vermeintliche Betroffenheit oder gar Verletzlichkeit sichtbar macht, kann damit punkten. Authentisch zu sein, ist heute gesellschaftlich attraktives Verhalten. Das sehe ich auch so. Und wir kennen alle die Sendungen und Talkshows, in denen permanent davon berichtet wird, was man alles hat und wovon man betroffen ist. Und das ist aber dann so ein Schauspiel für eine größere Öffentlichkeit. Das hat jetzt wieder nichts zu tun mit dem normalen Arbeitnehmer.
Genau. Und diese Spiele, die da heute stattfinden, allein weil sie technisch möglich sind, also dass man noch drei Tage später in Storchies Affäre hat, wie ein Abend verlief, wo jemand über die Strängenschläge war, was auch immer. Das hat mit Angst nichts zu tun, sondern oder wenig, sondern hier läuft es dann mit, muss der sich wieder so aufspielen? Warum ist hier schon wieder? Warum habe ich da keine Chancen zu punkten? Ist das schon wieder der coolere Freundeskreis? Habe ich ja was verpasst und so? Ja, also da wird es auf der Ebene. Das hat aber mit diesem ihm wichtigen Bogenschlag von Demokratie, Meinungsfreiheit, Angst. Also da passt das nirgendwo rein, finde ich so. Das sind Lifestyle-Fragen, die man heute halt auch klären muss.
Lifestyle-Fragen und da hat sich einiges verändert, was ich zum Beispiel gut finde als Beobachtung, ist zu sagen, besonders befriedigend ist diese Schauspieler-Authentizität für viele nicht. Was ist meine authentische Besonderheit wert, wenn sie so gut wie unsichtbar bleibt? Der Frust, nicht zureichend wahrgenommen zu werden, ist heute auf einem gesellschaftlichen Höchststand. Je höher die Dosis an Aufmerksamkeit ist, die ich für mich und mein Sein einfordere, umso höher meine Anfälligkeit für Enttäuschungen. Und ein Sein, das sich über seine Authentizität definiert, ist weitaus anfälliger für Kränkungen und Verletzungen als ein Sein, das diesen Anspruch gar nicht erst stellt. Denn der möglichst authentische Mensch steht immer zugleich mit allem auf dem Spiel. Denn er hat keine Meinung und zeigt kein Verhalten, sondern bei allem, was er tut, ist er seine Meinung und ist er sein Verhalten. Und das ist etwas, was wir sehr gut beobachten können. Und glaube ich, erklärt doch ein bisschen, warum es so eine Aversion gerade gegen die Kunstkritik gibt, weil das sehr viele Leute sind, die haben nicht Musik gemacht, sondern die sind die Musik und die haben nicht ein Statement gemacht bei Twitch, sondern sie sind das Statement. Und weil sie alles als authentisch erfahren und begreifen, was sie tun, muss dann auch jede Auseinandersetzung, jede Kritische, ein Angriff auf deren eigentliche Identität sein. Und das ist etwas, was sicherlich gut beobachtet ist und auch dafür sorgt, dass die Meinung plötzlich so eng mit der Verletzung einhergeht.
Ja, aber da würde ich sagen, dass ist dieses Paradox am Anfang schon beschrieben, umso mehr Möglichkeiten und gerade diese neuen technischen Möglichkeiten wollten uns immer mit einem erweitern, entgrenzen des Möglichkeiten. Und das einzige, was entgrenzt wurde, ist halt Enttäuschung, negative Wut im Politischen, wie auch immer.
Aber sag mal, wenn wir auf dieses Coverbild kommen, dieser Axolotl, der da drauf ist, dann geht es ja darum, dass das ein Tierchen ist, das nicht reif geworden ist. Es kann sich paaren, die Reproduktion ist gesichert, aber irgendwie ist dieses Tierchen in seiner Jugend stecken geblieben und das diagnostiziert er für unsere Gesellschaft. Jetzt will ich zwei Dinge sagen. Zum einen will ich widersprechen und sagen, jemand, der Schule fertig macht, dann die Ausbildung macht und so, hat dann bald keine Möglichkeit, Axolotl zu sein. Wer vielleicht in so einem kulturellen Bereich irgendwas mit Medien hineingeht, hat da eher die Möglichkeit, Axolotl zu sein, wird vielleicht auch dann mit seiner Stimme viel lauter werden als die Person, die Azubi oder das ist. Und da haben wir wieder diese Verschiebung. Zugleich würde ich aber auch doch wieder Precht dahingehend zustimmen, dass ich eine gewisse Infantilisierung erfahre.
Ich war kürzlich in einem geschäftlichen Umfeld, also das heißt, ich war als Kunde wo? Und dann wurde mir erst irgendwie das Produkt erklärt und dann kam die Sonne raus. Also die Sonne zeigte sich am Fenster. Und die Äußerung war folgendermaßen, wir haben über Produkte gesprochen. Nein, die Sonne kam noch mal raus. Und das sagt mir jemand mit 35 Jahren. Was soll ich dann machen? Den Schnuller rausholen oder so? Ich weiß es nicht.
Jemand freut sich einfach über die Sonne.
Okay.
Das Problem ist ja immer so ein bisschen.
Aber du weißt schon, was ich meine. Du weißt schon, du kennst diese gewisse Infantilisierung.
Ich schaue alte Filme inzwischen auch sehr gerne, weil da relativ viel gezeigt wird, was gar nicht im Drehbuch stand, sondern was einfach so mitgezeigt wird. Und es ist ganz viel Verhalten von non-playable Characters sozusagen. Also Leute, die in der Kulisse so rumstehen. Schon allein die Mode und deswegen auch dieses Guinness-Ding wirklich ganz hervorragend. Weil es da völlig klar war, bevor wir hier in den eigenen Privaträumen diese Schwelle übertreten in den Raum, wo man Frühstück zu sich nimmt, wird man hergerichtet. Und zwar von drei Leuten. Weil das einfach Anstand ist. Wir treten nicht im Schlapperlook aufeinander. Und heute stellen wir fest, die Leute gehen im Schlafanzug zur Rewe. Und da kann man natürlich Ableitungen draus machen, insbesondere wenn sehr viele Smartphones dabei sind, um mir diese Szenerie zu filmen.
Ich denke zum Beispiel an hier den Frankfurter Flughafen. Ich steige ja da am Bahnhof.
Das sind Langstreckenflüge. Ehrlich gesagt, es ist sei mal über 1,90 und das ist problematisch.
Ich steige da ja am Bahnhof manchmal um und stelle mir inzwischen die Frage, darf man überhaupt noch fliegen, wenn man keinen Schlafanzug hat oder keine Jogginghose?
Ich mahne da bitte zu japanischer Zurückhaltung. Solange niemand bewusstlos umfällt, kümmert man sich nicht drum. Man ignoriert. Das ist die neue Höflichkeit. Einfach zu ignorieren. Kein Gedanken drauf verschwenden. Ich könnte jetzt etwas provokativ fragen. Wolfgang, hast du denn in diesen Momenten keine anderen Themen, über die du nachdenken könntest? Musst du dich denn an solchen Sachen aufreiben? Ich dachte, du bist ein Mann mit unendlichem Bücherstapel.
Ja, ich stehe ja da und warte auf dem Zug und sehe diese Herrscharen in Flip-Flops und Schlafanzug mir entgegenkommen und denke, sind wir in der Jugendherberge oder am Flughafen?
Also, ich kann ja jetzt mal in diesem Modus bleiben. Ich sage, mein Tenor ist ignorieren.
Ja, ich mache das ja, aber ich beschimpfe da niemanden. Ich will das nur hier ausdrücklich sagen.
Also Richard David Precht ignoriert ja nicht. Ich finde dieses Kapitel interessant auf einer Metaebene, weil sie auch einige sagt, über wie superreiche Philosophen heute reden. Ist ein bisschen dispektierlich, aber dieses Neotonie-Argument und der Axolotte. Neotonie, Neotenie ist ein Grundbegriff für das menschliche Leben. Es beginnt nicht erst mit der Geburt, sondern es ist eigentlich ein bisschen unklar. Wir haben ja Diskurse bis heute. Aber es findet irgendwann so eine Geburt statt. Man fragt sich eigentlich, warum kommt es so unfertig auf die Welt? Warum wird es nicht erst fertig im Mutterleib und kommt dann wie so ein Pferd einfach raus und steht auf und geht halt weg so? Nein, das Baby liegt erst mal flach. Laufen dauert ein Jahr. Reden anderthalb Jahre. Man hat unendlich lange mit einem unfertigen, man muss sich um das Ding kümmern, sonst gelingt es nicht, Leben zu tun. Und jetzt sagt er, es gibt eine kulturelle Neotenie. Wir sind in unserem Verhalten untereinander nie erwachsen geworden. Plötzlich kommt ein Mann im Anzug, bei dem doch jeder wissen müsste, wie man sich ab jetzt verhält, in ein Geschäft und kriegt erst mal den Hinweis, die Sonne. Das ist also ein Beispiel für kulturelle Neotenie. Jemand hat einfach nicht ganz geschnallt, dass du nicht 18 Monate alt bist, sondern älter.
Wir sind nicht in der Wiener Maya-Krabbelkörper zusammen.
Und jetzt gibt es ja zwei Möglichkeiten. Ich sage ignorieren, einfach mitfreundlich sein.
Ich ignoriere das auch. Es war auch ein sehr sympathisches Gespräch. Ich wundere mich dann nur manchmal, wie entrück dich meinen Zeitgenossen gegenüberstehen.
Ich will von dir sagen, wenn man Menschen wie dir gegenübersteht, die im Anzug geschniegelt usw., es ist auch manchmal schwierig, das Gespräch zu beginnen, weil man nicht genau weiß, wie könnte man. Deswegen fängt man erstmal bei der Sonne an, schiffre Wetter, warum nicht? Und danach weibt man sich so rein. Richard David Precht sieht das alles viel strenger. Der will das ignorieren, noch sich reinweiben. Der fragt sich einfach heute, was ist denn hier los? Leute werden in die Welt gesetzt und plötzlich gibt es so eine Befindlichkeitsevolution. Plötzlich muss ich immer Rücksicht nehmen, dass sie eigentlich Neugeborene sind. Und ich finde, das hat einen Punkt. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein Phänomen, das da ist. Nur ich würde halt sagen, das ist, was wir wollen. Das ist eigentlich die Zielsetzung von Gesellschaft, dass wir uns existenzielle Fragen oder dass wir auf die Straße hinaus treten und sagen, ab jetzt ist Gefahr, zieh dich ordentlich an, sonst wirst du ignoriert und ausgestoßen. Verhalte dich ordentlich, sonst kriegst du nichts zu essen. Dass das genau alles nicht mehr da ist, ist kein Rückstritt in eine Neotenie oder wie man sonst, sondern das ist eigentlich ein zivilisatorischer Fortschritt. Wir können auf die Straße gehen und selbst als kulturell sechs Monate alte, die einfach sagen, sorry, aber ich habe gerade eine Woche Konferenz hinter mir, ich kann mich jetzt nicht mit einer politischen Diskussion, die heute Abend stattfindet und das Plakat, ich will jetzt einfach Rammstein hören und spazieren gehen. Das ist auch nicht der Punkt.
Es geht doch vielmehr darum, dass dieser neue Subjektivität, die er da beschreibt, eine gewisse Hypersensibilität hervorbringt, die dann dazu führt, dass es im Meinungsmix zu so viel Konfusion kommt. Dass Leute, die sagen, sie wollen eigentlich erwachsen behandelt werden, sind aber zugleich auch Kinder und reagieren entsprechend zum Beispiel auf Kritik. Dann ist das etwas, was die Meinungsfreiheit zumindest schwierig macht, beziehungsweise den Meinungsdiskurs merkwürdig macht. Also wo jeder so sein will, wie er möchte und dann aber durchaus gebremst werden könnte in der Kritik, dann aber trotz sich eigentlich wie ein Kind wiederum darauf reagiert, dann kommt man in so eine eigenartige Form, was dann auch häufig bedeutet, dass es eine subtile Form der Macht aus Übung gibt.
Absolut, aber wir haben eben schon festgestellt und dahinter wollen wir auch nicht zurück, dass Leute, die so aussehen, wie als würden sie sich gerade ausleben, sie eigentlich nicht ausleben, sondern die haben einen anstrengenden Alltag hinter sich. Die haben Aufgaben erfüllt, von denen völlig klar ist, die sind hier gerade nicht Kinder, sondern die haben das ernsthaft gemacht. Wir wissen aus der Diskussion jetzt, wie wenig wirklich total Verweigere wir haben in Deutschland.
In dem Bereich ja, aber zum Beispiel jetzt, wir haben eben Rizzo da gehört in dem Clip, das ist ja im höchsten Maße kindisch.
Genau.
Das wäre ja hier mit gemeint, mit dem was Precht beschreibt. Ich glaube, wir müssen immer wieder sagen, Precht beschreibt eigentlich mediale Phänomene. Also mein Lieblingsformat ist ja dahingehend deep und deutlich. Dort sitzen ja Leute, die nur von ihrer Sensibilität und so weiter berichten und ihren Traumata und was weiß ich. Damit will ich denen das nicht absprechen, dass die das haben. Ja, let them, genau, ich übe das ein, let them. Ich sage nur, ich finde interessant, dass das zu einer Show geworden ist. Dass man fünf oder acht Leute zusammensetzt und jeder hat was Schlimmes zu berichten. Dass das geht, hätte ich nicht gedacht. Also wir hatten mal in den neunziger Jahren oder in den nuller Jahren diese Talkshow Jürgen Fliege. Dort hatte dann dieser Fernsehfahrer auch immer mit Leuten über irgendwelche Dinge gesprochen, die traurig sind. Aber dass das jetzt noch mal unter jungen Leuten so eine Show sein kann und dass wir ganz viele Podcasts erleben, in denen die ganze Zeit Leute als Axelottel sich aufführen. Und davon auch noch mal gerne geknuddelt werden wollen von der Community, dass das etwas ist, was ich erlebe und dass das stattfindet unter 40-jährigen Medienschaffenden in Berlin, ist ein Phänomen. Nur ist das ein Medienphänomen und nicht flächendeckend. Wenn ich jetzt gleich auf eine Baustelle gehen würde oder einen Supermarkt oder in eine Zahnarztpraxis, egal mit wem ich dort spreche, würde ich das so kaum wiederfinden. Bis auf gewisse kulturelle Formen, die übernommen wurden, dass man dann sagt, hm, die so, ne.
Gut, dann lesen wir den Text jetzt weiter, wie auch der Autor das wollte. Wir nehmen ihn ernst an dieser Stelle, der subtilen Form der Machtausübung. Das schließen wir jetzt an. Ich will nur kurz sagen, Leute, die von der Arbeit kommen, lasst euch einfach hängen. Also ihr müsst nicht einen Anzug anziehen, nur weil ihr nach Hause fahrt. Auf keinen Fall.
Das sage ich ja gar nicht.
Und wenn ihr in einem Podcast über Gefühle sprechen wollt, macht es. Lasst euch nicht kritisieren von irgendwelchen Leuten, die sagen, das ist aber infantil oder so, sondern das ist ja, finde ich, der zivilisatorische Fortschritt.
Aber man darf das doch kritisieren.
Ja genau. Aber das heißt noch, ich möchte nur ermuntern.
Ich halte ja niemanden davon ab.
Sehr guter Nachtrag. Sehr guter Expedition.
Nein, aber das muss ich jetzt nicht immer. Ich bin ja nicht irgendwie der König, der jetzt Gesetze erlassen kann. Ich finde das nur merkwürdig. Ich würde mich nicht in eine Talkshow setzen und jetzt die ganze Zeit von irgendwelchen Dingen erzählen.
Dafür wirst du auch nicht gebogen. Da werden ja die Leute sehr überrascht, wenn du plötzlich anfingst im Schweizer Literaturclub.
Ich könnte Geschichten ausdenken. Mal gucken.
So, also die subtile Form der Machtausübung ist ja das, was mich auch wahnsinnig interessiert. Der Hegemon und dieser Cursor des gefühlten Anstands. Wer die Deutungshoheit darüber gewinnt, wie man miteinander sprechen darf, gewinnt gleichzeitig maßgeblich die Inhalte, sagt er. Nun ist er aber in einer Zeit, in der ich sagen würde, also die Deutungshoheit wird bestimmt von Leuten, die ganz selbstverständlich von kleinen Pashas reden und deswegen zum Bundeskanzler gewählt werden. Die von der Radical Left, die irgendwie die Antifa als die große weltbeherrschende Antichrist-Organisation ausrufen, deren Präsidenten sie jetzt inhaftieren wollen und lauter solche Sachen. Also ich will das nur ausdrücklich mal dazu sagen, wo ich gerade den Cursor des gefühlten Anstands verbietet sich hier schon, ja, weil dann, das will ich mal etwas länger vorlesen. Es ist nämlich wirklich grotesk, wie dieses Buch umschlägt. Es hat nämlich dann gar nichts mit Alexander Dobrindt Macht im Grunde Stephen-Miller-Politik im deutschen Innenministerium und verkauft uns das bei Anne Will noch und wo auch immer, in welchen Podcasts und Sendungen, die ganze Zeit als das ist der Mainstream. So reden wir jetzt, sondern darum geht es ja gar nicht. Precht schlägt in eine andere Richtung.
Kommt jetzt das mit der genderfluiden Person?
Nein, jetzt kommt, denn eine Linke, ja, plötzlich ist die Linke an einem Schulden, denn eine Linke, die nicht mehr den Kapitalismus überwinden will, sondern den kulturellen Kapitalismus gleichsam mit auf die Spitze treibt, ist eine Stütze jenes Systems geworden, die sie früher stürzen wollte. Statt einer Weltrevolution fordert sie eine Selbstrevolution und versteht sich aufs Schaffen von Macht mit immer subtileren Waffen. Wörter werden auf diese Weise zu Pflugscharen, mit denen das gesellschaftliche Feld bestellt, eingehegt und normiert wird, erstaunlich blind gegenüber sich selbst beruft sich diese neue Linke dabei auf Michael Foucault und dessen libertäre Kritik an sämtlichen Formen der Machtausübung. Begreift sie wirklich nicht, dass die Herrschaft über die sprachlichen Umgangsformen selbst eine autoritäre Struktur, eine Dispositiv der Macht ist, wahrscheinlich sogar das hinterlistigste seit Menschen Macht ausüben. Da denke ich mir, sorry, aber das ist so krass. Welche Realität wird hier beschrieben?
Er beschreibt nur eine Realität, die jetzt schon tausendmal in Sachbüchern, Talkshows usw. durchgerichtet wurde.
Wenn es das überhaupt mal gab, ist das antike Geschichte.
Die aber sehr klein ist. Du hattest irgendwann mal gesagt, die gibt es, aber das sind so 5000 Leute.
Das ist kleiner als die Märkte.
Wir haben ja jetzt schon häufig darüber diskutiert, wie groß die sind. Ich würde sagen, in gewissen kulturellen Institutionen gibt es, ich würde das nicht so drastisch ausdrücken wie er, aber gibt es da eine gewisse Hegemonie dieser Leute?
Ich habe die Zahlen nachgeschaut, Wolfgang, weil ich genau wusste, dass wieder irgendwelche Institutionen, am Ende kommt jetzt noch gleich der Campus und so.
Nein, nein, der Campus ist wirklich nicht so.
Ich habe mir die ARD-CDF, die heißt jetzt nicht mal Online-Studie, sondern irgendwie Leute benutzen, Internetmedien. Man kommt inzwischen, wenn man alle Bildschirme zusammenrechnet, pro Person in Deutschland auf über zehn Stunden Bildschirme, Inhalte, Konsum.
Pro Tag.
Pro Tag. Ich habe dann verglichen mit, wie oft gehen Leute eigentlich ins Museum, als mal Schiffre für, das ist eine der großen Kulturinstitutionen.
1,6 Mal wahrscheinlich.
Also, die Zahl liegt jetzt, man hat sich von Corona wieder ein bisschen erholt, heißt es, 106 Millionen Besuche in einem 80 Millionen Volk. Ich alleine gehe einmal pro Woche in ein Museum. Das heißt, für mich entfallen schon 50. Das heißt, 50 Leute gehen für mich niemals in ein Museum. Nie. Die sind da nie. Die wissen nicht, wie es in einem Museum zugeht. Wenn Leute in ein Museum gehen, dann sind das Schulklassen, die ins Naturkundemuseum gehen, in ein Museum, in dem es irgendwie kulturell und künstlich zugeht. Und dann noch auf streitbare Weise, da sind keine Leute.
Ja, Stefan, ich will dir ganz zustimmen. Wir sprechen hier über ein winziges Phänomen, das es aber gibt und das die Leute, die die Demokratie abnehmen, die sorgen auch nicht für Angst. Nein, das ist Quatsch. Das ist auch wirklich Quatsch und wird hochgeschrieben. Ich sehe nur, ich kenne natürlich Leute aus diesen Bereichen. Und die können mir Sachen erzählen. Und die sind jetzt vielleicht nicht so drastisch, wie das, was Precht schreibt, aber da ist schon was dran. Was mich nur ärgert, ist, dass er so tut, als sei das jetzt die Linke. Nachdem er gesagt hat, also dieses Rechts-Links Schema ist ergraut, man braucht es eigentlich nicht mehr, sagt er jetzt, das ist die neue Linke geworden. Und dann frage ich mich, welche neue Linke hat er in den letzten Jahren kennengelernt? Ich bin ja laufend irgendwo zu Gast, ob das Asta-Gewerkschaft, Fridays for Future oder sonst was ist. Ich erlebe das, was er dort beschreibt, nicht. Was ich erlebe, ist, dass dort Leute streiken für bessere Arbeitsbedingungen, für mehr Umweltschutz, dass sie Kampagnen machen, wie Deutsche Wohnen enteignen und co. Oder sie setzen sich für politische Fragen ein, friedenspolitische oder sonst etwas. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass er auch nur annähernd registriert hat, wohin sich die Linke entwickelt hat. Ich wundere mich auch, dass er eigentlich noch mal so ein Buch schreibt, als sei jetzt, weiß ich nicht, Katja Kipping. Ich finde die gar nicht jetzt nur schlecht. Ich will das hier nur ausdrücken. Aber sie war so als Galionsfigur in einer gewissen Art der Linken. Er tut so, als sei Katja Kipping die Alleintone angebende der Linkspartei. Wir wissen, dass Katja Kipping da schon lange nicht mehr was zu sagen hat. Warum greift er nicht?
Katja Kipping macht konkrete Arbeit in diesen...
Ja, ja, ja. Ich weiß das auch. Ich will nur sagen, es wird so getan, als wäre nur das überhaupt noch links irgendwie gewesen. Und das stimmt ja nicht. Gerade wenn man sich jetzt die Linkspartei ansieht und mit den Punkten und Themen, die sie setzt, dann kommt auch das, was er da alles beschreibt, gar nicht vor. Also vielleicht findet er das jetzt, wenn er eine Sendung von Sarah Bosetti guckt, dann wird er das wahrscheinlich in etwa so wiederfinden. Oder wenn in der Paulskirche wieder irgendein komischer Literaturpreis verliehen wird. Aber sonst ist das ja nicht das, was da gerade die linke Politik ausmacht. Und das wundert mich dann auch so. Auch wenn er sagt, der Kaparatist alten Typs traute sich etwas, der Comedienne neuen Typs entblößt jene, die sich etwas trauen. Ja, es gibt diese heute Show-Kaparatisten, die quasi nur noch mal den Status Quo bestätigen. Aber wir haben doch andere Comedians noch. Wir kennen ja zum Beispiel Jean-Philippe Kindler. Ich habe jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass der den Status Quo bestätigt mit dem, was er macht. Und dann redet er von dem Mann. Also früher hat man so gesagt, das macht man nicht. Achte mal hier, was der Nachbar sagt. Und da sagt er, die vierte Person Singular, das Mann, früher ein argwöhnischer Nachbar aus Opladen, ist heute ein queeres Mädchen aus Berlin Mitte oder Normen korrekt ausgedrückt, eine genderfluide Person, wo man auch sagen muss, als genderfluid und queer müsste man eh noch mal differenzieren. Aber lassen wir das mal so stehen. Das ist doch Unsinn. Wo drückt sich denn die genderfluide Person in diesem Mann aus? Da kann man sagen, es gibt gewisse Scheren im Kopf, bei gewissen Leuten in entsprechenden Institutionen oder so etwas. Aber dass das jetzt hegomonial ist, das sehe ich nicht. Dass man aber an gewissen Universitäten sehr erbitterte Auseinandersetzungen hat, zum Beispiel um die Frage, ist die Geschlechterbinarität eine Tatsache oder muss man das fluider denken? Das ist so. Und das dort auch mitunter, unfair gekämpft wird mit harten Bandagen, und zwar von beiden Seiten aus, gebe ich alles gerne zu. Aber ich würde sagen, am Ende ist es doch immer noch der argwöhnische Nachbar aus Opladen, bei dem man sehen muss, dass man den nicht verärgert.
Da du jetzt Universitäten kurz gesagt hast, lass mich eine Pointe machen. Wir wissen aus ganz vielen so darstrukturellen Erhebungen, dass Studenten heute am ärmsten von allen dran sind. Höchste Prävalenz für psychische Defekte, die ernsthaft behandelt werden müssen, größte Armut. Wenn wir also von Universitäten sprechen, dann meinen wir nicht, da wird der Hegemon und da ist die Zukunft und da kommt irgendwann der Jahrgang, der alles bestimmt, sondern das sind wirklich die Ärmsten der Armen, die dort auch kein Geld bekommen für das, was sie machen jeden Tag, sondern irgendwann so ein Abschluss, bei dem sie nicht wissen, was das im KI-Zeitalter überhaupt wert ist. Ich will mich auch in einem Fall hier festbeißen, nur kurz um das zu nennen, vorher aber in allgemeiner Beobachtung machen, da du jetzt bei Ben ungeskriptet warst. Du hast da sehr viel Wert draufgelegt, den Rechten, sage ich jetzt mal grob, zu sagen, wenn ihr über Migration redet, ist das kein Problem Migration, sondern es ist ein Vermeidungsproblem. Wir können genau benennen, welches Problem ihr vermeidet, wenn ihr über Migration redet, nämlich über ökonomische Grundlagen. Wenn ihr progressive irgendwie kommt und mir von selbstgerechten Linken erzählen, ist das genauso ein Vermeidungsproblem. Das ist genauso ein Fetisch, wie wenn so ein irgendeinem Podcaster über die Migration redet, über die Migranten, ohne haben die nicht und so weiter alle Messer in der Tasche. Wenn Richard David Precht über die wogen selbstgerechten Linken, ist es für mich auf einer Ebene einfach nicht passend mit der Realität, ja und auch irgendwie mich als Leser verarschend. Ich will sowas nicht mehr lesen. Wir haben jetzt genug über die selbstgerechten wogen Linken, ich nirgendwo, ja und jetzt eine Kategorie, an der er das festmacht. Es gibt Codes, sagt man ja immer gerne, es wird über Sprache und so. Es gibt Codes, die zu beherrschen äußerst wichtig sind. Minimale Abweichung im Sprachgebrauch wird schnell und heftig sanktioniert. Wer Putzfrau statt Reinigungskraft sagt, disqualifiziert sich alleine dadurch. So, er macht konkret dieses Beispiel, Putzfrau und Reinigungskraft. Ich kenne sehr viele, also wirklich dutzendhaft Leute, die sich beim Putzen zu Hause helfen lassen. Ich gehöre selbst nicht dazu, aber hier in Frankfurt, man kann sich das vorstellen, Leute haben Unternehmen, Leute fliegen Flugzeuge, wie auch immer. Ihr muss gereinigt werden, die Leute haben das. Würde ich jetzt sagen, gibt es auch funkzahle Gründe, warum man das im Auto ist, zu viele Kinder, wie auch immer. Noch niemals habe ich in diesem privaten Kontext, und ich bin eigentlich im richtigen Mühe, das Wort Reinigungskraft gehört. Noch nie. Jeder spricht von seiner Putzfrau. Jeder. Dieses Milieu, das von der Reinigungskraft spricht, gibt es nicht. Also eins dieser zwei Beispiele, das zweite ist Kindergärtnerin oder Erzieherin. Ich möchte mich nicht einigen, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie die Leute, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es da eine große, ich habe Angst, Kindergärtnerin zu sagen. Ich sage Erzieherin, ja. Aber dass er das Beispiel Putzfrau nennt, von dem ich sage, no way. Das Argument hat Null Traktion. Ja, das ist ein reines Phantasman. Wenn Richard David Precht über die wogen, selbstgerechten Linken spricht, ist das genauso wie wenn Donald Trump über die Antifa spricht. Fantasie.
Ich will es jetzt nicht ganz so drastisch machen.
Ich sehe diese selbstgerechten Linken nirgendwo. Was ich sehe, ist Politiker, die mir jeden Tag zeigen, welche Bratwurst sie heute essen.
Ja.
Da kann ich die Namen nennen.
Da kann ich die Bilder zeigen. Dass irgendwer eine Veggie-Wurst. Da muss man schon weit in die Antigenschicht zurückgehen, wie man die Grünen vorgeschlagen hatten, dass man vielleicht in öffentlichen Kantinen irgendwas und so an einem Freitag.
Mittlerweile müssen die auch im Wahlkampf 20 Würste essen, um zu beweisen, dass sie normal sind.
Es sind Fantasmen.
Ja. Ich würde aber schon sagen, ich halte auch diese Beispiele für unsinnig, die ihr da rausgreift. Was ich aber schon unterstreichen will, ist, dass wir, also er geht da so ab von diesem, von diesem eigentlichen Thema. Also wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn wir mal bei diesen großen Konflikten bleiben, Corona, Nahost und Ukraine. Da haben wir ja die ganze Zeit diese Unterstellungskultur. Was? Keine Waffenlieferungen? Putin-Unterstützer?
Bist du jetzt auch schon ein Antidemokrat? Also da steht immer alles auf dem Spiel.
Holocaust-Deugner oder was? Weil du das und das nicht so... Also es geht ja nur mit dieser permanenten Unterstellung. Zu sagen, ja ich weiß nicht, noch eine Schulschließung ist nicht gut. Es gibt auch enorme Effekte. Was? Nee, ich bin Team Vorsicht. Ich bin Team Trosten oder was auch immer.
Listen to the signs.
Ja, listen to the signs. Also das ist all das oder diese Einbahnstraßen, die man dann baut. Wenn da irgendwas mit einer Pipeline ist, dann kann das nur der Russe sein. Es kann nur der Russe sein, weil es was mit der Pipeline ist. Punkt. Und dann geht es nicht mehr weiter. Also diese ganze tautologische Argumentation, die wird ja auch nicht mehr aufgelöst. Also das ist ja auch interessant, dass diese ganzen Leute, die da sich immer bei all diesen Sachen so ungeheuer sicher war, es kann auf keinen Fall aus dem Labor sein, es kann auf keinen Fall dies und das sein, dass die immer weiter damit fortkommen. Und ich glaube, er muss einfach noch mal dieses Buch Die vierte Gewalt schreiben. Oder ich kann sagen, er hat es ja auch schon geschrieben. Und dann Melanie Ammann, Sie sind gemeint. Da kann ich hier reinschreiben. Wie heißen diese anderen alle, die bei Apokalypse Filtercafé jeden Tag zu Gast sind? Diese ganzen Leute, die sind hier gemeint, die die ganze Zeit darüber wachen, ob jemand das oder das gesagt hat und dann auch schwierig geworden, irritierende Äußerungen, eine umstrittene Person, das sind die, die die ganze Zeit den Meinungskorridor verengen. Jan Böhmermann ist auch jemand, der den Meinungskorridor verengt. Wenn man sich damit beschäftigen will, dann kann man das machen. Aber wenn man hier so grundlegend was sagen will, dann muss man sich da anders auseinandersetzen. Dann finde ich es wiederum hilfreicher, wenn er sich wirklich mit dieser Frage von Desinformationen und Hassrede auseinandersetzt. Also das ist ja dann das Kapitel, wenn es um JD Vans und die Sicherheitskonferenz geht. Wir haben ja auch darüber hier damals gesprochen. JD Vans hält da so eine Rede und sagt, ihr könnt ja alle nicht mehr eure Meinung sagen. Da wird schon in Großbritannien Menschen das Beten verboten, weil da eine Abtreibungsklinik in der Nähe ist. Selbst in privaten Räumen dürfen sie nicht mehr beten. Dann schreibt dann Precht, ja, also es ist doch sehr viel differenzierter, als das von JD Vans betrachtet wird. Aber er sagt dann auch, na ja, bei diesem Fall, den Vans auch angesprochen hat, nämlich, dass in Rumänien jemanden nicht mehr gestattet wurde, zur Wahl anzutreten, nämlich dieser Gheorgescu, dass der plötzlich ausgeschlossen wurde, weil man vermutete, dass er wohl über Russland bezahlt wird, dass die TikTok-Kampagne darüber bezahlt wurde. Da stellte sich ja doch aus, dass dem nicht so einfach ist. Wer entscheidet, dass die Beweislast eindeutig genug ist, damit eine illegale Beeinflussung vorliegt, schreibt Precht. Im Fall von Gheorgescu stehen nicht transparente Geheimdienstbehauptungen der Beteuerung der Unschuld gegenüber. So kamen die vielen TikTok-Plätze, wie die rumänische Investigativplattform Snoop herausgefunden haben will, ganz ohne russisches Geld zustande. Gheorgescu hätte schlichtweg die Hashtags eines Konkurrenten für seine Eigenwerbung benutzt. Und die Frage, die sich sofort stellt, ist, hätte die EU es auch versucht, also hätte man auch versucht, diese Wahl nicht zuzulassen, ihn als Kandidaten nicht zugelassen, hätte man die Wahl annulliert, auch dann, wenn der Wahlsieger im ersten Wahlgang ein überzeugter Anhänger der gegenwärtigen EU-Politik gewesen wäre. Eindeutig provestlich und antirussisch. Und wenn er durch, sagen wir mal, Gelder von einer den US-Demokraten nahestehenden transatlantischen Organisation begünstig die Wahl gewonnen hätte und damit den Sieg eines russlandfreundlichen Gegenkandidaten verhindert hätte. Und er macht das natürlich als rhetorische Frage, denn wir wissen, wie das dann zu beantworten ist. Und wir haben das ja jetzt auch da in Moldau gesehen, dass dann auch doch ein paar westliche Journalisten, die für einen Stern oder so schreiben, auch gesagt haben, naja, so ganz sauber geht das ja bei ihr auch nicht vonstatten, wenn plötzlich da eine Brücke gesperrt werden und gewisse Leute nicht zur Wahl gehen können, die aber eigentlich wählen dürften. Das heißt also da, wo er jetzt tatsächlich beschreibt, dass man unter dem Label des Informationen wirklich die Meinungsfreiheit und auch die demokratische Freiheit beschneidet. Da finde ich, ist er wieder sehr nah dran und ist auch sehr konkret.
Ich bin, ja, stimmt alles soweit. Ich finde auch, dass er zitiere, Thierry Perrin, auch wenn er dann schon nicht mehr EU-Kommissar war, wie er so sagt, ja, das könnten wir auch in Deutschland machen oder so. Ja, also es war ja noch eine rein rumänische Angelegenheit. Oder was, Rumänien? Also das mit der annullierten Präsidentschaftswahl und so. Ich bin trotzdem ein Anhänger. Jedenfalls will ich diese Verschwörungstheorie nicht zu früh vom Tisch wischen. Auch wenn jetzt Richard David Precht sagt, diese Dynamik, die hier problematisch ist, ist vor allem eine inländische. Da braucht man jetzt keine äußeren Einflüsse. Ich schaue mir das in Amerika jetzt immer mehr an und denke mir so, das, was da gerade stattfindet, ist ja vor allem Great Television. Also Jugendliche machen ihr Smartphone morgens auf und sehen 30 Verhaftungen gewaltsam gegen ihre eigenen Freunde und so und hassen danach ihr Land. Genauso schauen Republikaner in dieses Ding, machen dann so einen Wogen, die selbstgerechten irgendwas Diskurs und hassen auch ihr Land. Und dann stehen sich die beiden gegenüber und dass das von einer chinesischen Software verursacht wird oder darüber transportiert wird, ich weiß, du bist begeistert von diesem Scott-Galloway-Gedanken.
Ich glaube einfach, nein, die Amerikaner sind blöde genug, um das selbst so zu machen.
Ich glaube, die hätten bei Facebook und YouTube früher eingegriffen, bei TikTok außerhand.
Ja, aber ich bekomme das doch bei Instagram auch angesehen. Ich sehe jetzt nicht, dass Meta eine andere Politik als TikTok da präsentiert.
Jetzt können sie ja nicht mehr. TikTok zieht ja, aber es ist breit.
Also er geht dann darauf ein, dass die EU eigentlich gegen Desinformation vorgehen will. So und da heißt es dann, was ist Desinformation und wer entscheidet darüber? Er zitiert das, die EU hat die Wahlen in Rumänien gekippt. Ist das eine Desinformation oder schlicht eine Übertreibung? Ist die unbewiesene Behauptung, dass Putin nach der Ukraine auch vorhat, Polen und Deutschland anzugreifen, eine Information oder eine Desinformation? Ist der Satz, Trump ist ein Faschist, informativ oder desinformativ? War der Satz, Corona ist wie eine Grippe, Desinformation oder einfach nur medizinisch angreifbar? War die Behauptung, Russland habe mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit in einem False-Flect-Manöver die Nord Stream 2-Pipeline gesprengt, die von einigen transatlantikern lange beharrlich verbreitet und nie wieder rufen wurde, eine gezielte Desinformation? Müsste man sie im Sinne des Digital Services Acts löschen, weil sie einer brisanten politischen Sache offensichtlich Falsches behauptet? Also wir sehen doch hier ganz klar, sobald man sich in dieses Gehege begibt und sagt, wir müssen Desinformation bekämpfen, kommt die Meinungsfreiheit darin um. Und das zu beschreiben, finde ich unglaublich wichtig und das auch in dieser Ausführlichkeit zu tun. Wenn Rumänien ein Gesetz durchbringt, jetzt im März 2025, zur Bekämpfung illegaler Online-Inhalte, dann ist die Frage, was ist damit gemeint? Der sagt, das Gesetz geht weit über den Digital Services Act hinaus. Drittes in Kraft ist der rumänische Staat befugt, unmittelbar auf die Inhalte von Social Media-Plattformen einzuwirken. Der Staat, das sind in diesem Fall der rumänische Geheimdienst, die Ständige Wahlbehörde, der Nationale Rat für audiovisuelle Medien und das Verteidigungsministerium. Alle können sie veranlassen, Inhalte in den sozialen Medien ganz ohne eine juristische Prüfung innerhalb von 15 Minuten zu löschen und oder Nutze zu sperren. Laut dem Gesetz fallen darunter bereits Zweifel an Wahlergebnissen sowie kritische Aussagen, pass auf, zu Wirtschaftsentwicklungen oder zum Gesundheitssystem. Aufgespürt werden illegales und anstößiges in Rumänien künftig durch KI-Systeme, die die sozialen Netzwerke nach Schlüsselbegriffen durchforsten, ungeachtet des jeweiligen Kontextes, in dem sie zu betrachten sind. Das ist eine große Entwicklung, die wir jetzt in Rumänien vielleicht schon besonders stark beobachten können, vor der ich mich aber auch im Ganzen fürchte.
Genau. Also wir haben es hier mit Gesetzen zu tun, die im Grunde unter dem Label laufen. Die AfD regiert schon.
Ja.
Jemand kritisiert, dass Trumps Zahlen zur Arbeitslosigkeit so und so sind. Dann wird zuerst der entlassen, der die Zahlen veröffentlicht. Danach wird jeder inhaftiert, der diese Zahlen kritisiert, die dann irgendwie kommen oder so.
So, wir haben diesen Schwachkopf-Harbeck-Fall, in dem Harbeck gefragt wird, wollen sie das wieder dagegen vorgehen? Er sagt ja, also findet dann so eine große Razzia statt, so eine Hausdurchsuchung. Das ist, wenn man es zu Ende denkt, demokratiegefährdend. Jetzt hat Richard David Precht das Argument gebaut, über Demokratie ist Meinungsfreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit Angst. Und wenn wir die Demokratie schützen wollen, müssen wir bei der Angst anfangen, dann die Meinungsfreiheit schützen, damit die Demokratie. Da wir aber immer mit Vermeidungsproblemen zu tun haben, will ich nochmal ein Thema reinbringen, das ich auch für sehr demokratiegefährdend halte, für das wir auch eine Lösung brauchen, von der ich weiß, die, die hier negativ besprochen und referiert werden, die sind offenbar nicht die Lösung, auch wenn es so aussieht, sondern ich will nur ein Problem beschreiben, für das wir noch keine Lösung haben, auch nicht das, was jetzt von Nancy Faeser mit dem Demokratiefördergesetz, oder wenn man da habe gesagt, nee, du brauchst jetzt einen Königsstatus, kannst du dich nicht, du bist beleidigt worden, wie jeder andere Beleidigungsfall, das abklären muss das nochmal, dass du ein Amtsträger bist und so. Also ich habe nämlich extra nochmal nachgeguckt, gerade auch, weil er über dieses CBS-Interview mit den deutschen Ermittlern, die noch darüber feichsen, dass sie da Hausdurchsuchung machen dürfen und so. In Deutschland und jetzt das Demokratiegefährdende, gibt es 200.000 Ratsmitglieder in den Gemeinden und Stadträten. Wir haben also nicht nur immer Bundespolitik, Bundesminister, sondern die Demokratie wird getragen in der Kommune, da wo echte konkrete Fälle geklärt werden, wo ist ein Zebrastreifen, wo ist eine verkehrsberuhigte Straße, was geschieht hier. Also 200.000 Ratsmitglieder und Gemeinden und Stadträten, 11.000 Bürgermeister, 294 Landräte mit 18.000 Kreistagsabgeordneten, die ihnen da zuarbeiten Mehrheiten herbringen. Unzählige Menschen, also es gibt einfach gar keine Möglichkeit, das rauszufinden, in Ortschaftsräten und bezirksverordneten Versammlungen. So, wir haben also nicht nur Politik im Bundestag, sondern da ist auch Politik, die zu schützen ist. So, und jetzt Kriminalstatistik. Allein im Vergleich 2023 zu 2024 gab es einen Anstieg der Gewalttaten gegen diese Leute, deren Zahl ich gerade genannt habe, um 70 Prozent. 70 Prozent. Das Bundesinnenministerium spricht auf Nachfrage der linken Fraktion von einem sprunghaften Anstieg bei Körperverletzungen. Das BKA verzeichnet 5.000 Straftaten gegen Amts- und Mandatsträger. Knapp zwei Drittel der Bürgermeisterinnen und Bürgermeister von 11.000. Zwei Drittel in Deutschland geben an, im Rahmen ihrer Tätigkeit schon einmal beleidigt, beschimpft, bedroht und tätlich angegriffen worden zu sein. So, ich will das jetzt nicht auf diese Frage, wie gehen wir da gesetzlich gegen vor, sondern auf diese Anstandsfrage. Angst, Gefühle, alles das, was Precht sehr ernsthaft behandeln möchte, aber finde ich ja auch selber zu, ich weiß, das ist ein bisschen schwammig und so weiter, entschuldigend einführt. Wir haben hier das Problem, dass Leute nicht nur zu viel Meinung in den Diskurs einbringen, sondern dass sie selbst noch Mittel wählen, um ihre Meinung durchzusetzen, von denen sie wissen, das ist gerade nicht demokratisch. Denn sie arbeiten nicht daran, eine Mehrheit für irgendwas zu organisieren, sondern sie bedrohen, sie verletzen und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn zwei Drittel der Bürgermeister in Deutschland, dann haben wir es hier mit einer ernsthaften Problemlage zu tun, die finde ich sehr viel mehr demokratiegefährdend ist, als diese Gefühlslagen von Habeck, wenn da irgendwas ist, und er sagt dann, ich gehe mal gegen alles vor. Ja, da wundert mich auch warum er gegen Agnestrak Zimmermann hier in dem Text nicht. Weil da finde ich kann man, also diese industrielle Abarbeitung von wirklich nicht eher abschneidenden Verhalten, das ihr entgegengebracht wird.
Ja, aber das sind ja auch diese NGOs, die oder Unternehmen, die jetzt zum Teil genannt werden, dass da ein großes Geschäftsmodell entstanden ist. Ich hätte auch Straks Zimmermann hier mindestens fünf Seiten gewidmet. Und was du da beschreibst, ist definitiv so. Ich habe mit einem SPD Lokalpolitiker gesprochen und der hat auch gesagt, bei so einem Wahlkampf, dann ist man da früher so losgezogen, jeder eine Straße mit Wahlplakaten und so. Man geht nur noch zu zwei, zu dritt und nur noch zu gewissen Tageszeiten und so. Man macht da nicht mehr später abends. Und das ist die Realität, die stattfindet, die natürlich mit so einem Demokratiefördergesetz nicht einzuhägen ist, sondern da geht es ja um ganz andere Dinge.
Da trauen sich Leute, ihrer Meinung nicht zu sagen. Das ist genau das Gegenteil.
Das ist was völlig anderes. Aber was wir dann über das Demokratiefördergesetz lesen, ist schon absurd. Unter anderem um NGOs und Initiativen, wie die dauerhaft und zuverlässig zu fördern, beschloss das Kabinett der Ampelkoalition im Dezember 2022 das Demokratiefördergesetz. Das damals von Nancy Faeser geführte Innenministerium wollte damit gegen Verfassungsfeinde und Gefahren für die Demokratie vorgehen. Zu der Frage, wer und was dazu gehört, werden Rassismus, Antisemitismus, Antiziganismus, Islam- und Muslimfeindlichkeit, Queerfeindlichkeit, Frauenfeindlichkeit, Sexismus, Behindertenfeindlichkeit und Extremismus, wie Rechtsextremismus, islamistischer Extremismus, Linksextremismus sowie Hass im Netz, Desinformation und Wissenschaftsleugnung genannt. Ja, ja, und da muss man einfach sagen, ja, das geht so nicht. Also für die Dinge, die da oben genannt werden, gibt es ja auch schon ganz viele Gesetze. Also ich kann ja Leute nicht einfach so beleidigen. Das ist ja gar nicht möglich. Das wird ja hier auch in dem Buch beschrieben. Aber Wissenschaftsleugnung, wenn ich sage, ich glaube nicht an die Wirkung von Aspirin oder so, oder sage doch, ich nehme davon drei Stück am Tag, dann ist das meine Angelegenheit. Dann kann man das blöde finden, aber das ist einfach so. Aber das muss man zurechtkommen. Und damit kamen auch Gesellschaften immer zurecht. Also das ist, er sagt dann ja auch, wie verrückt das wäre, wenn man sich darauf ganz einlässt. Er sagt, man erinnere sich etwa daran, wie während der Covid-19-Pandemie offiziell verlautbart wurde, eine Impfung schütze auch andere vor Ansteckung. Wäre das Demokratiefördergesetz damals in Kraft gewesen, hätte es mit Sicherheit massenhafte Anzeigen wegen Desinformation und Wissenschaftsleugnung gegeben, nämlich gegen alle Kritiker, die den Ansteckungsschutz bezweifelten. Da wir inzwischen wissen, dass das, was da im Namen der Wissenschaft verkündet wurde, so nicht stimmt, hätten alle zuvor angezeigten Kritiker den Spieß anschließend umdrehen und Politiker, Virologen und Journalisten, die die Nicht-Ansteckung behauptet hatten, wegen Desinformation anzeigen können. Was für ein gesellschaftliches Desaster. Und er überlegt ja jetzt, warum machen die Politiker das? Er sagt ja, die sind jetzt nicht einfach Sinister und haben da ganz andere Absichten, sondern er sagt, es kommt aus dieser Angst heraus, wir müssen was machen, Hass im Netz und so weiter. Was können wir denn tun? Wir brauchen mal ein Gesetz. Und da wäre doch gut, man hätte zum Beispiel auch eine staatsferne Medienaufsicht. Also hätte man trotzdem wieder eine Art Wahrheitsministerium. Das heißt, wie man sich dreht und wendet, man müsste eigentlich eingestehen, dass man da in dieser Weise nichts machen kann. Kann man aber nicht. Und deswegen kommt man in einen Aktionismus, der einen eigentlich in Teufels Küche bringt.
Genau. Da sind wir alle einer Meinung. Thilo Mischke, möchtest du was dazu sagen?
Ja, ich habe jetzt gar nicht so unglaublich viel Lust, diesen Fall aufzuholen. Es geht also dann um die Frage der Cancer Culture. Und er geht da auf zwei Beispiele ein. Einmal auf Thilo Mischke. Wir haben das mitbekommen. Er sollte eigentlich Moderator der Sendung Aspekte werden. Und ist es dann nicht geworden.
Aspekte, nicht Titelthesen.
Titelthesentemplamente, genau. Weil er dieses Buch damals geschrieben hat in 80 Tagen um die Welt. Und das wurde ihm dann alles ja wieder in Podcast vorgespielt, wie er sich dort äußerte. Dann gab es ja noch Podcastäußerungen, wo er sich so merkwürdig auf einen Evolutionsbiologen bezog. Wir wollen das nicht hier alles wieder aufrollen. Jedenfalls sagt er, da sieht man daran, wie die Cancel Culture funktioniert. Nämlich da gibt es jemanden, der in seiner Vergangenheit vielleicht dumme Sachen gesagt hat oder falsche Sachen gesagt hat. Aber warum soll er dann, wenn er doch zugleich ein preisgekrönter Journalist ist, nicht auch diese Sendung machen? Das ist ja nicht das einzige Beispiel, das er nennt. Ein zweites Beispiel nennt er Nemi El Hassan, die auch eine preisgekrönte Journalistin beim WDR war. Dann sollte sie diese Wissenschaftssendung Quarks moderieren. Rechte Medien hatten herausgefunden, dass sie bei den Al-Quds-Märschen oder zumindest bei einem teilgenommen hat, bei denen dann Hetzel gegen Israel verbreitet wurde. Jetzt weiß man nicht, was Nemi El Hassan, ob sie da irgendwo mitgetan hat, aber sie war zumindest dabei. Sie hat sich zwar dann dafür entschuldigt und sich von Antisemitismus dagegen ausgesprochen und sich für das Existenzrecht Israels ausgesprochen. Und dennoch hat man ihr die Sendung dann wieder abspenstig gemacht. Sie durfte sie nicht bekommen. Und da sieht man, wie also so ein Angststillstand bei den Sendern und bei den Institutionen da ist, dass sie, sobald es dann also Druck aus der Öffentlichkeit gibt, einmal von Kulturschaffenden, die sich zusammenschließen und einmal von vor allen rechten Medien, die sich zusammenschließen, dass das also bewirkt, dass man sich nicht hinter die Person stellt oder vor die Person, besser gesagt, stellt, um sie zu beschützen, sondern dass man sie dann dem ausgeliefert lässt und dann sagt, bevor wir dann noch weiter Ärger bekommen, schießen wir lieber die Figur ab. Und dass das so ist, das würde ich erst einmal bestätigen. Und ich bin ja nicht glücklich gewesen mit dieser Entscheidung für Tilo Mischke, weil ich ihn nicht als Kulturmann in irgendeiner Weise eine Erinnerung habe und ich ihn nicht dafür den geeigneten Kandidaten halte. Was mich aber schon verblüfft hat, war, dass sich der Sender so verhalten hat, dass er einfach ewig geschwiegen hat, dann so eine halbgare Erklärung rausgibt, um dann eine Woche später zu sagen, naja, macht die Sendung doch nicht. Da habe ich gedacht, gut, wenn man so umgeht mit Leuten, die man da engagiert, und bei Némi El Hassan war das ähnlich gewesen, dann muss ich sagen, bin ich heilfroh, dass ich nicht bei irgendeinem Sender angestellt bin.
Genau, also da wird ja auch immer Fokus auf Sachen gelegt, bei denen man sich fragt, es gibt keine Ahnung, wie viele Sender anstellt, es gibt 16 Bundesländer, vielleicht 15 oder so. Da wird die ganze Zeit Programm gemacht, da moderieren also tausende Leute. Und man kümmert sich dann um wenige Fälle von Nicht-Moderation, die sozusagen ansteht und dramatisiert die dann auf so ein mega Ding hoch. Das sind also wie schon bei Habecks Schwachkopfsachen, so finde ich. Zum einen sehr selektive Zugriffe auf Empirie und zum anderen werden die so irgendwo verortet, wo ich mich frage, dieses Buch heißt Angststillstand. Es heißt nicht, wie Organisationen mittlerweile in Führungsebene damit umgehen, was sie glauben, öffentliche Meinung sei und was das für sie bedeutet. Und in der Hinsicht finde ich es ein bisschen schon grotesk, ehrlich gesagt, wie man aus dieser Argumentation von Habeck über Quarks zu Thilo Mischke dann plötzlich auf uns sieht ihr, jetzt ziehen wir mal einen Strich, jetzt ziehe ich mal Bilanz, Zitat Precht, man kann sich den Spaß gut vorstellen, den Rechte daran haben, die Empörungsmechanismen der Linken gegen diese selbst anzuwenden und ihnen Homophobie und Nazi-Chargon zu unterstellen. Also es kommt plötzlich so eine Hämme in den Text, die sagt, seht ihr, liebe Linke, ihr habt jetzt zehn Jahre lang Vogue-Terror gemacht, und jetzt dreht sich der Wind, und jetzt kommen die Rechten und übernehmen irgendwie alles. Als ob die Nazis Vorbild für die Bücherverbrennung brauchten. Als ob das ein Anschluss war damals an, seht ihr, kein Wunder, wo das Kaiserreich so Link und Vogue war. Es war doch völlig richtig, dass die Nazis danach... So, und diesen Bogenschlag gibt es heute auch nicht. Ich behaupte...
Was ich einfach glaube, ist, dass es schon generell eine, dass es Defamierungskulturen gibt oder Unkulturen. Und dass das jetzt so ist, deswegen bin ich ja so sehr für Free Speech, weil ich sage, wenn man jetzt anfängt, ich will die Meinung nicht und den Verlag bitte schließen, dann weiß ich, dass das dann umgekehrt doppelt zurückschlagen wird. Ich weiß aber auch, dass die Rechten, also Trump würde auch ohne, dass jemals irgendwo jemand gecancelt wurde von links, würde der trotzdem diese Politik machen. Also ich glaube nicht, dass der die Inspiration durch die linke braucht. Nur glaube ich, ist man argumentativ trotzdem auf der sicheren Seite von links, wenn man sagt, wir machen das nicht. Weil das dann vielleicht, das erbringt jetzt zum Beispiel auch den Fall Sarah Lee Heinrich, die mit 13, 14 Jahren irgendwelche Tweets veröffentlicht, die, was heißt veröffentlicht, die sie postet. Und dann wird das vier, fünf Jahre später, wenn sie in Amt und Würden ist, also die Grüne Jugend leitet ihr dann vorgeworfen und alle eschofieren sich darüber. Und dass man gar nicht in diese Art der Diffamierungskultur kommen sollte, halte ich für an sich sehr richtig. Nur, ich glaube, dass das vorbei ist. Also ich will ja auch ganz deutlich sagen, hier werden nochmal Wünsche artikuliert, hier werden nochmal Ideale von Demokratien uns aufgeschrieben, aber das ist alles völlig vorbei. Also ich glaube, was wir jetzt nur noch erleben werden, werden die ganze Zeit solche strategischen Kämpfe sein und und und. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir noch mal zu irgendeinem Diskurs zurückfinden, den Richard David Precht sich da in seinen letzten zwei Kapiteln mit der Brüderlichkeit oder so wünscht und der Resilienz und was auch immer. Also ich halte das für, ich lese das fast als Anachronismus, wenn ich das im Buch habe. Ich mache mir da gar keine Illusionen. Nur sehe ich tatsächlich, dass es so eine Lust, glaube ich, an der Diffamierung schon gibt.
Ich will es wirklich ganz drastisch sagen jetzt als Vorwurf an Richard David Precht. Und du hast jetzt gesagt, das Phänomen, das er hier beschreibt, ich sehe das nicht, es ist vorbei. Ich möchte behaupten, dieses Phänomen, und ich weiß, es wird jetzt sehr viel Widerspruch ernten, aber danach mache ich erst den eigentlichen Punkt, hat es nie gegeben. Das, was es gibt, ist ein Donald Trump, der sagt, ich muss die Ausländer nicht nur rausschmeißen, sondern quälen, ich muss Bücher verbieten, und ich muss alles unterjochen, weil ich damit auch gegen die Linke kämpfe, die haben ja immer die Stränge geschlagen. Und dann kommt ein deutscher Sachbuchautor und sagt, dass Donald Trump alle unterjochen möchte, Bücher verbietet und Ausländer nicht nur rausschmeißen, sondern quälen möchte, finde ich nicht so gut. Aber bei diesem Hinweis auf die Linken, da hat er einen Punkt. Da möchte ich ganz deutlich sagen, da hat Donald Trump keinen Punkt. Donald Trump wendet sich nicht gegen eine linke Hegemonie, der mal Einhalt geboten werden musste, weil sie ja immer die Stränge strackt.
Also das eine ist jetzt, du sagst, es hat nie eine linke Hegemonie gegeben, aber du sagst jetzt nicht, es hat nie Cancelversuche von links gegeben.
Es hat die Cancelversuche gegeben, es hat alles gegeben.
Genau, das würde ich auch hier nochmal sagen.
Donald Trump regiert gerade das Weiße Haus, er hat die Parlamentarer, alle auf seiner Seite, alle Kammern, alles und den Supreme Court. Und er tut so, als hätte vor ihm AOC die Präsidentschaft gehabt, die mit einem super vorken Supreme Court irgendwas, es hat, wie du sagst, Versuche gegeben, in dem außerparlamentarischen Bereich, in einem Gebiet, von dem ich sage, Soryans, Smith-Soryan-Museum hat sich nie jemand verirrt, dass ihr da Tipps gemacht hat. I don't care. Das ist nicht mal in Geschichtsbüchern relevant.
Ja, und du hättest auch nicht Gender Studies, den weiß ich nicht, wo studieren müssen.
Das ist völlig absurd. Niemand hat irgend wem irgendetwas aufgezwungen und so weiter.
Ich will das ja auch da unterstreichen. Und das finde ich auch das Problem, dass er das so alles durcheinander wurschtelt in diesem Buch. Denn da könnte man sehr viel mehr Klarheit machen und könnte tatsächlich sagen, welche politische Macht war denn da. Denn wir sind ja jetzt auch nicht nur an den USA interessiert, sondern auch an Deutschland. Wir können da sehen, 16 Jahre Merkel-Regierung. Das war ja jetzt nicht eine linke Kraft, die dort 16 Jahre regierte. Und danach hatten wir eine Ampel-Regierung, die auch nicht links war mit Christian Lindner im Finanzministerium. Alles mögliche, stoppbar. Gut, dann gab es diese paar Verrücktheiten, über die wir jetzt hier schon gesprochen haben, die Felsa und dieses Gesetz. Und dann natürlich einige Forderungen von einigen jungen, wilden Abgeordneten, die in ihrer ganzen Ohnmacht dann noch Blödsinn von sich gegeben haben, um das mal so polemisch zuzuspitzen. Und jetzt haben wir wieder eine März-Regierung, bei der man auch nicht sagen kann, es geht wahnsinnig links zu. Also das muss man festhalten. Wo er das, glaube ich, sieht und auch erkennen kann, aber da müsste er das auch jedes Mal so benennen, ist in einem gewissen medialen Bereich und in einem gewissen kulturellen Bereich. Dort kann ich das wiederfinden. Sicher nicht in dieser Überspitzung, wie das Precht hier mit uns unterjubelt, aber wir finden es da wieder. Und da muss ich auch dir noch mal sagen, das ist so.
Wir finden das. Die Frage ist ja nicht, ob wir das finden, sondern ob der Herr Hegemon mal sagte, das ist jetzt mein Thema. Und das war?
Nein, es geht mir einfach darum, dass man, dass dieses zum Beispiel diese, diese Hypersensibilität in vielen Fragen, wo sie nicht sein muss, dass wir das finden.
Wir gehen mal die engen Beispiele durch, die er nennt.
Ja, die Beispiele sind dann wiederum nicht gut gewählt.
Ist ja jetzt egal. Es steht ja in dem Buch drin und das wird entsprechend oft gelesen. Also das Winnetou Buch hat der Verlag also zurückgezogen, weil es da irgendwie Hinweise gab, dass sich vielleicht Leute auf den Schlips getreten fühlen, wenn wir da irgendwie keine Ahnung. Ich nehme an, bei Winnetou geht es um einen Indianer, der also irgendwo ist und so weiter. Wo darf man die noch Indianer nehmen?
Es ist eine Kinderbuch-Adaption von Karl May.
Ja, ich will es mal auch folgenden.
Und da hat er aber erst mal, also ich finde diesen Fall jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig wichtig, ich würde ihm jetzt auch nicht zu viel Raum geben. Nur, dass dieser Ravensburg-Verlag sagt, wir entschuldigen uns, wir brauchen sensitive reading, das hätte uns nicht passieren können. Und man denkt so, ja, aber für wen, für was macht ihr das da eigentlich alles gerade?
Du hältst es für irrelevant und da muss man nicht an die große Glocke hängen. Ich sagte ja die ganze Zeit, das was hier kritisiert wird, da würde ich überall behaupten, das muss man jetzt nicht so an die große Glocke hängen. Die ernsthaften Themen sehen doch, wie war der Cursor des vernünftigen Anstands beim Thema Corona, beim Thema Ukrainekrieg und beim Thema Gaza. Und da würde ich sagen, all in, das ist genau das Thema, da hat Precht schon ein Buch drüber geschrieben mit Welser, das wir sehr gut fanden. Und wenn man da geblieben wäre, zu sagen, seht euch mal an, was drohen kann. Auf einmal sind alle für eine Impfpflicht, bei dem man dann feststellt im parlamentarischen Verfahren, sorry, wir kriegen das gar nicht hingebunden. Weder mit einer politischen noch mit einer wissenschaftlichen Realität kriegen wir das jemals auf den Boden. Und trotzdem bestimmt das die öffentliche Meinung. Wie kann das denn passieren? Und da gehört, und du sagst völlig zurecht, das Vignetou-Buch ja gar nicht rein in diese Reihe. Warum steht das aber hier? Und ich will es jetzt ausdrücklich kritisieren, wie es hier steht. Denn, zweite ostdeutsche Beobachtung, also es ist dieses Vignetou-Buch, bei dem der Verlag sagt, die sind irgendwie Befindlichkeiten, wir ziehen das mal zurück. Und dann sagt er, für die Rechtspopulisten ein gefundenes Fressen, ein willkommener Beleg dafür, wie weit der Wokeirrsinn inzwischen reicht, hat der Verlag über diese gesellschaftliche Konsequenzen überhaupt nachgedacht. Also sozusagen der Vorwurf an den Verlag, das zu machen. So und jetzt ist dieser ganz wichtige Punkt. Es sind vor allem die Rechten, nämlich zu 45 Prozent, die sagen, meine Meinungsfreiheit sehe ich beschnitten.
Das wissen wir nicht, ob das Rechte sind.
Das steht ja hier in dem Buch so drin, dass es nämlich bei den Linken, die sich progressiv sehen, sagen das nur so 20 Prozent, aber bei den Rechten so 45 bis 50 Prozent. Und jetzt hat man folgendes Phänomen, und das kenne ich aus dem Osten und ich möchte davor warnen, dass man nämlich sagt, bitte keine Ausländer, weil dann haben wir Nazis und vor Nazis habe ich Angst. Also sage ich nichts gegen Nazis, weil vor denen habe ich ja Angst, sondern ich möchte nicht, dass die Nazis geweckt werden. Deswegen Ausländer raus. Und das ist im Osten eine ganz legitime Meinung von Frauen und Männern, die niemals von sich behaupten würden, also mir geht es ja nicht um die Ausländer, mir geht es nur darum, sie wissen ja, wie das hier ist. Hier gibt es einfach viele Nazis. Ja, so und das ist dieser Punkt, wenn wir in diese Falle tappen und Precht macht das hier, dass wir den Linken die Schuld geben, weil sie die Rechten provoziert haben und dann ist für alle scheiße.
Man kann aber dem Verlag wirklich einmal sagen, dass da Unsinn getrieben wurde. Ja, natürlich. Und ich meine, ich weiß ja auch genau, wie das ist. Man hat ja manchmal mit so Leuten zu tun und das ist ja so, die machen einen Post, dann kriegen sie drei kritische Kommentare und dann rufen die direkt eine Sondersitzung ein und sind verzweifelt. Bei mir würde ich sagen, bei mir beginnt der Spaß als ab 100 kritischen Kommentaren.
Du hast ja völlig recht, was den Fall angeht, aber Precht macht daraus ein.
Genau, der macht so etwas Großes dabei, aber trotzdem muss man sich auch schon wundern, wenn der Verlag verkündet, wir haben zum damaligen Zeitpunkt einen Fehler gemacht und wir können euch versichern, wir lernen daraus und dann wird aufgezählt, was man alles für Maßnahmen macht, sensitive reading und so weiter und man entschuldigt sich für verletzte Gefühle. Da fragt Richard David Precht zurecht, wen hat der Verlag im Auge, wenn er sich für verletzte Gefühle entschuldigt? Haben tatsächlich so viele Indigene, Amerikaner auf Instagram gegen das Kinderbuch rebelliert? War überhaupt ein einziger Native American dabei, der sich beim jungen Häuptling Winnetou tief verletzt fühlte? Eine Verletzung lag wahrscheinlich nirgendwo vor. Wo und für was und bei wem? Aber entschuldigt man sich denn bei Deutschen, die sich im Namen von Indigenen verletzt fühlen? Aber sie sind doch keine Indigenen. Ist die Verletzung dann nicht kulturelle Aneignung? Und das ist ja etwas, was wir sehr häufig erleben, was ich ja auch schon bei manchmal nicht häufig, ich will jetzt sagen, es ist nicht mein Lebensthema, aber ich habe es manchmal erlebt, dass man irgendetwas sagt und dann fühlt sich jemand verletzt, meldet sich im Publikum und sagt aber nicht, ich fühle mich verletzt, sondern es könnten sich Leute von dieser und jener Äußerung verletzt fühlen. Nur diese Leute, die sind gar nicht da. Die sind gar nicht im Raum und man identifiziert sich aber so gerne mit irgendwelchen, die sich verletzt fühlen könnten. Und dass das eine Tendenz war oder ist, darüber können wir lange streiten, würde ich so festhalten. Und dass er dann noch mal so eine Generalkritik an der Kunst und der Literatur macht, das finde ich an sich richtig. Ich finde nur schade, dass er sich so auf dieses Voker und Triggerwarnung und all das bezieht. Interessant ist ja, dass er jetzt da nicht mal tiefer reingeht, wie die Kultur und die Literatur sich so stromlinienförmig verhält. Also wir sehen ja Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchhaltes. Das ist ja so ein typisches Beispiel. Angepasste Jurymitglieder, angepasstes Publikum, angepraster Preisträger und alle bejubeln sich und hängen sich Orden rum. Das ist ja so ganz, ganz typisch für all das, was wir laufend erleben. Caroline Ehmke bekommt einen Preis, Max Campino bekommt einen Preis, morgen sind alle nochmal beim Bundespräsidenten. Das ist ja das. Und dass das so ist, finde ich gut, dass er nochmal das herausstellt und sagt, Kunst und Literatur, ursprünglich das Experimentallabor der modernen Gesellschaft, werden zum Besten möglich überwachten Raum, nicht Provokation, sondern Harmlosigkeit und Unbedenklichkeit werden nun verlangt, wo das Exzentrische, das Exzessive und das Tabullose seinen Platz hatte. Heute erfahren wir tatsächlich über ganz viele, die sich mal so oder so äußern, umstritten, Kunst, Schwierigkeiten, wollen wir nicht. Und da hat er einen Punkt, ich finde nur schade, dass er sich so auf dieses Vogue-Trigger-Kram-Zeug bezieht. Stattdessen hätte er vielmehr darüber mal reden können, warum zum Beispiel fast keine dezidierte Kapitalismuskritik mehr von Künstlern geäußert wird. Warum wird eigentlich überhaupt nie eine Kritik an der Bundesregierung laut? Warum wartet man nur darauf, bis der nächste Ministerpräsident einen auszeichnet? Wo sind da die Stimmen? Wenn Christoph Schlingensich früher irgendwo in der Talkshow war, da waren Politiker, dann hat der den richtig rund gemacht. Was ist heute? Böhmermann tritt mit Wolfgang Weimar auf, um nochmal über KI so ein bisschen zu pallieren. Oder wir sehen dann, dass die Politiker neben den Künstlern sitzen und die Künstler noch mal sagen, ja, die Demokratie ist in Gefahr. Liebe Frau Merkel, liebe Herr Busbach, was können wir denn da tun? Ja, also so reden ja mittlerweile die Künstler mit den Politikern. Und da ist diese Angststillstand da. Denn ich kenne Kulturschaffende, um diesen hässlichen Begriff einmal zu verwenden, die mir sagen, ich würde mich gerne dazu äußern, mache es nicht, weil ich noch eine Förderung brauche für mein nächstes Projekt und all das. Und da haben wir tatsächlich so eine ganz merkwürdige mentale Bürokratie, wie er es nennt. Nur glaube ich, sind die Beispiele, die er herausgreift, nicht gerade die besten. Hätte er besser über den Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchpreises mehr gesprochen, er tut das ja an einer Stelle aber nicht dezidiert genug.
Ich habe ja am Anfang gesagt, dieses Buch hat Achilleszenen, die wirklich die Standfestigkeit der ganzen Argumentation betreffen. Und das will ich jetzt an diesem Beispiel nochmal präzisieren. Kann man heute in Deutschland noch frei seine Meinung äußern oder sollte man lieber vorsichtig sein? Ich habe ja vorhin schon gesagt, das müsste man aufsplitten. Kannst du heute in Deutschland deine Meinung noch äußern oder eben kann irgendwer irgendwo seine Meinung äußern? Du hast schon gesagt, sehr viele Leute sind ja gar nicht betroffen und äußern sich trotzdem die ganze Zeit und übernehmen so eine Anwaltschaft und sagen, ich komme zwar aus Jena und bin männlich und leite ein Museum, aber wir müssen jetzt auch an die Frauen aus Ghana denken und deswegen müssen wir das Museum so und so gestalten. Es ist gar keine Frau aus Ghana da, die einfach mal sagen können, was ist eigentlich der Fall. So und dieses Problem, diese Unschärfe, zieht sich durch das ganze Buch, denn das, was du gerade gesagt hast, hier übernehmen Leute immer Anwaltschaften für und so weiter, passt einfach nicht argumentativ zu dieser Argumentation. Vorher, dass wir alle im Axel-Lotte-Lafen-Stadium nur noch unsere eigene Meinung die ganze Zeit und so weiter, und dann sind wir nur noch ich. Jeder Klick ist ein Ich. Das ist ja genau nicht so. Hier geht es ja um diese Anwaltschaften.
Den großen anderen könnte man eigentlich sagen.
Genau und jetzt ist nämlich dieses große Problem, das ich mit diesem Buch habe. Du hast dich auch schon gewundert. Er ruft am Ende so zur Resilienz auf und fragt uns auch, können wir Empörungswellen nicht mal souverän durchstehen? Diese Frage ist absolut berechtigt. Wir müssen jetzt aber ganz tief und scharf einmal Ja und einmal Nein sagen. Wenn in einem Raum einfach nur zehn Leute Anwälte für zehn Leute sind, von denen sie noch nie gehört haben, von denen sie so wissen, irgendwo gibt es sie, wir müssen jetzt mal für die auch die Partei ergreifen, dann würde ich sagen, sorry, aber diese Empörung stehen wir jetzt einfach mal durch. Ich sehe hier kein garnisches Kind, dessen Rechte als Amputierte hier gerade geschützt werden müssen, wenn wir was auch immer ausstellen. Aber wenn in einem Raum, in dem politisch verhandelt wird, tatsächlich jemand aufsteht und sagt, sorry, ich komme aus Asien, ich spreche kein Deutsch, aber ich verdiene hier Geld, zahle Steuern und ich habe diesen und jenen Anspruch, dann ist das nicht einfach resilient durchzustehen, dass da jemand schon wieder so eine komische Meinung hat oder so, sondern da ist jemand wirklich konkret betroffen, er redet von sich und er hat ein echtes Anliegen.
Ganz genau.
So und wir können jetzt nicht beides, nur weil Richard David Precht am Anfang diese Unterscheidung einfach nicht macht, ja am Ende so sagen, ja gut, okay, da ist das Buch so ein bisschen komisch, sondern nein, hier muss ein neues Buch geschrieben werden. Was ist eigentlich, wenn ein Philosoph in Deutschland, der überall nur Vogue und links, selbstgerechte Linke sieht, wenn man dem mal kommt mit dem Argument, ja, aber hier hat jemand ein echtes Anliegen und er bringt vielleicht auch so ein paar Freunde mit und die haben das echte Anliegen und es ist deren Anliegen und ja, die wollen, dass in einem Museum ein Bild abgehangen wird. Die wollen, dass ein Straßenname geändert wird. Sagen wir da jetzt auch einfach, ja, das ist doch so wie das bei allen und überhaupt wir differenzieren hier gar nicht. Das müssen wir jetzt mal resilient durchstehen. Das sind Axel Lottels und so weiter. Und alle Argumentationen, die er uns jetzt hier angeboten hat, fallen für mich da einfach raus aus dieser Kategorie, dieser Realität, in der das zu verhandeln.
Ja, nur sagt er ja, dass genau die Leute das ja meistens gar nicht einfordern. Und da würde ich ihm schon zustimmen.
Aber was ist, wenn sie es einfordern?
Dass das da nicht der Fall ist. Da ist es ja eher eine Frage von gesellschaftlicher Anerkennung als solcher. Und das große Problem, was du da jetzt angesprochen hast, ist, glaube ich, eher, dass Richard David Precht dann doch sich eigentlich eine Gesellschaft wünscht, die so harmonisch funktioniert. Und wir betonen ja immer Nein, es gibt ja Spaltung. Und die ist auf der ökonomischen Arena zu suchen, in der ökonomischen Arena zu suchen. Er will ja doch am Ende so eine Gesellschaft sich vorstellen, in der es alle gut meinen und dann wird man schon wieder miteinander auskommen, mit mehr Resilienz. Und sein Begriff ist ja dann die Brüderlichkeit, die müsste wieder da sein. Und da ist aber dieser Denkfehler einfach, den wir auch so häufig finden. Also ich habe mich ja sehr empört, du weißt es, über Esra Klein und diese Sache mit Charlie Kirk und ich. Wir sind uns eigentlich nicht zu einer Meinung, aber wir wollten beide für Amerika das Beste. Und das ist einfach so nicht, wenn er sagt, wer eine Gesinnung hat, wer eine andere Gesinnung hat als die meine, hat unweigerlich die falsche, wird heute angenommen. Und so erfinden sich die Voken, eine Idealgemeinschaft, in der jeder Voke zu sein hat, die rechten eine, in der jeder Recht zu denken hat und die Mitte eine, in der sich jeder an den Mainstream anpasst. Nur eines kommt bei all dem nicht heraus, eine reale Gemeinschaft im Rahmen des Möglichen, in der der Blick stärker auf das fällt, was man teilt, als auf das, was einen von den anderen unterscheidet. Also mit einem Wort Brüderlichkeit. Und das finde ich ist dieser Denkfehler zu sagen, dass es da doch am Ende diese Aussage geben kann, wir sitzen alle in einem Boot. Das haben wir ja auch bei Gilda Sahibi so heftig kritisiert. Und ich finde, wir haben das zurecht so getan. Und wir müssen das hier auch wieder machen. Schreibt Bücher, analysiert die Phänomene, aber kommt nicht bitte mir am Ende immer mit so einem harmonischen, wir brauchen jetzt so eine gemeinsame Harmonie, wo wir uns dann doch wieder alle verstehen, auch wenn wir anderer Ansicht sind. Es ist eben ein fundamental Unterschied, ob man sagt, in Deutschland sollen nur Deutsche leben, die schon seit vielen Generationen deutsch sind, oder ob man das anders sieht. Und da gibt es auch nicht irgendeine Harmonisierung, die da stattfinden kann, sondern das ist ein realer Kampf. Und ich kriege es auch nicht mit Harmonisierung, mit Narrativen oder sonst was hin, dass die Ungleichheit in Deutschland keine Rolle mehr spielt, sondern die Ungleichheit zu überwinden geht nur über Umverteilung und Ähnliches. Und diese Idee immer wieder von dieser, also am Ende dieses ja fast so als Bundespräsident zum Leser sprechen, das ist etwas, was mich gestört hat. Also für mich sind da die letzten beiden Kapitel besonders schwach.
Genau, ja, das ist alles ärgerlich. Ich habe zwei Punkte, die ich noch hart kritisieren möchte. Vorher werbe ich nochmal dafür. In NRW gab es jetzt Kommunalwahlen und so. Wir wundern uns seit Jahrzehnten, warum werden Wahlprogramme geschrieben? Nun hat das Wahlprogramm Schreiben jede Verwunderung überlebt. Es werden einfach Wahlprogramme geschrieben. Was bedeutet, beim nächsten Wahlkampf, der euch betrifft, einfach die Diskussion aussetzen, das Wahlprogramm Gemini geben und die Frage stellen, ist das für mich gut oder nicht? Einfach alle Wahlprogramme mit Gemini geben und sagen, so, ich bin so und so alt, ich hab das, meine Lebenssituation, das verdiene ich, ist das für mich gut oder schlecht, was soll ich wählen? Dann gibt Gemini einfach eine Antwort. Man muss das nicht mehr ausdiskutieren. Das ist ja ein Buch über Diskurse, ein Diskursbeitrag über Diskurse. Und ich hoffe einfach, dass sich das langsam mal leer läuft. Und zwar nicht, weil ich jetzt sage, das sollte man machen, das ist super klug, sondern ich hoffe, dass wir irgendwann so demnächst jetzt bald, morgen vielleicht, vielleicht schon heute, in so Gesprächssituationen kommen, wo man einfach wirklich sich ernsthaft wundert. Sorry, das fragst du mich gerade.
Naja, ohne jetzt KI dafür, glaube ich, einzusetzen, hat die Linke ja schon so Einkommensrechner und so was gemacht und hat dann ja einfach gesagt, hier kannst du das eingeben, was du verdienst und wie du profitieren würdest von unserem Steuermodell.
Genau.
Dann ist es ja ganz einfach.
Sowas, genau. So, zwei Sachen, die mich hier wirklich, wirklich stören. Das eine ist, ich schließe nochmal an, worüber wir eben schon sprachen, auch was legale und legitime Meinungsäußerung oder Kultur ist, muss offensichtlich paternalistisch und maternalistisch überwacht werden. Bei maternalistisch sagt er wahrscheinlich ein Claudia Roth.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Da gehe ich mir so? Ja. Okay, ich lese mal noch einen Satz vor. Eine Gesellschaft, die offensichtlich nur noch politisch korrekte Kunst und Literatur doldet und Provokation durch eine Compliance-Ästhetik ersetzt hat, nähert sich in diesem Punkt Sitten und Gebräuchen an, die völlig unvereinbar sind mit den Grundwerten liberaler Demokratie. Ich erinnerte mich, wie ich in der FAZ-Sportredaktion ankam. Als Volontär ist man ja mal überall auch beim Sport. Und der verantwortliche Redakteur meinte damals, Sport ist im Grunde auch Kultur. Wir sind das Vöter, aber nicht für den Kopf, sondern für den Körper. Das fand ich einen sehr guten Gedanken. Er hat daraus den Schluss gezogen, Sport ist, was unter der Brücke die Skateboarder machen, die sich nach der Schule da treffen. Die Redaktion so? Nee, Sport ist, was bei Olympia im Fernsehen stattfindet. Je nach Sportdefinition kann ich jetzt sagen, wow, das ist die wokeste Scheiße ever. Vor jedem Spiel müssen sie ein Bekenntnis ablegen, laufen mit so einem Banner rum und dann wird noch eine Hymne der Glückseligkeit gespielt. Das ist der Olympia-Teil in der ARD. Unter der Brücke, und ich würde mal sagen, wir können die Olympioniken an einer Hand abzählen, aber unter der Brücke, da ist viel. So ist das auch hier. Klar kann ich jetzt, wenn ich meine Bücher in der Kriminate schreibe und hinter mir nur hochklassische Literatur und so weiter, dann irgendwie das so ein bisschen verwechseln. Aber wir leben nicht in einer Zeit, in der Paternalisten und Maternalisten uns die Kultur aussortieren und sagen, das ist nicht für dich, wir zeigen die und das, sondern wir leben in einer Zeit, in der auf dem Schulhof einfach reine Nazitexte vertrickert werden, in der Popmusik Hakenkreuze ganz selbstverständlich als Albumkaffer verwendet werden.
Ganz selbstverständlich nicht, das ist Kanye West, der ist nun wirklich durch.
Ja, aber der weiß genau, damit hat er den Präsidenten Amerikas auf seiner Seite.
Ja, das ist jetzt Amerika. Wie gesagt, hier bezieht er sich auf einen ganz speziellen Bereich der Kultur, nämlich einer, die gefördert wird.
Ja, Olympia, Bundesliga.
Genau, er meint die staatlich geförderte Kunst- und Kulturszene und ein bisschen darüber hinaus, das Galeriewesen und sonst was. Und da können Leute natürlich solche Geschichten erzählen, aber du kommst ja zurecht mit deiner Zahl und sagst, wie oft gehen Leute ins Museum.
Ich empfehle da einfach beim Thema, was ist Kultur, am öffentlichen Nahverkehr teilzunehmen und die Leute auf die Displays zu schauen. Denn das ist die Kultur, die sie prägt. Und da überwacht niemand irgendetwas. Da siehst du einfach alles, was du willst.
Ja, ganz sicher.
So und da gilt diese ganze Argumentation nicht.
Ich glaube ja auch, dass wir, das ist auch viel zu wenig beachtet eigentlich, dass wir glaube ich auch besonders so vehement in diesen alten Institutionen ein Festhalten an Normen und wir müssen nochmal von jedem abfragen, ob er auch wirklich die Ukraine ganz solidarisch unterstützt oder nur halbsolidarisch. Dass das ja eine Kultur ist, die sich jetzt gerade besonders nochmal abdichtet gegen all das, was da draußen auf den Bildschirmen stattfindet, was du da beschrieben hast. Und deswegen glaubt man, wenn man jetzt nochmals noch vehementer durchsetzt und ich glaube, wenn man jetzt noch siebenmal den Friedenspreis des deutschen Buchhandels an Applebaum und die Irrigen verteilt, dann wird man endlich über die gesiegt haben, die bei TikTok sich anders informieren. Und das scheint mir jetzt gerade so eine besondere Abwehrbewegung zu sein. Das ist schade für die Leute, die da jetzt gerade Kunst drin machen wollen. Aber so ist das. Ich stimme dir aber auch zu. Dies ist nicht die Mehrheit, wie sie Kultur wahrnimmt. Selbst für das Kino. Weißt du, wie oft die Deutschen ins Kino gehen? Ich glaube, 1,6 Mal.
Jeder Deutsche geht einmal ins Kino.
Ja.
Und ein paar gehen zweimal.
Die waren dann fast alle in der Schuhe des Manitou.
Genau. So, jetzt finaler Punkt. Der wird sicherlich, Richard David Precht, selber noch viel ärgern oder Ärger einhandeln, denn ich finde, so geht es nicht. Hier im Text steht und ich habe jetzt einiges schon zu, also gab es jemals linke Shitstorms und so weiter gesagt. Ich werde es jetzt also nicht nochmal kommentieren, sondern einfach nur kontrastieren mit dem, was in der Wikipedia zu den beiden Grundbegriffen, die er hinnent, steht. Er schreibt, Shitstorms sind, wenn man so will, die Progrome des 21. Jahrhunderts mit der gleichen Entlastungsfunktion. Und ich möchte gerne zitieren aus der Wikipedia.
Ja, da habe ich auch gedacht, das kann dann nicht sein.
Das Progrom wird soziologisch definiert als einseitige und höchstens gering organisierte, nicht staatliche, von der Mehrheitsbevölkerung ausgehende Form extralegaler Gewalt, die sich gegen ein weitgehend wehrlose ethnische Gruppe richtet, wenn die Mehrheit keine Abhilfe des Staates gegen eine empfundene Normverletzung durch die Minderheit erwartet. Also, deswegen haben wir das auch, weil das ist so krass an der Definition, dass wir nur ganz wenige historische Beispiele haben. Aber Privatleute rotten sich zusammen, um auf Judenjagd zu gehen, weil sie wissen, der Staat wird sie da niemals für vorurteilen. So und deswegen sterben da einfach in Selbstjustiz und so Juden. Shitstorms, laut Wikipedia. Shitstorms bezeichnet im Deutschen das lawinartige Auftreten, negative Kritik bis hin zu Schmähkritik im Internet. Der Duden nahm das Wort 2013 auf und definierte einen Shitstorm als Sturm der Entrüstung in einem Kommunikationsmedium des Internets, der zum Teil mit beleidigten Äußerungen einhergeht. Shitstorms sind keine Progrome. Das eine ist ein rechtes Phänomen, das andere von mir, lass es ein linkes Phänomen sein, aber das ist die Diskrepanz.
Ist es ja noch nicht mal. Also ich will zwei Sachen noch dazu sagen. Erstmal ist ja der Shitstorm einer, der sich häufig gegen Leute richtet, die schon eine mediale Aufmerksamkeit genießen, sonst funktioniert er ja meistens nicht. Es sei denn, man hat, und das finde ich dann wirklich nicht gut, solche Menschen, die mal einmal im Fernsehen zu was befragt werden, sie sich da vielleicht unglücklich äußern und dann werden sie durch die Manege gezogen. Ich finde das ungehörig und gerade bei so einem Format wie die 100, da sind die wahrscheinlich auch mit 180 Mark abgespeist worden, dass sie da drei Stunden in diesem Studio knien müssen.
Die tun uns auch nicht alle leid.
Und dann werden die noch mal am Ring durch die Nase gezogen. Das dürfen wir nicht mal setzen. Weil da einer irgendwas gesagt hat, ist man dann bei Twitter der Depp der Nation. Das ist das eine. Also Shitstorms richten sich meistens gegen Leute, die irgendwie schon in der Öffentlichkeit stehen. Wenn Stefan sich zum Beispiel über Heidi Klum und ihre Fotos am Hauptbahnhof äußert, dann kann man den mit einem Shitstorm überziehen.
Dann bin ich ja ganz alleine.
Das ist ja nicht mal eine Lamine. Nein, umgekehrt, wenn sich Leute jetzt darüber empören, dass du über Heidi Klum, dass dir Taylor Swift lieber ist als Heidi Klum, dann kannst du ein Shitstorm erleben. So, meine ich jetzt. So, das ist das eine. Und das zweite ist auch, dass diese Shitstorms ja nichts mit einem Prochrom zu tun haben können. Es geht ja da um eine Frage der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie. Wer kann jetzt gerade etwas für sich dabei herausholen? Ich war ja, wie du das sagtest, bei Ben ungescriptet und habe dort unter anderem gesagt in diesen vier Stunden, dass wir mittlerweile in einer Situation sind, in der ich Migranten kenne, die nicht mehr mit dem Regionalexpress durch den Osten fahren, sondern eher ICE oder am liebsten Erste Klasse. Was passiert? Man versucht mir da jetzt einen Shitstorm zu kreieren, dann haben irgendwelche rechten Twitter-Profile da so einen Clip draus gemacht. Der verrückte Linke und Martin Sellner hat wohl, das hat mir gestern ein Freund geschickt, noch mal ein Video aufgenommen, bei dem es dann so klingt, als würde ich erste Klasse Tickets für Migranten fordern, was ich ganz lustig fände als Idee. So funktioniert der Shitstorm da. Also es hat wirklich gar nichts damit zu tun. Und da glaube ich, wäre ein, also ich meine, Richard David Precht rühmt sich so oft damit, dass er da in den sozialen Medien nicht vertreten ist. Vielleicht wäre es doch manchmal ganz gut, denke ich, weil man das dann besser einordnen könnte, was zum Beispiel ein Shitstorm ist und was auch wirklich einer ist. Denn nicht, wenn man 50 kritische Kommentare bekommen hat, ist man auch gleich in einem Shitstorm. Sondern man hat einfach auch 50 kritische Kommentare bekommen. Und weißt du was, morgen wird schon keiner mehr wissen, dass Martin Sellner ein Video darüber gemacht hat, dass ich irgendwas zu Migranten im ECE sage. Das ist, so muss man es auch mal sehen.
Genau, das ist wirklich ein wichtiger Unterschied zwischen Shitstorm und Progrom. Ein Tag später sind die beim Progrom einfach tot und beim Shitstorm haben sie es vergessen, dass es das gab.
Weil ja morgen wieder ein neuer Shitstorm ist. Rechtlich hat sich in Sachen Meinungsfreiheit gar nicht so viel in Deutschland verändert. Aber dennoch ist es so, dass wir über die subjektive Meinungsfreiheit sprechen müssen. Denn diese schwindet, wie Richard David Precht in seinem Buch Angststillstand, warum die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet, erklärt. Wenn er sich mit dieser subjektiven Meinungsfreiheit auseinandersetzt, mit dem Cursor-Journalismus, wenn er darüber spricht, dass es da durchaus Leute gibt, die den Meinungskorridor verengen und dass das eine gewisse Angst bei Funktionären auslöst und einen gewissen Anpassungsdruck, dann hat er da viele richtige Punkte. Wo er sich aber dann doch sehr stark verheddert, ist, wenn er allgemein über die Kulturszene spricht, wenn er plötzlich von den Voken Kulturkämpfen anfängt, dann wird er nicht mehr so präzise, wie er es anfangs war. Und dann gleitet er auch ab in am Ende doch eine sehr merkwürdige, übertreibende Position, der man dann doch mit der Realität, vor allem auch mit der ökonomischen Realität begegnen müsste.
Ja, ich habe mich sehr auf dieses Buch gefreut, denn der Hegemon kommt darin vor und ich interessiere mich für ihn. Aber er ist nicht sehr standfest, denn dieses Buch beginnt nicht mit einem archämedischen Punkt, sondern mit einer Achilles-Ferse, was mich zu einer Methodenkritik führt. Richard David Precht sollte das Thema noch mal schreiben. Aber erst, nachdem ihn jemand einem Smartphone geschenkt hat, damit er mal wirklich am Kunst- und Kulturbetrieb teilnehmen kann, wie jeder normale Mensch, statt ständig irgendwas von im Fernsehen, im Museum und in der Literatur zu sagen, dann hätte auch dieser Herr Hegemann hier eine größere Traktion und Standfestigkeit. Und dann würde ich ihm am Ende auch mehr zustimmen als diesmal.
Gute Literatur aus Argentinien von Samanta Schweblin. Der Band mit Erzählungen heißt Das gute Übel ist bei Surkamp erschienen, wurde aus dem argentinischen Spanisch von Marianne Gareis übersetzt. Das sind Geschichten, ja, wie soll ich sie beschreiben? Sie sind eigentlich ganz dem Realismus verhaftet, aber irgendwas ist dann doch merkwürdig verschoben da. Da ist etwas Wundersames, das sich im Alltag plötzlich auftut. Da ist möglicherweise auch ein Schicksalsschlag. Da ist ein kleines Vergehen, das dann doch etwas Größeres bedeutet. Es sind Anrufe, die plötzlich kommen und die Welt wird nochmal auf den Kopf gestellt, beziehungsweise man geht nochmal durch, was man erlebt hat. Da ist zum Beispiel die Geschichte ein fabelhaftes Tier. Die Ich-Erzählerin bekommt einen Anruf von Elena. Lange haben sie nicht miteinander gesprochen. Sie waren einst befreundet, beziehungsweise die Ich-Erzählerin war befreundet mit Elena, ihrem Mann und ihrem Sohn. Und Elena verkündet, dass sie bald sterben werde. Und sie will aber noch einmal hören, wie das damals war mit Peter, also ihrem Sohn, der schon lange Tote ist. Ob diese Ich-Erzählerin noch irgendwas zu erzählen weiß. Ich werde sterben, Leila, so heißt die Ich-Erzählerin. Deswegen rufe ich dich an. Die Erzählerin, ich betrachte meine Füße, bewege die Zehen. Jenseits des Balkons streichelt der Wind die Baumwipfel. Und auf einmal muss ich an das Pferd denken. Das heißt, was hier schon diese besondere Beschreibungsgabe von Samanta Schweblin ist, ist, dass ja eigentlich man erwarten würde, der Dialog geht jetzt weiter. Ich werde sterben leider, deswegen rufe ich dich an. Also würde man eigentlich jetzt sofort die Replik erwarten. Aber erst mal wird unterbrochen und wir sehen sofort, die Ich-Erzählerin, wie sie da sitzt. Und wir kennen das selbst, wenn wir telefonieren. Wir blicken vielleicht an uns runter, sehen unsere Zehen oder so. Aber jetzt kommt das Pferd und man denkt, was hat das mit einem Pferd zu tun? Nach vielen Jahren denke ich wieder daran, an dieses erste Mal, als ich es mit bedrückender Klarheit sah. Ich fuhr gerade vom Flughafen zu Elinor und das Taxi hielt an einer Ampel in der Avenida Vergara, direkt neben dem Tier. Es war schwer bepackt, zog einen Wagen mit einem Haufen Matratzen und ein Mann verpasste ihm Peitschenhebe, damit es schneller lief. In den Vorstädten von Buenos Aires hat es immer Pferde gegeben, aber damals wohnte ich schon lang im Ausland und der Anblick überraschte mich. Der Pferdebauch war so dicht neben mir, dass ich meine Hand hätte ausstrecken und ihn berühren können. Er wirkte geschwollen und proportional zum übrigen so mageren Körper. Die Beine krumm, das Fell um die Zügel abgeschabt. Aber ich erinnere mich vor allem an die Art, wie das Pferd seinen Kopf umwandte und mich ansah. Es sah mich direkt an mit diesen großen dunklen Augen. Ich weiß, dass es lange her, sagt Elena. Also wir sind wieder in dem Telefonat. Aber erinnerst du dich an die Verkleidung, die Peter an dem Abend trug und die er selbst gebastelt hatte? Ich will, dass mir jemand etwas über meinen Peter erzählt. Dazu wird also jetzt diese alte Freundin aufgerufen und sie versucht, den Abend zu rekonstruieren. Das war ein wunderliches Kind. So jung, aber so begabt. Wirklich begabt, nicht immer nur wie. Alle Eltern behaupten von ihren Kindern, dass sie so unglaublich begabt sind, sondern wirklich äußerst begabt, aber irgendwie auch merkwürdig. Wenn er gefragt wurde, was er werden will, dann antwortete er nicht wie die üblichen Kinder, sondern er sagte, er will Pferd werden, was immer das dann heißen mag. Und genau mit diesen enigmatischen Dingen, die uns begegnen können, wenn wir auf Menschen treffen, wenn wir Situationen haben und das Leben uns doch unheimlich wird. Von diesen Begegnungen, von dieser Art durch die Welt zu gehen beziehungsweise von dem, was uns so plötzlich trifft und betrifft, davon erzählt Schweblin. Da ist eine andere Geschichte, die heißt das Auge in der Kehle. Die beginnt so. Mein Vater geht ans Telefon. Er ist 27 Jahre alt und wie alle in den 90ern, nimmt er den Hörer ab und weiß nicht, wer dran ist. Die Leute rufen an und sagen, ich bin es, Kamen. Oder sie sagen, ich rufe vom Postamt an. Oder sie sagen, guten Morgen, ich wollte Ihren Termin bestätigen. Aber wenn das Telefon in der Nacht klingelt und mein Vater rangeht, sagt niemand etwas. Er wartet mit dem Hörer am Ohr, bis er es satt hat, dort zu stehen und nichts zu tun oder Fragen ins Leere zu stellen und manchmal sogar ausfällig zu werden. Er legt den Hörer auf und auch, wenn das mechanische Klicken der Angelegenheit ein Ende setzt, ahnt er doch, dass da noch mehr ist. Das Schweigen, das ihn jede Nacht anruft, heftet sich jeden Tag, den ganzen Tag über an ihn. Und er muss unweigerlich an Morris denken. Wer Morris ist, verrate ich jetzt hier noch nicht. Jedenfalls wird die Perspektive des Kindes eingenommen. Aber diese Erzählung geht dann erst einmal zurück. Sechs Monate, bevor diese Anrufe angefangen haben, bin ich zwei Jahre alt. Also hier erzählt eigentlich ein zweijähriges Kind uns eine Geschichte. Und wir werden aber mit dem Kind auch reifer. Aber das Kind erzählt anders, als andere Kinder erzählen würden mit zwei Jahren. Was kann man da schon sagen? Hier heißt es, ich sitze im Wohnzimmer meiner Großmutter väterlicherseits vor einem grundig Fernseher. Wenn es mir langweilig wird, krabbele ich und taumle ich umher, untersuche jeden Gegenstand, der mir in die Hände kommt, berühre alles, was für meine Hände zugänglich ist. Allen Menschen, denen meine Mutter mich anvertraut, sagt sie, bitte, pass auf ihn auf. Selbst meinem Vater sagt sie es an jenem Nachmittag zweimal sogar, bevor sie uns im Haus meiner Großmutter alleinlässt. Wenn ich die Funktion der Gegenstände nicht wirklich verstehe, lutsche ich daran, beiße hinein, schlage sie gegeneinander, also das, was Kinder tun, wenn sie da so krabbeln. Die Badeschuhe gegen die Fernbedienung vom Fernseher, die Fernbedienung gegen den Taschenrechner auf dem Regal, Großmuttes Uhr ab in den Mund. Und bevor ich sie auf dem Boden liegen lasse, schlage ich ein paar Mal damit auf den Teppich. Bei diesen Spielen aber passiert was. Er nimmt eine Lithiumbatterie in den Mund und die öffnet sich und es ist da in der Kehle plötzlich was. Und das Sprechen ist nicht mehr möglich. Das steht natürlich auch für das Schweigen überhaupt innerhalb einer Familie und auch das Rätsel der Eltern gegenüber einem Kind. Was kann das Kind ausdrücken oder was will es nicht ausdrücken? Was bleibt ungesagt? Davon handelt diese Geschichte. Und sie ist so wunderbar geschrieben, deshalb, weil hier eine Autorin ist, die es versteht, präzise Sätze zu schreiben. Und damit meine ich, ganz knare Beobachtungswahn zu zeigen, wie das eigentlich ist, wenn das kleine Kind sich angewöhnt hat, auf den Vater, wenn er nach Hause kommt, freudig zuzurennen. Und das, wann immer der Vater diese Geste des Empfangens macht, das Kind freudig auf ihn zurent. Das aber das Kind nicht freudig auf die Mutter zurent. Warum? Und man weiß es nicht. Und solche Dinge zu beobachten, aufzuschreiben, ist grandios. Und dabei aber auch so eine Verschiebung herzustellen, also ins Magische hineinzugehen, dass man also sich aus diesem Realismus löst und denkt, da ist noch etwas anders. Da gibt es auch doch eine Verbindung zu vielleicht sogar den Totenwiesen. Eine Erzählung, wo es eigentlich um eine Katze geht, die stirbt, geht. Also es ist eine besondere Art des Schreibens, ein magischer Realismus, könnte man sagen, wenn man es sich leicht machen will. Es ist jedenfalls sehr, sehr gute Literatur, der ich viele Leser wünsche.
Gibt es eigentlich Literatur, um noch nachzufragen, die, also sagen wir mal so, das Buch Die Holländerin wurde jetzt ausgezeichnet und jede Erwähnung geht auch auf den Stil. Ja, so und ich dachte mir dann so, ich habe das gelesen, als ich gerade im Zug saß, ob man nicht einfach eine Olympiade macht und sagt, okay Leute, Literatur, Inhalt, schön und gut, aber wir gehen jetzt mal auf den Stil. Welches ist der Roman, der den innerhalb des kurzmöglichsten Zeitraums spielt? Also es klingelt an der Tür, ist der erste Satz und danach nur Gedankenwelt, was auch immer, Erinnerungen, wie auch immer, endet mit, er macht die Tür auf. James Joyce.
Ulysses, das ist ja ein Tag. Und das ist ein fetter Roman.
Ja, sehr gut, sowas. Also da könnte man nochmal so methodisch einfach, was man so wirklich...
Doch, das gibt es viele. Also das gibt es auch von Don DeLillo.
Oder einfach Romaner, die nie auf dem Erdboden spielen. Im dritten Stock, im fünften Stock, dann kam der Hubschrauber, holte ihn ab. Irgend sowas.
Nein, aber gerade diese Zeitdehnung und Verdichtung, das ist schon was, was jetzt im Schreiben des 20. Jahrhunderts sehr häufig vorkommt, dass man also möglichst das dienen kann. Denn es ist ja in der Tat so, dass jetzt das Gelesen eine gewisse Zeit braucht oder man braucht eine gewisse Zeit, um etwas zu lesen. Und dann ist ja die Frage, wie genau kann man es beschreiben? Weil was ich jetzt eben beschrieben habe, ist ja schon der Punkt. Also die Freundin ruft an und normalerweise gibt es dann eine Replik am Telefon gleich. Aber wir bekommen dann erstmal einige Zeilen darüber, dass sie auf dem Balkon sitzt, wie die Atmosphäre ist. Bedeutet also, ist verstreicht, während wir es lesen, ja sehr viel mehr Zeit als eigentlich dort an Zeit innerhalb der Geschichte verstreicht. Und das ist schon etwas, was in der Literatur häufig thematisiert wird.
Sehr interessant, da man ja auch in eigenem Rhythmus liest. Manchmal verleiht man ja Bücher, die kriegt man dann zwei Jahre lang nicht zurück und sind immer noch umgelesen.
Ja, man sollte glaube ich gar keine Bücher verleihen. Ich verleihe nicht gerne Bücher.
So, what explains the liberal-conservative-happiness-gap? Es gibt eine Lücke in der Glückseligkeit, in der Zufriedenheit zwischen liberalen und konservativen. Nate Silver, ich hatte ihn ja kurz angesprochen, ist jetzt auch bei Substack groß zur Gegend und war dort in so einem Substack-Gespräch, irgendwie eine Stunde lang Gespräch und hat dann zu diesem Gespräch nochmal so Show Notes geschrieben, die ja diese Fragen hier aufwerfen, die uns auch interessieren. Wir gehen also nur kurz auf diesen Show Notes Text ein und haben hier zuallererst mal eine Grafik, die ich dir aus der Entfernung zeige. Es geht um die liberalen und um die konservativen und ob sie ihre Mental Health selbst reportieren mit excellent oder pur. Und du siehst, dass bei den liberalen 45 Prozent sagen, mir geht es schlecht. Und bei den Konservativen sagen 50 Prozent, mir geht es voll gut. Und so wie hier 50-50 entsprechend verteilt ist, sagen 20 Prozent der liberalen, mir geht es sehr gut. Und 20 Prozent der Konservativen, mir geht es voll schlecht. Also wir haben diese Verteilung von der Hälfte geht es schon mal grundsätzlich gut bei den Konservativen, grundsätzlich schlecht bei den liberalen. Und 20 Prozent der liberalen sagen, wow voll super. Und das spiegelt sich dann wieder bei den Konservativen, da sagen nicht 20 Prozent voll super, sondern 20 Prozent voll schlecht. Also ein richtiger Kontrast, könnte man so sagen. Es könnte eigentlich nicht weiter auseinander liegen. Und dann hat er diese weiteren Zahlen, in denen er verschiedene Berichte, wie zum Beispiel ein CDC-Bericht vom September 2020, der auf 2019 blickte und so auswertete. Wir haben ja auch schon über die U-Kurve gesprochen, die es nicht mehr gibt oder die es angeblich nie gab, je nachdem. Das sehen wir hier auch. Also die Jungen sind besonders anfällig und zeigen es besonders deutlich. Und jetzt will ich auf diese Zahlen hier eingehen. Das sind die, über die wir schon ganz kurz sprachen, beim Thema Haushalt Income. Datengrundlage sind hier 50.000 Befragte und zwar seit 2006. Es gibt große, große Studien, in dem Falle der Harvard Cooperative Election Study. Also es ist eine Studie, die sich vor allem um Wahlverhalten dreht, aber die Grundgesamtheit immer wieder ausführlich analysiert. Also 50.000 Leute seit 20 Jahren. Die sollen Selbstauskunft angeben von 0 bis 100, was ihre psychische Gesundheit angeht. Männer sind erstmal grundsätzlich zufriedener als Frauen. Junge Menschen sind grundsätzlich unzufriedener als Ältere. Menschen mit höherer Bildung sind grundsätzlich ein bisschen glücklicher als Menschen ohne hoher Ausbildung. Und du siehst hier immer, alles, was ich jetzt sagte, gilt grundsätzlich. Aber wenn man dann nochmal differenziert zwischen Liberalen und Konservativen, haben die Konservativen immer nochmal so einen Vorsprung von 15 bis 20 Prozent.
Denen geht es immer über alle ein bisschen besser.
Also grundsätzlich sind die besser drauf. Und diese eine Zahl, die wir jetzt hier mal nennen wollen, ist wirklich hochinteressant, denn 100.000 Dollar Jahreseinkommen plus, also ab 100.000 Euro, reportieren Liberale einen Zufriedenheitswert von 60 Prozent. Also 60 Prozent der Angesprochenen oder die Angesprochenen sagen 60 Prozent. Wir sind bei 60 Prozent. Wenn Konservative gefragt werden, 100.000 plus, wie geht es dir? Sagen 74 Prozent, mir geht es voll gut. Also auch hier Grundgesamtheit schon mal so, okay, das Niveau bei den Konservativen ist einfach sehr viel höher. In dem Fall 14 Prozent Unterschied. Bei Haushaltseinkommen 30.000 und niedriger sagen 47 Prozent der Liberalen, mir geht es voll gut, aber 60 Prozent der Konservativen sagen, reicht mir im Grunde voll gut. Und erstaunlicherweise liegen nun diese 60 Prozent Konservativen mit wenig Geld, 30.000 und weniger, auf gleicher Höhe wie die 60 Prozent der Liberalen, 100.000 Jahreseinkommen und mehr. Und hier wurden wirklich viele Leute befragt. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt, ja gut, es sind jetzt so und so viele, und dann hat man ja noch eine Subgruppe und dann bleibt im Grunde von 2000 befragt, nur noch fünf übrig oder so und die sind dann in Aussagen kräftig für die Grundgesamtheit, sondern hier wurden 50.000 Leute gefragt. Und da kommen schon ausreichend viele zusammen, die über 100.000 unter 30.000 verdienen. Und dann ist wirklich nur entscheidend, wie ist eigentlich mein politisches Weltbild. Also was auch immer das im Großen und Ganzen behauptet, aber dass hier einfach 60.000 Dollar übersprungen werden.
Wenn ich jetzt mal mich an eine Interpretation wagen sollte, dann würde ich sagen, nun, die Konservativen sind ja eher Schicksalsergebn. Sie fügen sich in die Situationen, in der sie sind. Sehen diese auch als die ihnen entsprechende an. Das haben sie verdient. Deshalb sind sie in dieser Situation und sie sind damit zufrieden. Zufriedenheit ist, glaube ich, ein sehr konservatives Sein. Während jetzt linke, progressive, wie immer man das nennen will, sagen würden, ich will mehr vom Leben. Ich bin fast bereit, hier nochmal mit dir in eine Debatte anzuschließen über das öko-emanzipatorische selbst. Aber ich will es hier nicht zu bunt treiben. Aber ich sage mal, das hat etwas damit zu tun, wenn man sagt, zu meiner Ich-Werdung gehört eben nicht, dass ich mich einfüge, dass ich sage, ich bin jetzt einfach so, wie man das so ist. Man unterwirft sich der Herrschaft des Mann, würde Heidegger sagen, sondern man sagt, ich will mehr aus mir machen, ich will mehr sein. Und wenn ich sage, das ist so, dann komme ich natürlich an den Punkt, wo ich merke, diese Art der Selbstverwirklichung, die mir davor schwebt, ist eine, die ist mit 30.000 nicht machbar. Da brauche ich eher 100.000 oder noch mehr. Egal, wo man wohnt? Ja, kommt drauf an, welche Ansprüche man dann hat. Es gibt Unterschiede, ob man jetzt in der Uckermark lebt oder in Frankfurt, da gibt es einen Unterschied. Und das dann aber noch hinzukommt, selbst wenn man das Geld dann hat, also wenn man sagt, Geld ist jetzt nicht mehr mein Problem. Ich muss nicht hoffen, dass ich 1000 Euro mehr verdiene. Das ist jetzt alles okay. Dass ich ja dann immer noch nicht dieses Obdach habe, das Konservativen zur Verfügung steht. Ich habe den Glauben, ich habe die Familie, also Familie im Sinne von, das ist jetzt noch mal in ganz anderer Weise so ein Überbau für das Leben an sich. Ja, nicht nur ich mag meine Familie oder ich mag meine Kinder, sondern das ist ja noch mal ein größeres politisches Programm, wie wir oft wissen. Haben wir ja gesehen bei der Beisetzungsfeier da von Charlie Kirk. Und es ist auch sonst nicht mehr, also man hat das Geld, aber man bekommt ja nicht gleichzeitig ein Sinnangebot, sondern man bekommt Freizeitangebote, aber nicht ein Sinnangebot. Und deswegen kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass trotzdem das Geld dann möglicherweise sogar da ist, die Unzufriedenheit nicht gleichauf ist wie mit den Konservativen, die sagen, und so hat Gott das alles für mich gewollt und damit ist gut.
Genau, also ich finde auch, hier ist sehr viel Anlass drin, um so steffenmauartig nochmal richtig hinzugehen, die Leute zu fragen, woran liegt es. Denn einfach nur über eine statistische Kategorisierung finden wir das wohl kaum raus. Es gibt ein Denkangebot in diesen Text, also ein Erzähler greift Matt Iglesias auf. Der hat einen Text geschrieben, warum sind junge Liberale so deprimiert. Und darin kommt er auf einen performativen Aspekt zu sprechen. Das nämlich, und das hatten wir ja bei Precht auch schon ihm als Achillesferse ausgelegt, es ein bisschen unklar ist, wie die Leute antworten auf, bist du zufrieden und wie ist es beim Blick auf die Welt. Man könnte nämlich bei den Konservativen Scheuklappenphänomene beobachten, während man bei Liberalen mehr so ein Solidaritätsvibe beobachtet. Also, dass man für die anderen so ein bisschen mitleidet. Also, wenn so was wie ein Gaza passiert, kann ich nicht zufrieden sein.
Ja.
So, finde ich nicht schlecht.
Aber man macht sich trotzdem abends dann die gute Flasche Wein auf.
Genau. Also, es hat sozusagen gar keine Effekte, sondern einfach nur Demoskopieeffekte. Das kann ich mir auch sehr gut vorstellen. Ich habe dann Gemini nochmal nach dieser Studie The Politics of Depression. Also, ich weiß auch, wie man hinter eine Elsevier-Paywall kommt, aber in dem Falle, dachte ich mir, frage ich kurz KE., will das ja eh nicht komplett lesen. Es gibt wohl das Phänomen, dass liberale Mädchen am stärksten von diesen depressiven Symptomen betroffen sind, während konservative Junge am geringsten darunter leiden, laut dieser Demoskopie. Wenn man sich aber Stefan Mao-artig anschaut, wie die Lebenschancen, biografischen Möglichkeiten und so weiter von jungen Männern und jungen Frauen, von konservativer und liberaler Seite aussieht, dann sehen wir, und das war ja auch in diesem einen, finde ich, sehr erwähnenswerten, direkt nach der Trump-Wiederwahl wurden junge Leute angerufen. Die spielen dir eine halbe Stunde lang eine männliche Stimme nach der anderen vor, die sagt, nee, ich weiß nicht weiter, keine Ahnung, aber wir haben Trump gewählt, wie auch immer. Und bei den jungen Frauen, die gefragt wurden, ja, gestern war Wahl, ne? Ja, ich bin gerade mit meiner Bewerbung beschäftigt. Ich ziehe morgen nach so und so und so. Alle im Aufbruch, also wirklich komplett im Aufbruch, es ist selektiv ausgewählt, aber alle jungen Mädels im Aufbruch und die Männer alle, sorry, Schule ist jetzt vorbei, keine Ahnung, man weiß noch nicht, was ich jetzt mache und so. Und dieses Phänomen, gekoppelt mit liberale Mädchen, sind am stärksten von anstiegenden depressiven Symptomen betroffen, scheint mir ein, also hier ist nicht nur Achilles Seh, sondern hier muss man wirklich mal anschauen, was das bedeutet, denn den jungen liberalen Mädels geht's offenbar faktisch nicht so schlecht. Ja, aber es geht nicht im Vergleich zu diesen Männern.
Ja, aber das kann ich ja auch, glaube ich, ganz gut erklären, wenn man sich nämlich mal bedenkt, dass wir jetzt nicht nur ein Emanzipationsversprechen haben, sondern auch eine Realität, dass sich das sehr gut verwirklichen lässt. Man kann sagen, da ist vieles noch nicht oder manches noch nicht umsetzbar, aber es hat sich unglaublich viel verbessert. Das heißt, also für viele kann jetzt dieser Aufbruch tatsächlich beginnen und die werden nicht mehr irgendwo festgehalten. Da gibt es nicht mehr irgendwelche Strukturen, die das verhindern. Dann macht man es also und dann sieht man plötzlich, ach so, das ist jetzt die Freiheit. Ich fand das interessant in diesem Podcast, den wir heute schon mehrmals zitiert haben. Also Karoline Wahl ist dabei. Ja, Gorda Mereditsch und Karoline Wahl sagt, dass sie dann in Zürich bei einem Verlag gearbeitet hat und dass sie dann sich so dachte, ach, jetzt, wenn du an dein Junges, also an dein Teenager-Mädchen denkst, an dein Teenager, ich denkst, dann wärst du jetzt enttäuscht von dir, dass du nur das hast, wo man ihr sagen würde, na gut, bei einem Schweizer Verlag in Zürich arbeiten, das ist ja eigentlich toll. Ja, so. Und sie wollte aber mehr.
Genau.
Und jetzt hat sie das ja tatsächlich geschafft, mit ihrer Literatur erfolgreich zu sein und auch ökonomisch erfolgreich zu sein. Aber das bleibt ja trotzdem nur ganz wenigen vorbehalten. Da gehören jetzt zu den wenigen auch viel mehr Frauen, als das vor 30, 40 Jahren der Fall war. Aber es bleibt für eine kleine Gruppe, dass es wie allen zuzurufen, wer doch einfach Influenz haben wirst, du Reiches, geht dir auch nicht. Und daran sieht man eigentlich, dass also jetzt mit dieser Erwartung, die diese Emanzipation mit sich bringt, natürlich auch ganz viele Enttäuschungen entstehen, während die konservativen Männer, die Jungen, ja nicht mehr jetzt frisch enttäuscht werden, sondern die starten schon enttäuscht rein in die Sache und sind deshalb in so einer Liturgie.
Die Bens und Hoss und Hopf, dein ist natürlich richtig bampf.
Und bei denen richtet sich aber die Ertäuschung manchmal auch gegen sich selbst, aber oft dann, ja, so wird es zumindest dann angeleitet. Also ich habe auch noch mal so darüber nachgedacht, über Hoss und Hopf. Wir kommen eigentlich nicht ab vom Thema, ne, wir sind eigentlich noch genau dabei. Nämlich, es ist ja so, die haben das Angebot, das Hoss und Hopf und all diese eigentlich machen, ist du kannst reich werden, streng dich an, mach Krypto, mach sonst was und dann bist du auch bald in Dubai.
Ja.
Da wissen wir, das funktioniert ja nicht. So und dann haben sie eigentlich kein Angebot mehr gehabt. Dann bieten sie jetzt noch ein zweites Angebot. Du kannst mit uns gemeinsam hassen, du kannst mit uns gemeinsam herziehen über diese Politik, die nur noch Migranten kennt und dich vergessen hat und und und. Diese ganzen Geschichten dann. Und das ist also eine Verbindung, die die noch mal herstellen können, weil sie ökonomisch nicht herstellbar ist. Denn die sind ja nicht alle Millionäre geworden, weil sie eifrig den Podcast gehört haben. Aber in dem gemeinsamen Hassen, der gemeinsamen Ablehnung von irgendetwas, da können sie sich noch mal kurz verbinden. Und das reicht dann aus. Und ich glaube, das ist da auch ein Faktor, der mit reinspielt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall interessant auch. Ich will jetzt noch kurz markieren, wie das für dich völlig klar ist. Nur weil fünf Leute YouTube-Videos auf Dubai machen, betrifft das nur diese fünf Leute und ist kein flächendeckendes Phänomen. Während man das bei anderen Themen immer sagen muss, dass das kein flächendeckendes Phänomen ist, nur weil man fünf Leute ein Video macht.
Was willst du mir damit unterstellen?
Naja, irgendwer macht in einem Museum irgendein Video zu irgendeinem Ich hab Thomas Mann gelesen. Und ich will dir nur sagen, Niemand liest Thomas Mann.
Ja, aber ich hab mich ja auch dann immer, wir wollen nicht wieder, aber ich will dir nur sagen, es gibt in bestimmten Bereichen gab es gewisse Phänomene.
Ich nenne noch ein paar interessante Zahlen. Alter. Generation Z. Born 97 und später. Liberale, Wert 40. Also mehrheitlich unzufrieden. Selbst die Konservativen in diesem Alter kommen nur auf 56 Prozent. Während die Silent Generation, 64 und älter, heißt ja Silent, selbst die Liberalen kommen auf 64. Überragend also die Konservativen, jungen um zehn Punkte in der Zufriedenheit. Und ältere Konservative 73 Prozent. Drei Viertel sind einfach zufrieden. Das mal in Verbindung mit Religion. Wir haben ja bei Charlie Kirk jetzt sehr viele junge Leute gesehen, die sich der Religion zuwenden und politische Views äußern. Protestanten und Katholiken nehmen sich im Grunde nichts. Selbst die Liberalen sind bei 60, 61 Prozent zufriedenheitswerten. Atheisten 48 Prozent. Also allein der Glaube an Gott hilft ja nochmal 13 Prozent nach oben. Und Political Activity, also zur Frage, darf ich mich äußern oder nicht, hohes Nachrichteninteresse korreliert mit mehr Zufriedenheit, Low News and Political Interest mit sehr viel weniger. Also bei den Liberalen, wer sich viel für Politik interessiert, 57 Prozent, wenig, 46 Prozent, noch mal, das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Also wer sich viel für Politik interessiert, ist zufriedener.
Der wird nicht unzufriedener, sondern ist zufriedener. Aber wir wissen nicht, womit das korreliert.
Ja, ich kenne aus meinem Umfeld Leute, die sagen, ich bin endlich wieder zufriedener, weil ich so wenig Nachrichten konsumiere.
Ja, genau. Ich hätte jetzt auch gedacht, News Avoidance ist eigentlich ein Ding, was da reinspielt. Aber bei den Konservativen, sich für Nachrichten und Politik zu interessieren, ist es mit 73 Prozent, während Low News and Political Interest mit 60 Prozent. Und jetzt noch ein witziger Satz, der hier steht allgemein. Was die Kindererziehung angeht, sind die glücklichsten Menschen tatsächlich diejenigen, deren Kinder bereits ausgezogen sind. Also man hat Kinder, aber nicht mehr die unmittelbare Verantwortung. Finde ich sehr gut. Dafür, dass wir in Deutschland ja mehrheitlich jetzt Haushalte haben, in denen die eigenen Kinder schon nicht mehr vor Ort leben, ist das eigentlich sehr zufrieden.
Ein Diskussionspapier zur Nutzung der sozialen Medien für Kinder und Jugendliche, herausgegeben von der Leopoldina. Wissenschaftler setzen sich da zusammen und überlegen, was ist zu tun. Zunächst einmal beschreiben sie. In der Einleitung heißt es, gegenwärtig erleben wir eine globale Krise der psychischen Gesundheit junger Menschen. Dann sagen sie auch gleich, dass das ein multikausales Geflecht ist. Sie kommen noch mal kurz auf die Corona-Pandemie, die Maßnahmen zu ihrer Eindämmung und ihrer Folgen sowie eine Reihe globaler Megatrends, darunter der Klimawandel und unregulierte soziale Medien. Also es gibt mehrere Dinge, die dafür verantwortlich sind. Es ist also nicht nur die Rolle der sozialen Medien, aber diese steht nun im Vordergrund für dieses Papier. Wenn ich auch hier schon sagen möchte, interessant ist, dass sie zwar sich mit Facebook, Instagram, Reddit, YouTube, TikTok beschäftigen wollen, also das schon erwähnen, aber gar nicht zum Beispiel auf das Streamen eingehen, also das Dauerstreamen bei Twitch, die Podcast-Schwemme oder so. Das wäre ja auch was, worüber man reden könnte. Sie gehen auch auf Messenger-Dienste ein, soweit die auch so Social Media Funktionen haben. Der Großteil der verfügbaren Evidenz ist korrelativer, nicht kausaler Natur. Das ist also auch nochmal wichtig zu sagen. Man kann sich das so leicht machen. Sie zitieren Jonathan Haidt, sagen aber auch andere Forscherinnen und Forscher haben diese Feststellung, wonach also wir eine Epidemie psychischer Erkrankungen aufgrund von sozialen Medien haben, scharf kritisiert. Und auch Haidt vorgeworfene Interpretiere korrelative Zusammenhänge zwischen Technologienutzung und psychischen Erkrankungen unzulässigerweise kausal. Sie sagen, dass man eigentlich ja in diesen Fällen, wie sollen Eltern damit umgehen, mit einem Vorsorgeprinzip jetzt aber doch agieren sollte. Denn auch wenn das korrelativ ist, scheint es wohl doch so zu sein, dass diese extreme Social-Media-Nutzung negative Folgen hat. Zumindest für Menschen, die ohnehin eine Suchteaffinität haben. Und deswegen braucht man Maßnahmen, die ergriffen werden müssen, um diese Risiken zu minimieren. Wenn wir uns das Nutzungsverhalten ansehen von Kindern und Jugendlichen, dann zeigt sich, 10% der 6- bis 7-Jährigen, 17% der 8- bis 9-Jährigen, 46% der 10- bis 11-Jährigen, 71% der 12- bis 13-Jährigen nutzen aktuellen Studien zufolge mindestens einmal pro Woche TikTok. Das scheint mir auch viel zu sein. Vor allem wundert mich das, dass es bei 6-, 7-, 8- und 9-Jährigen, 10-Jährigen der Fall ist. Das kann ja nicht sein, dass man dort den Kindern schon dafür zuträgern wird. Also wenn ich hier für Free Speech oder so bin, ich bin nicht dafür, dass 7-Jährige jetzt mit TikTok-Videos versorgt werden. Es wird eine weitere Studie zitiert, Kindheit, Internet, Medien. Da wird berichtet, dass etwa die Hälfte der befragten Kinder, 6- bis 13-Jährige bzw. ihre Eltern von einer fast täglichen Nutzung sozialer Medien sprechen. Die Ergebnisse der Studie zeigen, dass über 80 Prozent der jugendlichen sozialen Medien täglich durchschnittlich 3,5 Stunden nutzen. Also da sprechen wir jetzt von den 12- bis 19-Jährigen. Die sind also 3,5 Stunden dort. Bei all dem zusammengerechnet, was wir jetzt ebenso erwähnt haben, Jugendliche im Alter von 14- bis 17-Jahren neigen signifikant häufiger zu einem pathologischen Nutzungsverhalten als Kinder im Alter von 10- bis 13-Jahren. Bedeutet also eigentlich für mich, da wo die elterliche Erziehung notwendigerweise aufgrund von Pubertät und all dem nachlässt, intensiviert sich die Beschäftigung mit Social Media. Dann heißt es, das Smartphone ist dabei das beliebteste Endgerät für die Nutzung. Fast jedes zweite Kind zwischen 6 und 13 Jahren besitzt sein eigenes Smartphone. Oder darf das Gerät der Eltern nutzen. Das ist ein bisschen schwammig jetzt formuliert. Was heißt das Gerät der Eltern nutzen? Bekommen die das mal gereicht oder wie viel nutzen sie es? Denn sonst finde ich die Zahl schon ziemlich drastisch. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass die Hälfte so ein Smartphone besitzt. Das scheint mir viel. Aber es relativiert sich dann ein bisschen, wenn es auch darum die Nutzung des wütterlichen Smartphones geht.
Genau. Typischerweise haben die Eltern Smartphones, sind die Kinder nicht. Und dann darf ich Musik hören, darf ich Bilder angucken, darf ich das überhauen. Und dann wandelt man halt so rein. Wenn man dann sein erstes bekommt und alle Eltern halten sich an die Regel, was weiß ich, erst eine Weile für eine Schule oder so. Ja, dann hat es das erste eigene Smartphone. Aber das ist ja noch nicht.
Ja, aber da würde ich ja sagen, da wo das Smartphone der Eltern weitergegeben wird, hat man ja noch alles sehr gut unter Kontrolle, beziehungsweise muss es ja nicht geben. Also da braucht man ja nicht regulieren. Das ist ja dann wirklich etwas, was älterliche Fürsorge betrifft. Dann geht es um die sozialen Medien, dass diese auch wichtige Chancen darstellen kommen, dass es auch Studien darüber gibt, dass dieses positive Feedback in den sozialen Medien durchaus das Selbstwertgefühl stärkt. Insbesondere die authentische Darstellung im Netz hängt in mehreren Studien positiv mit psychischem Wohlbefinden zusammen. Der Austausch privater Facebook-Nachrichten hing über die Zeit mit einer stärkeren Wahrnehmung sozialer Unterstützung zusammen. Diese war wiederum bei Mädchen mit einem Rückgang depressiver Symptome verbunden. Auch dazu gibt es Studien, dass es nicht so einheitlich zu beobachten ist. Auch wird hier darauf eingegangen, dass es Minderheiten gibt oder vulnerable Gruppen. Wie die LGBTQ-Plus-Mitglieder dieser Gruppe, dass die auch über die sozialen Medien in gewisser Weise Support erfahren und auch das Selbstwertgefühl sich steigert. Man ist nicht allein dann mit den spezifischeren Problemen. Bei Mädchen kann die Nutzung sozialer Medien dem Befund nach zudem mit Körperunzufriedenheit, Perfektionismus, psychischen Erkrankungen und einem erhöhten Risiko für sexuelle Belästigung und Übergriffe einhergehen. Also auch das ist ein negativer Effekt, der zu nennen ist. Nun ist es ja so, dass hier oft viel in einen Topf geworfen wird, zum Beispiel von Jonathan Hyatt. Man hat sich dann eine Studie in Deutschland angesehen und da heißt es, Kinder und Jugendliche mit suchtartigem Nutzungsverhalten wiesen signifikant häufiger stark ausgeprägte Depressions- und Angstsymptome, Stresserleben, Schlafprobleme und suizidale Gedanken auf als Gleichalterige mit nicht suchtartigem Nutzungsverhalten. Es ist also auch hier wieder eine Frage von Maß und Ziel. Und auch nochmal interessant, die externen Faktoren in stressreichen Situationen. Wenn dann noch Social Media hinzukommt, heißt es, dann intensiviert sich das alles sehr viel stärker. Das heißt, auch da ist die Frage, wie kommen diese stressreichen Situationen zustande, weil die nicht alle nur durch Social Media produziert werden. Es heißt dann hier, dass die Eltern das wichtigste Vorbild sind bei der Nutzung der sozialen Medien. Also die Studienlage scheint da ziemlich eindeutig zu sein, wie die Eltern die Medien nutzen. So tun es dann auch die Kinder. Hängen die Kinder am Smartphone. Kann man Rückschlüsse darauf schließen, dass die Eltern das auch stark tun.
Ich kann ja sagen, alle sind süchtig nach Snapchat und ich kenne keinen Eltern, der Snapchat hat.
Aber was man sagen kann, ist die Nutzung. Also ich glaube, wenn du die ganze Zeit deine Eltern siehst, wie sie permanent dort in Social Media sind, ob die Eltern jetzt bei Facebook sind und du bist als 12-Jähriger bei Snapchat, macht nicht den Unterschied.
Also, was es auf jeden Fall gibt, ist das Phänomen, man sieht die Eltern viel am Smartphone. Nur wissen wir ja alle, wir können nicht so richtig sehen, was Leute am Smartphone machen, außer wir stehen in der Bahn direkt hinter ihnen. Was bedeutet, Kinder sehen sehr wohl, sehr häufig ihre Eltern am Smartphone, sehen aber nicht, dass die da gerade arbeiten, was lesen, wie auch immer, in so einem positiven Sinne, was ihnen dann so eine Art Erlaubnisstruktur gibt, dann kann ich den ganzen Tag Snapchat machen. Also von daher ist diese Verkettung, aber ja, Eltern sind grundsätzlich vorbildhaft für die, also grundsätzlich halt, man ahmt sehr viel nach.
Bildungseinrichtungen, wie sieht es da eigentlich aus? Da heißt es, der Einsatz privater Smartphones und anderer technischer Geräte wird im Unterricht an vielen Schulen eingeschränkt und ganz untersagt. Also das ist jetzt nicht etwas, was erst kommt. Hessen wird genannt, zum Beispiel ab dem Schuljahr 2025, 26, ein landesweites Verbot privater Smartphone-Nutzung in Schulen geplant. Die Geräte dürfen zwar mitgeführt, aber grundsätzlich weder im Schulgebäude noch auf dem Schulgelände genutzt werden, mit Ausnahmen etwa für die Oberstufe. Das halte ich auch für eine sinnvolle Maßnahme. Warum sollte man jetzt da auch nochmal mit dem Smartphone laufen? Also da habe ich ja gar nichts dagegen, das so zu regulieren.
Genau, aber wir können uns vorstellen, sowas wäre für Erwachsene nicht mehr einzuführen, weil sie es nicht akzeptieren würden. Also hier ist, das ist, ich finde es ja gut, dass es so ist, aber es ist nur weil es paternalistisch entschieden werden kann, wird das so gemacht. Ansonsten, also da nochmal die Erwachsenen in so eine Vorbildrolle bringen, ja dann ihr aber auch nicht im Parlament. So, ne? Also dann wäre das sofort nicht möglich.
Du weißt, wo es noch so ist, in den Berliner Clubs, also wo es zur Sache geht.
Ja, genau, da will man sich die Fotografie machen, hat man die Hände voll, wie auch immer, das ist dann anders.
Zur technischen Altersverifikation entwickeln manche Anbieter digitale Brieftaschen, die digitale Ausweise und Altersnachweise auf dem Smartphone speichern. So lässt sich das Alter einfach nachweisen, was den Zugang zu altersbeschränkten Diensten sicherer machen kann und sozialen Medien die Einhaltung gesetzlicher Vorgaben erleichtert. Je nach konkreter Ausgestaltung der Lösungen können jedoch Konflikte mit dem Datenschutz und der IT-Sicherheit entstehen. Es besteht die Gefahr, dass soziale Medien mit solchen Schutzsystemen zusätzliche persönliche Daten ihrer Nutzerinnen und Nutzer erfassen, die sie sonst nicht erhalten würden. Taylor Lawrence hat sich ja dazu entsprechend geäußert.
Ich möchte gerne ganz detailliert, ich habe ja drei Kinder im betroffenen Alter. Das iPhone weiß, wenn es in einem Familienzusammenhang betrieben wird, also elterliche Geräte in diesem Netzwerk hängen, dann können die einfach sagen, der Geburtstag dieses Kindes ist, und dann weiß das iPhone grundsätzlich, wie alt das Kind ist. Was bedeutet? Im App Store gibt es dann bestimmte Apps einfach nicht, und zwar nicht, weil da irgendwer eine Palantir-Analyse gemacht hat, oder sowas, ja. So wie GPT jetzt kommt und sagt, am Nutzerverhalten können wir ermitteln, wie alt der ist und so. Genau das findet ja alles nicht statt, sondern jemand, auf dem man sich verlässt, die Eltern haben gesagt, dieses iPhone gehört einem Kind, das dann und dann geboren wurde, es ist also jetzt, rechne es selber aus. So, dann sagt das iPhone, nach meiner Mathematik, der Allgemein, bist du gerade 13 Jahre alt, ich biete dir diese App nicht an. Ich habe gesehen, du hast sie gesucht, aber sie ist für dich nicht verfügbar. Und das kann man für das ganze Gerät einstellen, nur es wird eben mit Absicht natürlich nicht im Browser für Webseiten eingestellt. So, das heißt, wenn man jetzt eine große Infrastruktur aufbaut, mit Android-Telefoner und iPhones dürfen gewisse Seiten nicht mehr aufrufen im Browser, müsste dafür überhaupt gar kein Überwachungsgesetz geschaffen werden oder was auch immer. Man müsste sich nur darauf einigen, wer die Datenbank pflegt, in der die URLs stehen, wo dann einfach eine Jahreszahl dahinter steht, auf einem iPhone von so einem darf diese Seite einfach nie aufgerufen werden.
Aber du müsstest ja das gesamte Netz dort...
Nein, ich müsste nur die Seiten auflisten, die gesperrt werden sollten. Alle anderen...
Ja, ja, aber was heißt nur? Das sind der Millionen.
Naja, klar, die müssen dann entdeckt werden. Und wenn rotten.com entdeckt wurde als das lieber nicht, muss es auf die Liste.
Ja, wir gehen jetzt mal zu den Empfehlungen.
Aber die Liste kann man transparent und so weiter, den politischen Diskurs...
Ja, ja, was hier empfohlen wird. Für Kinder unter 13 Jahren sollte ein strikte und wirksames Nutzungsverbot für Social Media gelten. Für 13- bis 17-jährige Jugendliche sollten soziale Medien und Netzwerke altersgerecht gestaltet werden, was eine deutliche Einschränkung der bisherigen Funktionalität bedeutet. So, da sehe ich halt ein Problem. Wenn gesagt wird, muss altersgerecht gestaltet werden. Das kann zum einen, und das wird auch hier genannt, bedeuten, dass gewisse algorithmische Kräfte dann nicht zum Leben erweckt werden, dass die jetzt auch mit 13 schon 70 Push-Nachrichten bekommen und all diese Dinge. Aber inhaltlich wird es dann schon bei vielen Dingen schwierig. Wir können uns ganz schnell auf ein paar grundsätzliche Sachen einigen.
Das ist das Ziel, dass es inhaltlich schwierig wird. Das ist kein Problem.
Ich sage nur, in den politischen Diskursen, die wir jetzt gerade haben, erleben wir, dass da so alles über einen Kamm geschoren wird. Und wie wir das jetzt eben bei der Desinformation herausgearbeitet haben, sehen wir ja dann, dass das dann gesagt wird, wir sind ja altersgerecht, besser auch nichts mit Krieg und Leid und so zu zeigen.
Ja, aber wir sind wieder an diesem Punkt. Ich möchte gerne die Kinder vor Pornografie und solchen Gewalttaten schützen. Und drei Sekunden später befinde ich mich in einer Diskussion, wer für die Erwachsenen was einschränkt. Das ist aber eine ganz andere Diskussion. Und ich weiß, wir kommen nie wieder zurück auf diese, aber wie schützen wir die 7-Mio.
Wir kommen jetzt ganz gleich dazu zurück. Zudem halten wir eine elterliche Nutzungsbegleitung der 13- bis 15-Jährigen für wichtig, wie sie viele Eltern wünschen und teilweise praktizieren. Da würde ich sagen, na ja, die Nutzungsbegleitung, das ist äußerst...
Eltern haben schon genug zu tun.
Ja, vor allen Dingen sind sie auch nicht immer jederzeit da. Also das wird ja... Sie sind ja nicht, wenn das Smartphone angeht, schön die Eltern nehmen. Zumal ja auch hier gesagt wird, die Privatsphäre der Kinder muss auch gewahrt werden. Also da wird es dann irgendwann nicht schön.
Ja, und sie wird nicht gewahrt, indem wir die Kinder zu Hause einschließen und das Handy im Keller verbannen. Ja.
Soweit sich die Handlungsempfehlung im Folgenden an die Betreiber der sozialen Medien richten, sollte ihre Umsetzung zudem durch wirksame rechtliche Vorgaben und Sanktionsmöglichkeiten abgesichert werden. Da besteht glaube ich zwischen uns Einigkeit, dass das möglich sein soll. Wir empfehlen, die ab 2026 eingeführte EUDI-Wallet in Deutschland so auszugestalten, dass sie allen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern mindestens ab 16 Jahren zur Verfügung steht und eine datensparsame Altersverifikation ermöglicht. Da kann man dann hoffen, dass diese auch wirklich so umgesetzt wird, weil wir wissen, wie der Lobbyismus in Brüssel so betrieben wird, was die Daten betrifft. Dazu gehören insbesondere die Möglichkeit, nachzuweisen, dass eine Person mindestens 16 oder 18 Jahre alt ist, Kontoeröffnung und so weiter. Ich würde auch noch hinzufügen, na ja, bei vielen Sachen meldet man sich ja gar nicht an, wie zum Beispiel bei YouTube, da kann man ja auch sehr viel konsumieren, ohne sich anzumelden. Das Mindestalter für die Einrichtung eines Social Media Accounts sollte verbindlich auf 13 Jahre festgelegt sein. Dann habe ich Cecibiti jetzt ja so alles las und die ganze Zeit Facebook und Instagram alles rezipiert, hat er gefragt, wie viele Porno Seiten eigentlich eine Altersverifikation haben. Und dann sagt mir Cecibiti, dass das sehr schwierig zu sagen sei, und es gibt so viele und hin und her. Und man geht dann so ein bisschen da dem nach, fragt noch mal und sagt dann ja, aber so im Allgemeinen und wie ist das bei großen Seiten und so etwas. Also rund heraus kann man sagen, 70 Prozent aller Porno Seiten haben keine, beziehungsweise nur eine Altersverifikation, wo gefragt wird, bist du über 18? Und da kann man auf ja klicken und dann ist man drin. Und eigentlich da, wo es in so ein Bezahlding geht, wo man irgendwelche Zusatzinhalte bekommt, da ist natürlich eine Altersverifikation, ist aber sowieso fast nicht nötig, weil eh das mit Kreditkarte und alles läuft. Also da ist das so. Ja, genau. Und bedeutet also, ich finde es ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass wir die ganze, also ich finde es auch wichtig, über Social Media und so zu reden, aber ich finde es echt merkwürdig, dass man weiß, wie hoch der Pronokonsum bei Minderjährigen ist und dass die alle Zugang haben zu allem, zu extremsten Inhalten, ja, dadurch, dass es international ist, noch zu viele extremeren Sachen, als sie auf deutschem Boden erlaubt sind. Und dass darüber aber so wenig geredet wird. Also das ist ja ein ein mega Problem.
Also Pornoseiten, für Pornoseiten gelten im Grunde schon diese Lösung mit den Listen, von denen ich gerade sprach. Also es gibt sehr viele Vereine und ich glaube sogar staatsnahe Seiten, die dir einfach eine Liste anbieten, die du über so eine Headblocker-App oder sonstiges abonnierst. Dann ist einfach völlig klar, kann hier nicht aufgerufen werden. Und da noch eine Pornoseite zu finden, die man dann trotzdem aufrufen kann, weil man 13 und clever ist und so, ist dann schon schwierig. Also die Liste wäre schon gut.
Nur jedoch, wenn die Eltern diese Einstellungen vorgenommen haben. Wir wissen aber ja von ganz vielen, dass sie mit 12 oder 14 ein Smartphone bekommen oder ein Laptop haben und dann können sie machen, was sie wollen.
Da rennst du auf die Türen rein, denn ich bin ja eh dagegen, dass den Eltern auferlegt wird, jetzt das Internet für die Kinder.
Genau, aber wie würde man das mit zum Beispiel mit den Pornoseiten so regeln, dass nicht Zwölfjährige Zugang haben zur Hardcore-Promografie?
Also wir hatten mal eine Diskussion über die Top-Level-Domain XXX, also adresseirgendwas.xxx. Und in dem Falle ist ein bisschen wie bei der Lieferkettengesetzgebung, hat sich die Pornobranche gewünscht, dass man das endlich einführt, damit die nämlich dann sagen können, und damit haben wir uns einmal alles entledigt, denn es ist dann völlig klar, wenn diese Domain mit xxx endet, brauchst du keine weitere Kontrolle führen, wie heißt die Seite, was findet da statt, was auch immer, sondern es ist grundsätzlich klar, xxx, Liebesbetriebssystem, ist hier nicht. So. Dann kannst du nämlich diesen ganzen Überwachungskram sparen, und wir wissen ja, Erwachsene, also es gibt ausreichend Erwachsene, die für Kapitalzufluss auf xxx Seiten sorgen. Die müssen jetzt nicht zwingend auch noch die Kinder erobern, wie die Zigarettenindustrie und denen sagen, ne, wenn du menthol raus, ist gut für die Zähne oder was auch immer. Das müsste ja gar nicht stattfinden. Es reicht ja völlig, diesen Markt auszuschöpfen. Und es kam aber immer nicht zu solchen Sachen.
Ja, sehr staunlich.
Es ist so ein bisschen, also du beklagst ja immer zu Recht, diesen Lobbyismus, der dann den Gesetzgebungsprozess kapert, weil mal irgendwer wieder ein Überwachungsanliegen hat. Und ich möchte daran erinnern, ich habe es schon mal bei der Gelegenheit gemacht im Sommersalon, wir hatten eine Corona-Pandemie, bei dem es plötzlich hieß, oh shit, wir müssen in die allerhöchste Privatsphäre eingreifen und nachvollziehen können, wer mit wem wann wo Kontakt hatte. Und dann hat der Staat ganz viele Ideen gehabt, wer diese Datenbank betreibt und was auch immer. Und dann gab es den Lobbydruck der normalen Bevölkerung, der gesagt hat, sorry, aber wir wollen ja keine Datenbank, wir wollen nur eine Kontaktdings. Und man hat diese Corona-App geschaffen, die bis heute und für alle Zeit ein Leuchtturm dafür ist, wie man die härtesten Privatsphäre regeln. Einfach so löst, dass niemand ernsthaft in seiner Privatsphäre eingeschränkt wird, sondern ein ganz definiertes faktisches Problem aus der Welt geräumt ist. Und das hat diese Corona-App geleistet. Und wenn ich auch diese Hacker beim CCC immer höre, die dann sagen, es gibt keine technische Lösung für ein soziales Problem, möchte ich gerne groß veto sagen, doch, man muss nur ein bisschen klüger mal drüber nachdenken, sich die Designs genau anschauen, das transparent bauen und es dann für alle zur Verfügung stellen.
Hier erntest du aber auch keinen Widerspruch von mir, sondern ich habe immer nur darauf verwiesen.
Altersverifikation ist ein Problem, das kannst du lösen, wie die Corona-Warnapp.
Und ich habe immer nur darauf verwiesen, wo ich die Probleme sehe, dass dann Dinge nicht so gelöst sind, wie man es wünschte. Denn es ist ja leider eine Ausnahme geblieben, wie man mit dieser Corona-Warnapp umgegangen ist. Denn wir haben ja schon damals gesagt, als die kam, Mensch, das könnte man doch eigentlich für so viele Dinge einführen. Warum muss ich eigentlich überall meinen gesamten Standort und weiß ich nicht was angeben?
Naja, ich habe ein zweites Beispiel genannt.
Da kann man es dann sehen.
Apple Pay kommt auch sehr vielen Datenschutzanforderungen entgegen.
Aber nicht alle Leute haben Apple-Geräte und werden sie auch in der Zukunft bescharmt.
Google Pay funktioniert ja fast ähnlich.
Letzter Satz. Wir empfehlen die Nutzung von Smartphones in Kitas und Schulen bis einschließlich Klasse 10 zu untersagen. Das ist also die Empfehlung hier von der Leopoldina. Ich glaube, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen hochgegriffen. Ich denke, dass man da bis zur 10. Klasse. Und dann, weil ich ja auch immer denke, ja und dann und danach wird man dann so in die Freiheit entlassen und weiß gar nicht, was man damit machen soll oder so. Ich glaube.
Ich kann ja eine Sache sagen. Die Leute kennen dann die Smartphones schon. Auch wenn man es ihnen komplett verbietet oder was auch immer. Es geht ja nur hier um die Abwendung des Allergrößten.
Die schulische Sache.
Aber wir werden niemals eine Situation haben, in der ein 18-Jähriger ein iPhone geschenkt bekommt und sagt, was ist denn das?
Ja, ich halte nur, es ist eigentlich für gut, wenn so ein Diskussionspapier erscheint, dass man dann zum Beispiel so einen Hinweis macht und sagt, bei der Corona-Warn-App, da haben wir das so und so. Ja, das finde ich ganz wichtig. Ich hätte eigentlich gerne bei diesem Positionspapier mehr IT gelesen, wie man irgendwas umsetzt, weil nicht, dass das, und das passiert jetzt gerade, Politiker sagen, ah Positionswahl, Smartphone-Verbot und so, wunderbar. Ich würde sowieso mal noch ein paar andere Dinge da klären. Und dann passiert nämlich so was wie das, was in den USA passiert und was Taylor Lawrence uns dann erzählt.
Wir müssen uns ja alle alphabetisieren. Man muss wissen, was ist ein Hashtag, was ist ein Timestamp, was ist ein irgendwas. Diese ganzen kleinen technischen Begriffe kann man sich jetzt einfach mal drauf schaffen. Und dann kann man an solchen Diskursen auch teilnehmen, ohne immer nur wie Taylor Lawrence zu Recht das groß zu kritisieren. Aber die kleine konstruktive Wende muss da einfach sein. So, ich möchte uns einen Text nahebringen, in dem ich in dem Falle, damit wir in den Vibe kommen, wirklich mal einfach ein bisschen mehr lese, als wir das sonst im Salon machen. Es geht um einen Text von Barbara Russ in der FAZ mit der Überschrift, Warum immer mehr Frauen freiwillig single bleiben. Also, es ist ein Kontrastprogramm zu dem, was ich eben vorstellte mit, die Konservativen sind so glücklich, Familie in FAZ, wenn das erst mal hinhaut. Also, man Kinder hat und an Gott glaubt, ist man so zufriedener. Dunkle Haare, weißes Lagen, ein leichtes Lächeln auf den Lippen und ein Funkeln an der Hand. Das Model Emily Ratajikowski liegt im Bett scheinbar unbekleidet und ungeschminkt. Das Einzige, was sie trägt, sind zwei dicke Ringe an ihrer rechten Hand. Was trägt sie? Sie hat es hingeschrieben, der einzige Bildunterschrift, den sie dazugeschrieben hat, Divorcerings, also ihre Scheidungsringe. Die wurden extra umgestaltet, also es war mal ein Verlobungsring. Jetzt hat sie den in zwei Teile gemacht. Der Stein war groß genug, ich habe das Bild gesehen. Sehr viele Leute haben sehr viel Geld und sie hat jetzt diese Ringe. Auch bei dem Berliner Schmucklabel Leo Mathild ist der Trend angekommen. Normalerweise wird der Schmuck, der mit dem Ex-Partner assoziiert wird, erst einmal abgelegt, sagt Schmuck-Designer Leo Eberlin. Aber nach ein paar Monaten suchen die Kunden eine Lösung, weil sich die Finger nackt anfühlen. Oft werden Ringe deshalb umgearbeitet, zum Beispiel der alte Verlobungsring in etwas Neues. Eine Kette, die man später den Kindern vererben kann oder einen lässigen Ring für einen anderen Finger. Schmuck ist für viele das emotionalste Stück, das sie besitzen, weil damit oft Meilensteine gekrönt werden. Und warum sollte man nicht auch die Scheidung als Meilenstein mit einem Ring markieren, wenn es sich richtig anfühlt? Sie kommen dann auf, Nadja von Busek zu sprechen, eine Kreativagenturinhaberin, die sagt, ich habe mir kein Schmuck gekauft, sondern mir eine Party mit meinen Freundinnen und Freunden geschenkt, Dresscode, Hochzeit. Also man sollte sich wie zu einer Hochzeit anziehen, aber man ist zu einer Scheidungsparty, wo sie dann endlich den Schmuck angelegt hat und so weiter. Von Busek selbst trägt ein schwarzes Cocktailkleid mit weißen Spitzenhandschuhen. Also wahrscheinlich hat sie auch so geheiratet. Und typischerweise wird das Ende von etwas gefeiert. Abitur, Abschlüsse, Berufsausstiege, warum nicht auch Befreiungsschläge. Das ist das Wort, das hier. Das Ende einer Liebe. Nadja von Busek. Die Scheidung hat mich auf mich selbst zurückgeworfen, aber ich wusste, wann und wo ich Hilfe brauche und konnte sie mir in den richtigen Momenten holen. Sie habe gemerkt, ich kann mich auf mich verlassen und bin für mich da. Ebenso wie mein soziales Netz. Das hat mir gezeigt, dass allein sein besser ist, als in einer schlechten Beziehung zu sein. Ich habe kürzlich erst wieder eine private Erzählung bekommen zu diesem Phänomen. Eine Scheidung findet statt. Der Mann hat vorher natürlich geregelt, das Unternehmen, es sei es, wie auch immer, er hat ausgedehnt keine Sorgen. Die Frau muss sich plötzlich durchschlagen, wieder einen Berufseinstieg finden und so weiter und so fort. Zufriedenheitswerte ein Jahr später. Die Frau in so einem riesigen sozialen Netz super aufgehoben. Immer noch arm dran, aber wohlauf. Der Mann so fertig mit der Welt. Nichts regelt sich mehr hier und so. Da nutzt einem dann auch die Eigentumerschaft an irgendwelchen Unternehmen nicht. So, mit dieser Erkenntnis ist von Busekia nun nicht alleine, also dass man als Frau alleine besser klarkommt. Vor ein paar Jahren sorgte der Verhaltenswissenschaftler Paul Dolin verschlagt sein, als er auf einem Festival pointiert behauptete, für Männer lohne sich eine Ehe, Frauen sollten sie lieber sein lassen. Also hier für alle Hörer, die mich seitdem ich das mal erwähnte, immer fragen, wo ist der Text dazu? Also Paul Dolin hat dazu geschrieben, dieses Buch heißt Happy Ever After, mit der These Männer profitieren von einer Ehe mehr als Frauen, und zwar ungefähr so viel wie die Frauen nicht davon profitieren. Also das Nullsummspiel der Zufriedenheit wird zu Ungunsten hinsichtlich der Männer verschoben, plötzlich leben sie länger, leben gesünder, wie auch immer, schlafen besser und den Frauen geht es aber schlechter als zuvor. Selbst wenn beide in einer Ehe, dem Mann und der Frau, die Beziehungskilo an Körpergewicht zunehmen, gilt das bei dem Mann als, oh dem geht es so gut, endlich so angekommen und so weiter, und die Frau kriegt dieses Stick mal nicht los, dass sie einfach fett geworden ist, was man Männern ebenso nicht unterschreibt. Dolin zitiert eine Studie, 24.000 verheiratete Deutsche, keine Ahnung, also es ist ja, wer weiß, was da für große Storys gemacht werden. Mit der Ehe kann man glücklicher werden, muss aber nicht. Die Verteilung ist 50-50. Und wir wissen jetzt, die Männer werden glücklicher, die Frauen unglücklicher. Und 50-50 zeigt genau, hier haben wir jetzt mit einem Seerosenphänomen zu tun. In Amerika deshalb, in Deutschland wahrscheinlich ähnlich, vier von fünf Scheidungen werden von den Frauen initiiert. Diese Frauen haben nicht nur ihren Mann konkret zahlt, sondern sie sind regelrecht Männer müde. Für Männer ist eine Ehe immer ein Statusgewinn, aber Frauen profitieren von dem sozialen Netz, mit dem sie eine Trennung bewältigen können. Also Männer haben in der Ehe nur einen Statusgewinn, der sich aber faktisch nicht niederschlägt, im Sinne von echter Hilfe, echte Bünde, was auch immer. Da hilft jemand, dann geht ihnen das verloren. Und die Frauen können danach aber soziale Netze aktivieren, die die Männer so gar nicht haben. Das ist ein bisschen wie in der Alten Republik der Berufsausstieg. Plötzlich sind die Kollegen nicht mehr da und man stellt fest, das sind gar nicht meine Freunde gewesen. Also man fühlte sich so, aber es hatte gar kein empirisches Korrelar. Eine historische Entwicklung wird hier kurz abgerissen. Frauen brauchen keine Männer mehr. Denn seit Frauen ihr eigenes Geld verdienen, haben viele Männer einen Teil ihrer Identität verloren. Das beobachtet auch Marie-Rose Klee in ihrer Praxis. Frauen brauchen heute keinen Mann mehr für ihre finanzielle Absicherung. Darüber hinaus hat er aber oft nichts zu bieten. Die Notwendigkeit der Beziehungspflege, der tiefen Verbindung durch Selbstreflektion und den partnerschaftlichen Dialog ist vielen Männern nicht bewusst. Wenn der Mann sich nicht mehr als Versorger der Frau und Familie definieren kann, was bleibt ihm dann noch? Ich beobachte bei vielen Männern, dass sie total lost sind.
Also wenn ich das so alles höre, es deckt sich so wenig mit der anekdotischen Evidenz, die ich anzubieten hätte. Ich wundere mich zum Beispiel über diese Schilderung der Männer. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es das gibt. Ich will nicht das leugnen. Aber ich sehe ja schon, dass sich jetzt in den letzten Jahrzehnten etwas entwickelt hat. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur eine Emanzipation der Frau, sondern auch eine Veränderung, wie Männer mit Männern umgehen, sie mit sich selbst umgehen, wie sie Familie neu definieren und all das. Also hier wird ja was geschildert, das könnte ja ein Text sein, dass du sagst, ich habe hier was von 1971 gefunden und dann würde ich dir das auch glauben. Und das wundert mich ein bisschen. Und deshalb sage ich, das deckt sich nicht mit der Erfahrung, die ich jetzt im Umfeld mache. Dass da zum Beispiel die Männer sind, die nur ökonomisch vielleicht noch was anzubieten haben und das brauchen aber die Frauen nicht mehr so dringend. Ich sehe andere Familien, sehe andere Väter und Mütter, die sicherlich auch Probleme haben, aber wo das nicht so einseitig geschildert wird, wie das jetzt hier in dem Text rüberkommt.
Weißt du, was ich glaube? Du kennst mehr Männer, die Bücher geschrieben haben, als Kinder gezeugt haben.
Das mag sein, aber ich kenne auch Männer, die Kinder gezeugt haben und keine Bücher geschrieben haben. Und ich kenne auch Leute, die Kinder gezeugt haben.
Ich kenne auch Männer, die Kinder gezeugt haben, aber keine Bücher geschrieben haben. Im normalen Alltag hast du ausschließlich Männer, die nicht mal Bücher lesen. Das ist der Normalfall. Ein Mann, der ein Buch schreibt, wenn du davon mehr als zwei Männer kennst, die ein Buch geschrieben haben, dann ist das eine Seltenheit. Dann ist das eine Hochidee. Ja, ich weiß. Das hat nichts mit der Realität zu tun. Wir reden hier über die 85 Millionen.
Ja, aber ich komme ja aus einer ganz normalen Familie, in der sonst niemand ein Buch geschrieben hat oder sonst irgendwelche Dinge macht.
Das hast du aus einer ganz normalen Familie gemacht.
Doch, ich komme aus einer ganz normalen Familie. Und ich sehe auch, und da sind auch Cousins und Cousinen und so etwas. Und da trifft das nicht so zu. Also ich denke jetzt nicht an irgendwelche Schriftsteller, die ich kenne, die in Berlin Mitte leben und da noch ein Kind haben, sondern ich denke schon an Menschen, die ich zum Beispiel aus Koblenz kenne, die in Anführungszeichen normalen Berufen nachgehen und wo das in dieser Weise zumindest in dieser Überspitzung nicht zutrifft. Was ich aber auch kenne ist zum Beispiel aus dem Bekanntenkreis meine Eltern, dass dort vor vielen Jahren dann Scheidungen stattgefunden haben. Und da es tatsächlich zutrifft, dass die Frauen sich wunderbar sofort ein soziales Netzwerk aufgebaut haben bzw. das was sie schon hatten erweitern konnten, während es für die Männer ein ganz großes Problem war und sie nach der Scheidung nichts anderes taten als so möglichst schnell jemanden zu suchen, um erneut zu heiraten und am besten noch mal ein Haus zu bauen. Und ich kenne auch einen, der hat sogar drei mal jetzt schon gemacht und hoffen, dass es jetzt beim dritten Mal mit dem dritten Haus und so weiter funktionieren mag. Also weil da offenbar das Netz sonst nicht funktioniert, sondern immer nur über die Ehe funktioniert. Das bestätige ich alles gern. Ich habe jetzt nur eben an Männer gedacht, die um die 30 sind, wo ich das nicht so in dieser Weise sehe oder die vielleicht um die 40 sind.
Also dass dieser Text hier in dem großen Widerspruch steht, habe ich ja eben schon angemerkt. Denn wir haben ja eben einen Text gehabt, in dem behauptet wurde, es sind vor allem liberale junge Frauen, die besonders unzufrieden sind. Und jetzt hören wir aber hier, ja und das ist ja der sozusagen qualitative Dreh, der dann demnächst mal aufzuarbeiten ist. Ich bekomme auch immer häufiger Anfragen, ob ich das mal belegen könne, dass jetzt schon die zweite Generation in der Schule mit Mädels bessere Abschlüsse haben und die erste Generation im Arbeitsmarkt ankommt, die höhere Einstiegsgelder haben als die Jungs. Ja, da gibt es ja Zahlen von solchen Sachen. Ja, also das wird es jetzt vermehrt geben, da kann man mich noch ein Jahr lang fragen und danach wird es völlig offensichtlich sein, dass es so ist. Und entsprechend lesen wir hier und zwar ausdrücklich in diesem Kontrast, junge liberale Frauen gelten als besonders depressionsanfällig. Und dann lesen wir hier, Psychologin Marie-Grosse Klee kennt diesen Effekt aus ihrer Praxis. Frauen feiern nach einer Trennung, dass sie frei sind, ihre Wohnung so einrichten können, wie sie wollen, ihre Zeit so einteilen können, wie sie wollen, sich anziehen und ausgehen können, wie es ihnen gefällt. Es liegt keine schmutzige Unterwäsche auf dem Boden außer der eigenen. Die Psychologin sagt, das habe viel mit Kontrollgewinn zu tun. Sie feiern, dass sie die Kontrolle über sich selbst, ihre Gefühle und ihren Alltag zurück haben. Sie schreiben wieder ihre eigene Geschichte. Manche gesellschaftlich unhinterfragten Geschichten, die über lange Zeit erzählt werden, sollten laut Verhaltensforscher Peter Dolan von Zeit zu Zeit auf ihre Aktualität überprüft werden. So wie die mehr von der alten Jungfahr oder das Beziehung um ihrer Selbstwillen erstrebenswert sein. Die Frauen haben mit dem Hinterfragen längst begonnen.
Ja, ich möchte aber auch hier noch mal hinzufügen, dass es jetzt nicht ein Phänomen, das zwei Jahre alt ist, sondern im Schlager haben wir es schon länger vernommen. Es gibt, ich habe es glaube ich schon mal erwähnt, diesen wunderbaren Schlager von Gitte. Ich will alles, ich will alles und zwar sofort. Das ist im Prinzip auch ein Lied. Niemand speist mich ab, niemand macht mich satt, heißt es ja. Das davon kündet, dass man sich nicht mehr an den Mann bindet, der einem dann alles vorschreibt, sondern ich mache jetzt, was ich will. Wir haben von Mary Rose, die mal damit auch beim Grand Prix aufrecht gehen, wo sie eine Trennung verarbeitet und dann sich auch tatsächlich recht bald getrennt hat, nämlich von, jetzt kommt das popkulturelle Wissen, Gottlieb Wendehals, Werner Böhm. Hier fliegen gleich die Löcher aus dem Käse, wo sie das dann verkörpert und sie hat ja dann auch eigentlich für, sagen wir, die geschiedene Frau ab 40 vor allem Musik gemacht. Das wird sie nicht so sehen vielleicht, aber das war so. Und auch noch eines ihrer letzten Dieder, sie hat ja ihre Karriere jetzt beendet, heißt Unbemannt und dem heißt es, der Weg zum Glück ist unbemannt. Also das heißt in diesen Schlagern und da gibt es jetzt weitere Beispiele, die man nennen könnte, haben wir ganz häufig seit den 80er Jahren eigentlich, dass das Leben nach der Scheidung gefeiert wird. Ist da sehr präsent.
Ja, ich will folgende Perspektive jetzt dafür werben, wenn man Nachrichten schaut, wie auch immer. Wir sehen in dem öffentlichen politischen Betrieb sehr viele Männer außer Rand und Band. Donald Trump, JD Vans, Cash Patel und die Leute, die sie beauftragen, die also mit Maske, ohne Namen, fetten Bäuchen und Jeanshose irgendwie über amerikanische Straßen rennen und da Ausländer einfangen. Alles Männer, zu 100 Prozent Männer bei Eisarbeiten. Ja, auch zu meiner Alibi Frau, weil könnte ja sein, dass man mal ein siebenjähriges Kind hat, dass man körperlich durchsuchen muss. Dann macht das halt die Frau. So, das ist also sichtbar und politisch. Und vielleicht ist das unsichtbare Private in einem genauso großen Wandel, nur dass wir es einfach eben nicht sehen.
Das glaube ich ist so. Was ich aber auch noch mal hinzufügen möchte, ist immer mehr Frauen scheinen auch auf diesen rechten Kurs einzuschlagen.
Ja, wir haben ja auch einen allgemeinen Rechtstreben.
Ja, ja, ich will nur sagen, die Unterstützerinnen für Trump werden nicht weniger.
Also ob Trump gerade überhaupt die Unterstützung gewinnt, würde ich schon mal als offene Frage sagen.
Ja, oder sagen wir für diese rechte Politik, für JD. Wins. Wir haben das doch jetzt bei Charlie Kirk gesehen. Das war ziemlich Pari Pari. Da waren jetzt nicht nur die Männer, die dort aufgetrumpft haben. Und wenn wir uns ansehen, wie die Witwe sich verhält, also bitte.
Genau, und das ist ja genau der Punkt. Immer, wenn wir öffentlich, politisch etwas sehen, können wir davon ausgehen, dass die unsichtbare private Gegenbewegung auch so da ist, aber eben nicht so abgefilmt wird. Also wenn jetzt jemand, so wie wir, Charlie Kirks Wegbegleiter und die Frauen hängen dann, während die Rede gehalten wird, am Arm und sagen, ja, ja, alles genau richtig und so, dann kann man sich dafür vorstellen, nicht nur gibt es für diesen Mann gerade Gegenmodelle, halt unsichtbar und privat, aber gibt's, und für die Frau auch. Also nennen sich da ist immer mehr in Bewegung, als man so glaubt.
Der Goldpreis steigt. Das bedeutet auch, es gibt einen neuen Goldrausch. Jocelyn C. Zuckerman hat sich für Le Monde Diplomatiek, die deutsche Ausgabe vom Oktober, das angesehen. In Ghana floriert der illegale Bergbau. Sie hat sich dort mit Menschen getroffen, die darunter leiden. Es sind wirklich erschreckende Bilder, die hier gezeichnet werden. Flüsse, in denen man früher schwimmen konnte, die sind jetzt verseucht. Man kann das Wasser nicht mehr nutzen, nicht zum Gießen, nicht zum Trinken. Nichts ist da möglich. Der Fluss hat nun die Farbe von Milchkaffee. Eine Fließrichtung ist nicht mehr auszumachen. Das sind die Umweltschäden, die angerichtet werden. Wenn der Goldpreis steigt, dann lohnt es sich plötzlich auch, da zu graben, wo es sich eben nicht gelohnt hat. Da lohnt es sich auch, das Gesetz zu missachten, sonst muss man halt ein bisschen Bestechungsgelder mehr zahlen und kann trotzdem weitermachen. Ein 50-jähriger IT-Spezialist, Bride heißt er, ist zum Umweltaktivisten geworden. Er wollte eigentlich den Bauernhof seines Großvaters weiter betreiben, aber das ist so nicht mehr möglich. Überall hässliche Erdhügel, trübe Teiche. Es sind Überbleibsel eines zerstörerischen Goldrausch, heißt es da. Der Goldrausch, der ist nicht neu. Schon Ende des 17. Jahrhunderts gab es das in Ghana. Das hat das Land dann auch eine Zeit lang reich gemacht, zum mächtigsten Akteur Westafrikas werden lassen. Bis dann das Unglück mit den Briten kam im 19. Jahrhundert. Die Kolonialisierung, die Unabhängigkeit zieht sich dann hin. Sie wird erlangt im Jahr 1957. In Ghana führte dies alles zu einer Verdopplung der Goldexporte, dass man dort so viel Geld mit Gold verdienen kann. Und was dabei verfolgt wird, ist das Prinzip, gather them and sell, das wird dann als Gallemsee bezeichnet, also so zusammengeschoben die Worte, sammeln und verkaufen. Heute macht der illegale Abbau mehr als ein Drittel der jährlichen Goldproduktion Ghanas aus. Besonders gravierend sind die Auswirkungen auf die Umwelt. Mit der Ausbreitung des Gallemsee wurden Wälder abgeholzt, die Böden aufgerissen und einst unberührte Landschaften mit Schwermetallen verseucht. Blei, Cyanid, Kataminium, Arsene und insbesondere Quecksilber haben die Erde wie das Wasser vergiftet. Die Kakaoindustrie, Ghanas, sehr wichtige Industrie. Ghanas, der zweitgrößte Kakao-Produzent der Welt, ist davon bedroht. Die Bedeutung für die Wirtschaft Ghanas ist damit auch eine Frage der Zeit. Also wie bedeutend sie noch sein wird, nämlich momentan macht eben dieser Sektor noch 20 Prozent der Exporteinnahmen aus, aber es wird schwierig. Nahmen die Erlöse im Goldsektor von 5 Milliarden US-Dollar 2021 auf 11,6 Milliarden US-Dollar 2024 zu, schrumpften sie im Kakaobereich im gleichen Zeitraum um mehr als ein Drittel von 2,9 Milliarden US-Dollar auf 1,7 Milliarden US-Dollar. Eigentlich hatte man den Goldabbau ganz gut geregelt in Ghana. Man hat viele Umweltstandards eingehalten und die großen Konzerne, die dort tätig waren, Anglo Gold, Ashanti und Goldfields, haben sich an diese Auflagen auch gehalten, heißt es hier. Aber jetzt ist es so, dass überall die Leute losziehen, dass die Leute nach Goldrahmen beziehungsweise Unterstützung bekommen. Seit die chinesische Regierung ab 2013 im Rahmen ihrer Belt and Road Initiative mit dem Bau von Infrastrukturprojekten in Ghana begann, verändern industriell arbeitende Bagger und Bulldozer das Gesicht des handwerklichen Bergbaus. Gallemsee wurde zu einem großen Geschäft. Man versucht sich dann mit Bestechung eines Clans oder damit, dass man entsprechend hohe Angebote den Kakaobauern macht, verkauft doch euer Land, wir können hier arbeiten und kurzzeitig gibt es dann auch mal Geld. Versucht man sich also da immer weiter auszubreiten. China hat da ein großes Interesse, das zu tun und betreibt diesen Hauptbau an der Natur so stark, dass 44 der 288 Wallschutzgebiete Ghanas schon kaputt gegangen sind. Es ist also eine unglaubliche Katastrophe, die man dort anrichtet und der Goldpreis steigt weiter. Es führt aufgrund der vielen Vergiftungen des Trinkwassers zu Fehlgeburten, zu starken Missbildungen. All das wird jetzt nach und nach untersucht. Aber die Spatzenpfeifen ist von den Dächern. Es ist vollkommen klar, was da passiert. Heute ist der handwerkliche Goldabbau für sage und schreibe 38 Prozent aller weltweiten Quecksilberemissionen verantwortlich. Das ist mehr als bei jeder anderen menschlichen Aktivität, einschließlich der Kohleverbrennung. Wir sind in einer Situation, wo die Fehlgeburten immer weiter zunehmen. Man glaubt, dass man, wenn das so weitergeht, schon ab 2030 Wasser importieren muss nach Ghana. Reis, Fisch, sogar Vieh weisen Spuren von Quecksilber inzwischen auf. Und die Kakaobauern sind unheimlich schlecht bezahlt. Sie verdienen weniger als 100 US-Dollar im Monat. Für sie ist also der Einstieg in den Bergbau, beziehungsweise der Verkauf des Landes, eine Möglichkeit, um sich daraus zu befreien. Aber dann ist auch die Frage, wohin mit dem Geld, wo bleibt man dann? Was kann man dann tun? Im Februar kündigte die EU und Japan an, künftig Kakao-Importe aus Ghana auf Schwermetall-Verunreinigung zu untersuchen. Noch gravierender klingt die Warnung des niederländischen Botschafters in Ghana. Demnach besteht die Gefahr, dass der im Land produzierte Kakao 20 Prozent des weltweiten Angebots von der EU pauschal zurückgewiesen wird. Das ist der Wahnsinn, der hinter dem schönen glänzenden Gold steckt. Es ist eine große Katastrophe. Eigentlich müsste man Gold verbieten. Ja, es ergibt keinen Sinn, man müsste eigentlich Gold verbieten.
Genau, und genau weil es keine Funktion hat, sondern einfach nur schön aussieht und selten ist, ist es ja Gold. Die KI-Genetik-Revolution kommt. Und die Frage ist, woher? Die Antwort ist aus China. Bill Drexel schreibt in The New Atlantis über unsere typischen Ängste, die wir so haben. Eigentlich sagen wir doch, wir haben doch irgendwelche dystopischen Befürchtungen, dass eine KI uns überrumpelt oder ein Bewusstsein entwickelt, wir die Kontrolle verlieren, was auch immer. Und er sagt, ne, also wir können das sehr konkretisieren, wofür wir Angst haben sollten. Und dieses Thema kriegt gerade gar keine Aufmerksamkeit, denn die unmittelbarste Bedrohung, die KI für die Menschheit darstellt, ist nicht übermenschliche Intelligenz, die uns dann aussortiert, sondern, dass die Menschen, die KI benutzen, um sich selber auszusortieren. Ganz konkret kann man sich demnächst für sich selber oder seine Nachkommen Vorteile kaufen, weil man die Möglichkeiten hat, seine eigene DNA jetzt der Kontrolle durch KI zu unterwerfen oder nicht. Und jetzt sagt er hier, wir haben noch ein historisches Monopol in den westlichen Ländern, dass wir hier bioethische Normen einhalten. Aber wir haben ja in China schon gesehen, die haben ja sogar schon Kinder gezüchtet. Und dann ist dieser Forscher da kurz verschwunden und dann taucht er aber wieder auf und ist so voller Blüte. Also die chinesische Regierung hat da gar nicht so viel dagegen. 1953 wurde das Genom entdeckt. Seitdem hat man so ein bisschen überlegt, was man damit macht, diese CRISPR-Genschere entwickelt. Und jetzt versteht man die Grammatik. Also wir haben es mit einer Sprache zu tun, die wir jetzt erst richtig verstehen. Da wir KI-Systeme haben wie Evo 2, das kam im Februar und ist vom ARC Institute, NVIDIA und anderen ein veröffentlichtes, durchgeführtes Projekt, das mit das Ziel hat, alle bekannten lebendigen Arten und noch einige bekannten, aber ausgestorbenen Arten in ein DNA-Modell zu bringen. Was bedeutet, dass die neun Billionen Nukleotiden einfach drinstecken und man jetzt so Chatbot-artig einfach fragen kann, was könnte man jetzt damit tun? Es werden verschiedene Firmen genannt, die jetzt schon in vitro Gematogenese machen, die DNA nehmen. In China zum Beispiel gibt es ein Unternehmen, das schaut sich nur DNA-Code an und kann dir dann zeigen, wie dein Kind aussieht in verschiedenen Altersstufen. Also so, wie man so nachmodelliert, wenn man irgendwelche Knochenfunde hat oder so, wie das Gesicht da drüber aussah. Das macht man jetzt mit DNA alleine. In China hat man bereits menschliche Gene in Markaken, also Affen, eingeführt, die dann gebären lassen. Und man hat eine gesteigerte kognitive Leistungsfähigkeit entdeckt, was für mich so das Szenario Planet der Affen, wie plötzlich Rede der Affe. Und so, ja, ja, findet ja alles schon statt. Die chinesische Führung ist natürlich sehr hinterher. Vor allem, wir kriegen ja diesen Monat noch einen neuen Fünfjahresplan aus China. Der Fünfjahresplan der Kommunistischen Partei Chinas für 2021 enthält bereits Ziele zu die Zitat, Qualität der Geburtenpopulation zu verbessern. Das heißt, die Zielsetzung ist schon formuliert. Jetzt hat man natürlich neue Möglichkeiten, methodisch da einzugreifen. Wir haben ein sehr großes Unternehmen, BGI, weltweit im Vertrieb von so pränatalen Tests, also die man einfach so über die Apotheke und so beziehen kann. Hier droht, man weiß nicht genau, was mit diesen Daten passiert, weil China hat da ein Monopol auf, falls jemand für sich privat einfach mal gucken will, ob mit den Genen alles in Ordnung sind. So ein bisschen wie bei 23andMe. Und dieser Chef von dem Laden wird hier mit einem sehr interessanten Spruch zitiert und zwar, die westliche Welt hat ja auch diese Forschung. Jetzt erwartet man, dass in China die, also das erste Mal eine Schlüsseltechnologie sofort, also KI und Genetik, das sofort Vorreiter China ist. Also dass da kein Aufholen oder so stattfindet, sondern sobald das dann marktfähig ist, wird es China sein. Und dieser Schäfe von dem Laden, der Name lautet, finde ich jetzt nicht, aber egal, ich trage sein Zitat vor. Man fühlt sich fortschrittlich, bla bla bla. Man verfolgt alle diese Regeln und hat diese Protokolle und Gesetze und Vorschriften. Man braucht jemanden, der das ändert, der das alles in die Luft jagt. Also wir haben hier so eine Art Doge Typen, die einfach ihre KI und Genetik Symbiose da machen wollen und die sich, also die schon froh sind, dass sie in China einfach die Regierung auf ihrer Seite haben, die denen ein großes Versprechen machen und die über die westliche Welt lachen, weil die immer noch so mit ethischen Vorbehalten da kommen und so.
Eine erschreckende Welt.
Das ist wirklich heikel, ja.
Das Ende des Menschen ist eigentlich das wichtigere Buch von Francisco Kuyama. Alle reden immer über das Ende der Geschichte, aber der beschreibt das sehr gut, was eigentlich passiert, wenn dieser Transhumanismus sich durchsetzt, wie dann tatsächlich jede Art von Gleichheit ausgehebelt wird. Und das passiert jetzt da schon. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie dann auch so eine Großmacht, wie die USA darauf reagieren werden.
Genau. Also es gibt hier eine Firma, um das mal noch zu sagen, die bietet dir an, aus Hautzellen, Eizellen und Sperma zu erschaffen. Also Reproduktion über die Hautzelle selbst. Dann kommst du auch um die Leihmutter herum, weil das ist dann einfach Zeugung, die dann noch in so Geräten, die noch entwickelt werden müssen. Und die bieten aber jetzt schon an, zu sagen, naja, wir können ja dann unendlich viele Embryonen erzeugen. Sie haben ja unendlich viele Hautzellen, die wir ihnen einfach und so weiter. Und dann wählen wir einfach das Beste aus.
Ja. Jaja.
Das sind ganz neue Entwicklungen.
Kommen wir zum Friedensnobelpreis. In der Süddeutschen Zeitung schreibt Jan Heidtmann über die Preisträgerin Maria Corina Machado. Sie ist die Oppositionsführerin in Venezuela. Und sie ist aber abgetaucht an einem geheimen Ort in Caracas. Hält sie sich auf, hier heißt es Gerüchten zur Folge, ist sie in der ungenutzten US-Botschaft versteckt. Genau wissen das aber nur ihre engsten Vertrauten. Sie ist also jetzt ausgezeichnet worden. Was heißt das? Nun, sie wird als die eisene Lady gegen die Autokratie genannt. Wir wissen, Venezuela wird von Maduro regiert. Das ist nun auch kein Demokrat, wie wir wissen. Die studierte Wirtschaftsingenieurin stammt aus einer Industriefamilie, engagiert sich dann aber früh politisch. 2002 gründet sie Sumate, eigentlich eine Nicht-Regierungsorganisation zur Wahlbeobachtung, über die Machado seit dem Versuch des Regimes Venezuela zu stürzen. Erst das von Staatspräsident Hugo Chavis, dann das seines Nachfolgers Maduro. Es ist so, dass Machado auch angetreten ist für die Präsidentschaftswahlen 2024. Dann hat man sie da herausgekickt. Sie darf dann jetzt 15 Jahre lang, glaube ich, kein öffentliches Amt bekleiden. Man kämpft gegen sie. Die USA bezeichnen, heißt es hier Venezuela, das Staatspräsident als Chef eines Narkoterrorkartells und haben die Drogenschmuckner des Landes als unrechtmäßige Kompatanten eingestuft, mit denen sie sich in einem bewaffneten Konflikt befänden. Nun ist es interessant, dass ja die USA da schon vorgehen. Kriegsschiffe fahren da rum. 20 Menschen wurden bei dieser völkerrechtswidrigen Aktion bereits getötet. Trump hat auch alle Verhandlungen mit der Regierung in Venezuela abgeblasen, hat da Richard Connell gesagt, nee, das stoppen wir jetzt alles. Ja, und wie ist es jetzt mit dieser Nobelpreisträgerin? Wo steht die? Nun, Marina Corina Machado hat die gewaltsame Linie des US-Präsidenten immer unterstützt. Und in einem Kommentar dann von Heidtmann heißt es, dass da zwar jetzt Freude und Erleichterung war, dass es nicht Trump geworden ist, darüber war man erleichtert, freu dich darüber, dass eine Oppositionspolitikerin ausgezeichnet wurde, aber zufrieden kann man damit nicht sein. Er sagt, der Friedensnobelpreis zielt auf Verbrüderung, wie der Stifter Albert Nobel schrieb, also auf Versöhnung. Maria Corina Machado steht für vieles, aber dafür nicht. Sie ist eine mutige Frau, die den Widerstand gegen ein äußerst repressives Regime führt. Aber sie hat bis dahin keinen Frieden gestiftet, eher im Gegenteil. 2002 war Machado ein Putschversuch gegen Hugo Chavez unterstützt. Chavez war gerade einmal drei Jahre zuvor, nach demokratischen Wahlen zum Präsidenten Venezuela ernannt worden. Seine sozialistische Regierung wurde zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch von breiten Schichten der Bevölkerung getragen. Aber Machado war das nicht recht. Sie kommt aus einer wohlhabenden industriellen Familie. 2002 wendete sich dieser Putsch, schreibt Heidtmann, vor allem gegen zahlreiche Sozialprogramme der Regierung Chavez. Außerdem hatte wohl die Familie auch die Befürchtung, enteignet zu werden. Bis heute steht Machado in der Wirtschaftspolitik für einen radikal marktwirtschaftlichen Kurs, für weitgehende Privatisierung und die Ausbeutung der Bodenschätze des Landes durch ausländische Konzerne. Auch interessant, schreibt er hier, sie hat die Carta de Madrid unterschrieben. Die ist also eine Verteidigungskarta aller spanischsprachigen Länder gegen den Kommunismus. 2020 unterschreibt sie das, ja. Also der Kommunismus steht kurz vor der Tür. Initiiert wurde die Carta von Forum Madrid, einer Denkfabrik der extrem rechten Partei Spaniens Vox. Wer hat noch mit unterzeichnet? Melanie, Javier Millet und Jair Bolsonaro. Im September nahm Machado per Video an der Konferenz Europa Viva 25 teil. Das kennen wir. Das ist nämlich das Treffen von rechten Parteien, von Vox, Fidesz aus Ungarn, Rassemble National. Machado entrichtete da per Videowotschaft ihre wärmsten Grüße an die große Freunde. Bei der ersten Präsidentschaft von Trump zeigte sie sich als des treue Gefährtin. Jetzt in seiner zweiten Amtszeit unterstützt sie die harte Linie der amerikanischen Regierung auch gegen die eigenen Landsleute. Also es ist kein Wort von ihr bekannt, dass sie diese Abschiebungen kritisiert, die gerade USA vornimmt, wovon ja auch sehr viele Venezueler betroffen sind. Auch gegen diese völkerrechtswidrigen Attacken sagt sie nichts. Sie preist Trumps Unterstützung für Venezuela. Und da heißt es dann noch, es ist deshalb auch kein Wunder, dass Machado den Friedensnobelpreis nicht nur dem venezuelanischen Volk, sondern auch Donald Trump gewidmet hat.
Das steht ja auch direkt angerufen.
Mit anderen Worten, Trump hat schon den Preis gewonnen. Nur ein bisschen anders.
Ja, finde ich auch hochinteressant, wie man immer so New York Times Texte zum Thema, hoffentlich wird der nächste Papst nicht jetzt auch noch ein Amerikaner, weil der nächste Trump ja alles. Und dann hört der Heidtmann, okay, der nächste Papst ist ein Amerikaner. Und dann einen Tag später, er doch nicht so richtig. Und jetzt so, Trump hat den Friedensnobelpreis nicht bekommen. Naja, nicht so richtig nicht. Gut, kommen wir zu etwas Heiterem. Und wir müssen es ausdrücklich dazu sagen, das ist jetzt heiter. Wir reden über Peter Thiel und seine komischen Ideen. Also, der Guardian, ich verlinke es, hat zwei Texte dazu. Ich verlinke den einen, der von Adrian Daub ist, dann da mitverlinkt in diesem Text. Johanna Bujan, Dara Kier und Nick Robbins-Early haben sich mit Vorträgen von Peter Thiel beschäftigt, die er Mitte September bis jetzt Anfang Oktober gehalten hat. Wir haben ja schon über Mangols Ausführung gesprochen. Ich habe das alles Gemini gegeben und so. Ich frage Gemini, hier, wie sieht es aus? Gemini so, ja, das ist ja gespenstisch, was wir jetzt hier. Ich habe mal einen Audioclip gemacht aus einem Textauszug aus dieser Berichterstattung, die endet mit einem Original Wortlaut von Peter Thiel aus diesen, weil wir haben ja schon, bevor wir das von Mangold besprachen, schon über Peter Thiel gesprochen im Sinne von, der möchte einfach Zero to One für Unternehmen und dann möglichst viele so ab 400 plus starten, damit bloß kein Staat auf Augenhöhe kommt mit so einem Konzern. Peter Thiel, also es ist wirklich unglaublich, wie er selber eigentlich die ganze Idee von Religion nur noch aus instrumentellen Gründen für dieses eigentliche Ziel benutzt.
Er glaubt, dass das Armageddon von einer Antichrist-ähnlichen Figur eingeleitet wird, die die Angst vor existenziellen Bedrohungen wie Klimawande, KI und Atomkrieg schürt, um sich übermäßige Macht anzueignen. Die Idee ist, dass diese Figur die Menschen davon überzeugen wird, alles in ihrer Macht stehende zu tun, um etwas wie einen dritten Weltkrieg zu verhindern, vermeiden. Einschließlich der Akzeptanz einer Einweltordnung, die alle vor der Apokalypse schützen soll und eine vollständige Einschränkung des technologischen Fortschritts vorsieht. Seiner Meinung nach geschieht dies bereits. Thiel sagte, dass internationale Finanzinstitutionen, die es den Menschen erschweren, ihr Vermögen in Steueroasen zu schützen, ein Zeichen dafür sind, dass der Antichrist möglicherweise Macht anhäuft und das Armageddon beschleunigt und erklärte, es ist ziemlich schwierig geworden, sein Geld zu verstecken.
Der arme, arme Milliardär sieht den Antichristen heraufziehen und der Indikator dafür ist, er kann mein Geld nicht mehr vor dieser einen Weltregierung schützen.
Ja, also ich denke auch, das wird meine Reaktion sein, wenn nochmal das Finanzamt schreibt, dann sage ich einfach, das ist der Antichrist.
Sorry, aber der Antichrist, ja, im Grunde muss er nicht gegen den Antichristen werden. Man sieht hier wieder das globale Regime, die dir dein Geld nicht gönnen. Also es ist wirklich crazy. Er sagt übrigens auch, ich bin grundsätzlich immer für maximale Meinungsfreiheit, aber mein einziger konkreter Test ist, ob ich über den Antichristen sprechen kann. Wenn ich das nicht kann, dann ist es zu restriktiv. Also wenn wir einen insgesamt sehr instrumentellen Umgang mit all diesen Furlefanz, so im Sinne von, wie wollen wir die Bevölkerung zähmen und züchtigen? Wir machen ihnen wieder so eine Glaubensidee. Wir revitalisieren das einfach. Dann reden wir die ganze Zeit vom Antichristen. Warum? Weil wir daran erkennen, ob die uns hier blöd erklären oder nicht. Also wo der Körser steht. Wir möchten gerne über die Stränge schlagen. Wir bewegen bewusst, was ganz albern ist. Aber wenn es durchgeht, okay. Und inhaltlich unterfüttern wir dann den Antichristen mit dem globalen Regime, das halt bei uns Steuern eintreibt. Toll, das ist die ganze Idee. So, und er hat das in vier Vorlesungen gemacht. Thiels Worte. Die Vereinigung der Welt unter einem globalen Staat ist im Grunde identisch mit dem Antichristen. Eine Welt oder keine ist im gewissen Sinne dasselbe wie die Frage Antichrist oder Armageddon. Kannten wir soweit aus diesem Gespräch, dass er da mit Ross Dingster-Bums in der New York Times geführt hat. Er kommt auf die Legionäre des Antichristens zu sprechen. Wir haben schon über Greta Thunberg gesprochen. Er nennt hier einen weiteren. Elisier Judkowski. Den kennen wir auch schon aus der Behandlung mit KI. Denn der hat eigentlich das Dingsbild, was Nick Bostrom dann aufgegriffen hat, mit die KI wird uns übernehmen, die Büroklammer-Idee.
Genau.
Ich möchte sehr empfehlen, dieser Elisier Judkowski, der uns in diesen Büchern erklärt wird, so ein bisschen wie bei Dave Eggers, dieser Gründer von dem Circle-Unternehmen, der nur noch so durch die Gänge schwebt, so postheroisch, der ist eigentlich gar nicht da, so ein Mysterium irgendwie. So wird er ja auch in diesen KI-Büchern, da in den beiden beschrieben. Den gibt es aber wirklich und der war jetzt bei Hardfork im Podcast und redet da mit den beiden. Während ja Kevin Ruse, wie wir finden, schon so ein bisschen sehr Mainstreaming ist, geht ja Newton schon so mehr auch mal in diese etwas aufgeklärte Richtung, auch bei Charlie Kirk und so. Und das ist hochinteressantes Gespräch. Also Hardfork mit Elisier, Eliza, wie auch immer, Judkowsky, das kann ich euch empfehlen. Außerdem wird ja natürlich ganz groß dann von Thiel über den Kattichon geredet. Ich frage mich immer, sagt er in dieser Einvorlesung, was nach 1945 in der Welt als Kattichon fungiert. Eine vorläufige Antwort ist, dass der Kattichon 40 Jahre lang, von 49 bis 89, der Antikommunismus war. Also wieder so ein Ende der Geschichte. Was ist jetzt eigentlich hier? Und Amerika sieht er derzeit in dieser Doppelrolle, sowohl als potenziellen Kattichon als auch als potenziellen Antichrist. Also es könnte sowohl der Antichrist im Sinne von er unterstützt, dass eine Weltregime im Sinne von Joe Biden macht internationale Bande und so. Und dann kommt aber Donald Trump und sagt, nee, nichts hier mit internationaler Bande. Wir zerstören sowohl die Thais nach außen als auch die Institutionen innen. Also wir sind diejenigen, die das neue römische Reich, das in der Bibel erwähnt wurde, aber jetzt immer 2000 Jahre später, abräumt. Und dadurch ist noch unklar, ob jetzt Amerika der Kathechon oder der Antichrist selbst ist. Mit solchen Fragen kann man sich beschäftigen. Also es ist wirklich Herr Mangold. Ich bin dann auch sehr gespannt, was ich demnächst in der sogenannten Gegenwart höre. Außerdem geht er sehr auf die Charlie Kirk Trauerfeier ein, so wie wir auch, bei genau diesen Themen hier. Denn er sieht hier sowohl ein incredibly sämtliche Frau Kirk, die eben sagt, ah nee, also Jesus war im Grunde das Vorbild für meinen Charlie und Charlie ist im Grunde der Nachfolge von Jesus. Also Charlie vergibt und deswegen vergebe ich auch, wie auch immer. Und dann kommt er aber direkt danach Trump, der sagt, nee, hier wird nicht vergeben, wir hassen unsere Feinde. Und das verbindet jetzt Peter Thiel mit diesem, seht ihr, es begegnet uns wieder, und zwar in völlig säkularisierter Kleidung, aber es ist im Grunde diese religiöse, also diese Theologie, die da drin steckt. Und wir haben das ja auch schon bei diesen Erlösungstheologen oder was auch immer da in Peru und so, die also gesagt haben, nee, nee, das begegnet uns überall wieder. Also wenn du ein iPhone kaufst, ist das ein, was wir auch immer begehren, wo es herkommt, wie auch immer, und du musst dann da zahlen.
Bei den Befreiungstheologen.
Befreiungstheologen, genau. So, also wir haben es mit einer, und deswegen nutzt Thiel das ja auch, totalen Säkularisierung, aber eben dieser Idee zu tun. Die kommt einfach nur in diesen neuen Begriffen wieder, und das erkennt er halt da bei Donald Trump und so. Was haben wir hier noch? Sehr raffinierte Pointen. Der Antichrist kommt nicht als offensichtlicher Zerstörer, das so verwenden wir immer den Antichristen, sondern wir haben das ja jetzt eingebettet in dieses, der Christ, die Rückkehr des Christus ist nur, wenn eine Erlösung wirklich vonnöten ist. Also muss der Antichrist möglichst böse daherkommen und ja, aber eigentlich das Gute schafft, aber das schlechte will und so. Diese ganze Idee, also der Antichrist, den wir immer als, ja, das ist der, der alles zerstört und so weiter. Nein, der kommt ja als Verführer, der die Angst vor der Apokalypse nutzt und sagt, ihr wollt doch auch nicht am Klimawandel sterben, ihr wollt doch auch nicht von der KI und so weiter. Also kommt in diesem Mantel des Schäfchens.
Deswegen Kreatur Tunberg, die große Mahnerin.
Genau, genau, genau.
Die will er uns gar nicht retten.
Genau, er hat aber besondere Angst vor Tunberg, weil er sich auch Gedanken macht, wie sieht der Antichrist eigentlich aus? Und er stellt dann fest, er müsste sehr jung und sehr reich sein. Also er betont häufiger diesen Vorlesungen. Deswegen auf den Originaltext bin ich sehr gespannt, wie Handlungsvermögen ein Geld macht. Das beeindruckt ihn selber immer wieder. Plötzlich sitzt man beim Präsidenten am Tisch, plötzlich geht das und das und so. Das Geld Handlungsvermögen verspricht, findet er sehr beeindruckend immer noch. Und man muss jung sein, denn man muss ja in einer Lebenszeit schaffen, das antichristliche Werk der eine Welt Regierung herzustellen. Und da hat der Creator Thunberg gesehen. Also es gibt entweder super Reiche oder super Junge, und die Thunberg ist super jung. Reich kann man ja noch werden, aber wenn man alt ist, wird man nicht wieder jung und so. Solche Gedanken. Deswegen Thunberg als die große, da muss man ja aufpassen und so. Und hochinteressant finde ich den Text, das könnten sich dann auch Politikwissenschaftler mal anschauen. Diese vierte Vorlesung heißt Das neue Rom. Das alte Rom als Kartechon, das schon in der Bibel erwähnt wird. Das neue Rom in dieser Doppelfunktion. Ist es das neue Rom oder das Anti-Rom? Das Amerika, das wir gegenwärtig sehen, ist natürlich immer problematisch, wenn alle vier Jahre neuer Präsident gewählt wird und so, weil dann pendelt das ja da immer hin und her. Und er sieht aber gar nicht China oder so. Also China kommt jetzt hier gar nicht vor. Und ich habe ja auch diese Antichrist-Idee, dass dieses ganze Durcheinander, diese völlig inhärent unlogische Idee von Maga und so, eigentlich von China verursacht wird, die sich ja auch Gedanken machen. Also die Amerikaner, wenn wir uns jetzt mal genau anschauen, wie kriegen wir die? Mit Religiosität, mit Reformwillen und mit der Staat muss sparen. Also binden wir das alles mal zusammen und machen ganz TikTok voll von solchen Videos. Dann erklären dir irgendwelche Leute, dass du unabhängig vom Staat reich werden musst mit Bitcoin. Andere erzählen dir, die Bürokratie steht im Weg. Der andere sagt, die Ausländer sind und so. Und dann bildet sich so ein Maga irgendwas. Und das Allerglückste, was man noch sagen kann, ist, ja, da gibt es so viel Strömung und die müssen immer wieder neu auskängeln, was so ist. Aber dass das eigentlich gar keine Logik hat, ist ja so verrückt. Also wird aber hier nicht gesehen. Adrian Daub macht dann zwei Punkte, die ich ganz interessant finde. Peter Thiel ist so fasziniert von Girard, von seinem Lehrer da in Stanford oder wo, der ihm dieses mimetische Begehren gelehrt hat, dass er irgendwann aufgehört hat, selber mal einen kreativen Gedanken zu finden, sondern nur noch nimmt, was halt so da liegt. Aber er cosplayt dann Girard. Deswegen auch diese Idee der Vorlesung. Warum hält Peter Thiel eine Vorlesung? Er will halt einfach der Gelehrte sein, der so am Rednerpult steht und so. Also finde ich nicht schlecht. Und Adrian Daub sagt dann, ja, das was Thiel hier liefert, findet er in den ganz klugen Bibliotheken. Aber am Ende kommt einfach nur ein Dan Brown raus.
Ja, genau.
Also die Mystik nochmal aufgreift irgendwie und er versucht so einen Cliffhanger daraus zu machen. Und Peter Thiel sagt jetzt hier, es ist Thiels Versuch, sich selbst aus der Gleichung seiner eigenen Machtanalyse herauszunehmen. Das finde ich sehr gut. Er möchte in einer Welt, die er selbst gestalten möchte, deswegen ja dieses nur die Unternehmer sollen entscheiden und so, möchte er sich selbst als ich bin hier nur Beobachter. Ich bin ja einfach nur ein Professor, der euch was erzählt und so. Das finde ich schon nicht schlecht. Daub schreibt, das Bild, das von Thiel in diesen Vorlesungen entsteht, ist das von jemanden, der verzweifelt versucht, sich von seiner eigenen Macht zu distanzieren. Und er kommt auf diesen Apocalypse Now, auf so ein Zitat, Ain't you running the world, Peter, if it isn't you, who is? Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das in diesem Film vorkommt, also müssen wir uns schon mal anschauen. Aber es hat ja auch meine Zeit im Vöter immer so geprägt, weil Schömerer, Lorenz Jäger, so zusammengefasst. Schömerer will einfach immer wissen, wer hier die Macht. Egal, was hier gerade Sache ist. Erst mal kurz Analyse, Meta und so weiter. Und dann, wer hat hier wessen Fäden in der Hand? Deswegen auch diese Obsession mit dem Silicon Valley und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist hier bei Peter Thiel auch. Peter Thiel macht hier die ganze Zeit, ich meine, der Christ, der Antichrist, der Kathechon und dann Trump, der große Aufhalter und so weiter und so fort. Das sind alles einfach nur ganz mächtige Leute. Der Christ ist mächtig, der kann uns erlösen, der Antichrist ist mächtig, der kann alles zerstören, der Kathechon ist mächtig, der kann nämlich die beiden aufhalten und so weiter und so fort. Also es wird alles nur an diesem Machtfragen-Ding. Also wir sind hier ganz weit weg von so einem, könnte man sein Leben nicht mal genießen, kann man sich nicht mal fragen, hat es Spaß gemacht, so. Ganz weit weg, also es ist wirklich nur, ist hier jemand noch mächtiger als ich? Also ich habe 10 Milliarden und sehr viel Einfluss. Ist noch jemand mächtiger als ich? Und dann haben wir so einen Pop Hans mit der Antichrist und die Einwelt-Regierung und die Greta Thunberg und so weiter und so was. Also es ist wirklich schlimm. Thiel hat die Sorgen der Welt, mit denen einer sehr elitären Gruppe alternder Tech-Unternehmer verwechselt, mit denen er verkehrt. Also das, was wir überall immer sehen. Das, was er abläuft, ist lächerlich. Es ist wirklich so lächerlich, das kann man Ihnen vorstellen. Es ist einfach nur nicht, also man muss es ernst nehmen, weil die halt über das Geld zu mächtig sind, wie Cory Dock darauf sagt. Aber von dem Geld mal abgesehen, ist das so unfassbar lächerlich. Man kann sich das nicht vorstellen.
Ja, es ist ganz erbärmlich auch. Und sie werden älter von Jahr zu Jahr. Sie haben gesehen, wie früh Steve Jobs gestorben ist und glauben natürlich auch, dass sie sich jetzt doch auf diese Art noch verewigen können. Wenn sie ja vielleicht selbst so eine Art Christusfigur sind oder was auch immer, dann möglicherweise spielt das alles keine Rolle mehr. Deswegen ja auch diese ganzen Ideen vom ewigen Leben, die sie da verfolgen. Sie können natürlich diese eigene Endlichkeit, die sie haben, trotz all der Milliarden nicht aushalten. Und es ist dann auch interessant, dass sie sich eigentlich der Macht zuwenden müssen, weil mit dem Geld allein und Steueroptimierungsmodelle oder so, dafür brauche ich ja keinerlei Transzendenz. Aber wenn ich hier über das andere nachdenke, dann benötige ich das ja.
Ja, also diese AI, nicht AI, diese All-In-Milliardäre, die diesen Podcast machen. Die haben ja diesen Firmchef auf der Bühne begrüßt, dem sie erstmal erzählen, wow, durch deine Abnehmensspritze hat der 30 Kilo verloren, der 20 und ich auch 10. So, vielen Dank erstmal so, ne? Und gestern haben die den Podcast veröffentlicht mit Brian Johnson. Also mit diesem Typen, der einfach seinen Blueprints... Long-Javity-Typ, der gesündeste Mensch der Welt, so, ne? Und man guckt den aber allen in die Augen, also sowohl diesen Brian Johnson als auch Peter Thiel und so weiter. Man denkt sich so, du siehst nicht gesund aus.
Nee. Also Peter Thiel sieht nicht gesund aus. Warum glänzt er immer wie eine Speckschwarte?
Der ist auch so verknöchert und irgendwas und so. Irgendetwas stimmt da nicht, ja? Irgendetwas stimmt mit diesen Leuten.
Zum Schluss Musik von Georg Philipp Telemann, ein Zeitgenosse von Johann Sebastian Bach. Eine ganze Weile lang unterschätzt, aber inzwischen wird er doch sehr häufig im Repertoire gespielt. Hier gibt es eine schöne Begebenheit. Ich war vor über einem Jahr in Darmstadt, dort im Theater. Die haben da auch so eine Barockfestreihe. Dort spielte die Akademie für Alte Musik Berlin mit der wunderbaren Geigerin Isabelle Faust, die ja hier schon häufiger Erwähnung fand. Und das, was sie dort gespielt haben, das gibt es jetzt bei Harmonia Mundi, endlich auf CD bzw. auf den Streaming-Plattformen. Und ich kann das sehr empfehlen, den Ouvertüren-Suiten Fantasien von Telemann. Es ist wunderbar deshalb, weil es ein Komponist ist, der Ironie beherrscht. Man wundert sich über diese Einfälle, die er mitunter hat, wie er auch die Konventionen aufgreift und sie dann auch persifilieren kann. Vor allem ist es ein Komponist, der Naturlaute mit dem Orchester nachstellen kann. So gibt es hier ein Konzerto, das ein Froschkonzert ist. Das heißt, wir hören da tatsächlich, wie Instrumente Frösche nachahmen. Ganz beeindruckend. Es ist ein Komponist, der sich sehr mühelos beim französischen und italienischen Stil der Zeit bedient. Und es ist ein Komponist, der virtuos mit dem Kontrapunkt umgehen kann und der auch neue Klänge entwickelt. Also man hat bei vielen den Eindruck, zum Beispiel jetzt gerade das Konzert nach dem Froschkonzert, also die Suite.
Heißt das Froschkonzert?
Das heißt Concerto, The Frogs, beziehungsweise die Rehlinge. Das ist also eine besondere Art von Fröschen. Und dann gibt es eine Suite, Goliaths Travels. Das ist auch wunderbar, weil wir dort sehen, wie hören können, wie ein Instrument noch klingen kann, wie ein Orchester Klänge erzeugt, bei denen man sagt, eigentlich kann das doch nicht mehr in der Harmonie aufgelöst werden. Wo bin ich hier schon fast im 20. Jahrhundert angekommen oder wo? Und dann geschieht das aber doch. Also ich finde es ganz erstaunlich, wie er neue Klangwelten entstehen lässt. Man ist also laufend überrascht. Es gibt Dialoge mit Trompete und Violine. Auch das ist hervorragend gespielt. Also ich muss sagen, es ist eine ganz wunderbare Aufnahme mit tollen Kompositionen. Wenn wir sehen, wie weit er sich harmonisch vor war, kann man gar nicht glauben, dass das im 18. Jahrhundert geschehen ist. Aber es gibt natürlich noch andere Komponisten, die das auch konnten. Aber ich finde hier, es ist so mustergültig umgesetzt. Isabelle Faust sowieso eine brillante Geigerin und hat hier ein großartiges Ensemble an ihrer Seite. Man hat viel Freude und ich wünsche viel Freude damit.
Sehr gut. Damit ist die September Lektüre abgehandelt.
In gewisser Weise ja. Dann bis Ende des Monats.
Yes, bis Ende des Monats. Da kommen wir auf alle schrecklichen Themen zurück.